Untertitelung des ZDF für funk, 2017
Titelung des ZDF für funk, 2017
euro.com punkt pl das sind den job was hier los okay dann nicht scamshops ja
also wenn mich mein adblock schon warnt auf diesen shop zu gehen dann weiß man
nicht was sache ist kommt bei geiz als eigentlich jeder shop rein oder sind
alle überprüft ich glaube nicht dass da groß ich ehrlich keine ahnung aber ich
glaube nicht dass die überprüft sind ich vermute mal du kannst dir einen shop
plugin installieren oder halt selbst machen je nachdem also für den online
shop den du verwendest und irgendein geiz als plugin gibt es gibt es
garantiert hier kommen nochmal shoppify shoppify geiz als das gibt es dann
garantiert zum zum enablen ja wahrscheinlich musste dann
wahrscheinlich musste geiz als dann irgendwie keine ahnung bisschen
reffling abdrücken oder so wahrscheinlich musste da einfach in einem
jeweiligen shop system in häkchen setzen export geiz hat geiz als oder so die
preisverlauf kurve die sieht wirklich aus
ja
the dogecoin gibt das eigentlich noch was ist der kurs von dogecoin ein doge
für ja das ist ja unglaublich viel wert als 2018 waren immer ein bisschen was
wert da hast du zumindest schon mal einen
halben cent quatsch naja aufgerundet sehr extrem aufgerundet die hälfte
du hast quasi die hälfte von einem hälfte cent gekriegt was ist denn
so gerade die angesicht habe ich verfolgt das überhaupt nicht was ist da
so die angesagte währung immer noch bitcoin ja klar ist das ist das was
cristiano ronaldo bei sich auf der webseite gemeint hat das ist schon ein
zwei jahre her die also es war die webseite von cristiano ronaldo her
ob der das selbst gemacht hat habe ich so meiner zweifel ehrlich gesagt
wahrscheinlich einige ab admins oder das light coim
Es ist gar nicht, ob das litecoin oder ethereum war, was der gemeint hat und zumindest
Wahrscheinlich waren die admins einfach besonders besonders clever und haben gedacht, wir machen einfach einen javascript
Einfach einen javascript ethereum miner drauf, weil ich meine die website von cristiano ronaldo wird öfters mal besucht
Eigentlich ist das eine richtig gute idee
Einfach 20 milliarden webseiten machen und überall bitcoin miner drauf installieren
Und dann musst du noch irgendwie, was heißt nur, nur, du musst nur die leute irgendwie drauf bekommen auf die webseiten und drauf bleiben
Was china link, ah nee, chain link
China link
price
Was ist der höchste price?
Wrapped bitcoin, was, warum gibt es
was zum
Warum gibt es
Warum gibt es dreimal bitcoins
Und was ist, was ist
Yarnfinance
Ist es der rubel bitcoin oder was ist das was was ist das ich blicke da so überhaupt nicht durch was was
Krypto währung angeht er ist der wahnsinn
Maker die gehen zumindest gut ab hier
Yarnfinance
Jvv jfi
Source code reddit
Was zum teufel ist das?
Schon nie gehört
Exzellent, egal, machen wir jetzt zu, juckt jetzt nicht weiter, übrigens soll ich euch mal was soll ich euch mal was was nice ist zeigen
Mal gucken ob das video hier wieder weiter verarbeitet hat
Nope, immer noch nicht
Soll ich mal was sagen
Ich habe wieder wieder von meinem klo aufgenommen auf twitter
Allerdings nicht wirklich vom klo
Sondern ich habe nfc tags für mich entdeckt und zwar passt mal auf dass das ist auch exzellent
big brain finde ich
Oder wettbewerbs kennt hier mit crypto währung aus
Das hier
Massive brain
So choose my name is joshu
Und dann sagt mal eine noob frage wenn ich einen telekom router mit 300 mbit netz habe und dann
Einen gigabit switch dran mache und da wiederum pc und nas kriegen dann pc und nas eine ip aber ja ja ja klar
Das ist dem egal
Das ist das ist denen egal das wichtig ist was du für den link kriegst am jeweiligen endgerät und was der switch dazwischen kann
Also wenn du pc und nas an den gigabit switch steckst dass dir das juckt die überhaupt nicht wie schnell dann ab link ist
Da könnte auch in 56k modem dranhängen das ist egal
Aber passt mal auf hier ich habe nämlich nfc tags für mich entdeckt
Und ich habe mir gedacht warum sollte ich nicht nfc tags ein bisschen in meine heimautomatisierung einbauen
auf
die leise
leise
Wahrscheinlich wird er sagen jetzt spinnt er
Das würde das würde nie einer sagen oder
so
nie einer sagen dass er spinnt
Wo kommen wir denn da hin?
Hallo jungs und mädels hier ist der max
Und die meisten werden wahrscheinlich jetzt wieder sagen jetzt spinnt er jetzt spinnt er wieder rum
Ich habe gestern schon auf twitter geschrieben ich habe den großen vorteil von nfc tags entdeckt
Und ja ich war hier gerade auf dem klo und habe ich mir gedacht ich nehme das jetzt einfach mal auf wie toll das funktioniert
Ja zumindest hier im bad wie zum beispiel heute morgen ist mir aufgefallen ich bin ins bad gegangen und hier ist relativ kühl ich habe ja
Da so ein heizhaus stehen aber ihr seht es ja da kommt
Das funktioniert nicht da kommt man nicht dran
Jetzt habe ich mir an der stelle hier
Ein nfc tag hinbekommen passt mal auf ich nehme ein iphone halters dran
ist das nicht nice und wieder aus
Wie da und jetzt das ich mal habe ich auf dem klo warm
ohne dass ich auf warum fokussiert das nicht
Wohin das ist hier ein heizer gehen muss kann ich einfach weil ich habe immer ein handy immer dabei einfach nfc tag scannt das ganze funktioniert nur
weil ich hier neben noch diese steckdose dran habe und das ist eine steckdosenleiste die habe
ich geflasht mit custom firmware das heißt das ganze funktioniert so ich scanne den nfc tag
mit meinem also das geht nur mit dem mit dem neuen iphone und ich scanne den nfc tag und
dann geht das ganze über home assistant also das ist meine heimautomatisierungslösung schickt es
ein event über shortcuts an home assistant und home assistant löst dann hier wireless über das
wlan das event an dieser tasmota steckdose aus die kennt ihr noch die steckdose die haben wir
zusammen hier im im stream ich weiß nicht geflasht haben also nicht zusammen im stream aber wir haben
ich glaube das motor irgendwie darauf eingereicht oder so ganz einzuschalten und wieder auszuschalten
natürlich man kann auch man kann da auch
natürlich von hand drauf drücken dass es ausgeht so ist das natürlich nicht ich weiß auch nicht
warum ich das jetzt aufgenommen hat aber so sieht es aus bis dahin macht's gut ist das nice also
ich finde das ist eines der besten sachen die ich so heimautomatisierungstechnik also ein einfaches
eines der praktischsten ich habe jetzt auch ein nfc tag trüben im schlafzimmer und wenn ich das
handy also das geht nur mit dem neuen iphone das alte hat ja noch kein nfc und wenn ich drüben ich
lege das immer nebenbei nebenbei nebenbei nebenbei nebenbei nebenbei nebenbei nebenbei nebenbei nebenbei nebenbei
im bett ab und wenn ich das handy quasi auf den nfc tag lege im bett dann und ich habe irgendwas
vergessen auszuschalten dann geht's aus also sprich dort wo ein motor in den rollläden drunter drin ist
geht die rollläden runter dort wo ich irgendwas vergessen habe auszuschalten und das an irgendeiner
steckdose hängt die man ausschalten kann wird ausgeschaltet und das licht wobei das noch nicht
so 100 pro funktioniert das licht im schlafzimmer geht auf gelb ich habe jetzt ja rgb beleuchtung
für mich entdeckt auch noch
ich habe lange zeit einen bogen gemacht um smart lightning lighting oder und rgb beleuchtung und
sowas aber mittlerweile komme ich da langsam auf den geschmack und dann geht das licht im
schlafzimmer noch auf gelb und geht dann so nach zehn minuten oder so ist gar nicht was ich genau
eingestellt habe geht es dann so langsam über zehn minuten oder fünf minuten fädelt das dann so aus
ja das ist sehr nah ist also aktuell habe ich diese sachen hier als smart
habe ich hiervon ein paar als smart lampe wobei das hier viel viel zu teuer ist btf genau das
das geht aber weil man hat echt sagen muss geht mal 50 euro geht mal 50 euro von der glühbirne aus
aber die sind auch die sind schön hell also die haben gute farben und die sind schön hell wenn
man rgb braucht wenn man kein rgb braucht kriegt man das ganze auch deutlich günstiger da kann man
nämlich sowas hier zum beispiel nehmen dann bezahlt man nur ach nee nee schwachsinn das
ist auch dies auch mit rgb ne dies weiß genau also es gibt die großen von denen die haben 1200 lumen
und rgb und alles du kannst also dinge sind wirklich nicht übel also weil es halt auch
teuer ich mal geht mal 50 euro für eine für die glühbirne aus ja glühbirne ist ja keine glühbirne
50 euro für lampen sei ich viel zu übertrieben aber die haben rgb die haben auch die haben
eine weiße dimmbare weiße led also sprich du musst nicht die farben rein aus rgb mission du
kannst die farben auch aus aus weiß plus rgb mission was natürlich viel praktischer ist die
sind über wlan diese dieses das ist wifi da ist das ist kein sieg wie diese philips hüdinger die
auch so beliebt sind die gehen ja über sieg wie zum beispiel aber ein paar sieg die lampen will
ich mir auch noch hinhängen weil es das dick wie nett mesh netzwerk erweitert ja genau davon habe
ich auch noch welche
und da die gibt es auch in einer variante entweder komplett weiß dimmbar weiß und und quasi licht
weiß farbe das ist im prinzip wahrscheinlich noch eine rote led mit dabei und komplett rgb
wobei es ja eigentlich rgb w ist oder wie heißt das rgb w also quasi rot grün blau weiß also
sprich man hat nicht nur drei farben aus dem man alles mitnehmen kann sondern man hat auch
eine weiße was was die sache besser macht insgesamt b 22 das ist dieses übrigens wer sich
fragt b 22 dieser komische sockel da wird in indien verwendet warum das hier angeboten weiß
ich ob man irgendjemand leute das hier haben aber es geht es geht auch ein bisschen günstiger bezahlt
man quasi dann nur 27 wenn man weil die wenigsten leute brauchen wahrscheinlich ja gut iphone 7 6
was soll jetzt sagen genau ja also die wenigsten leute brauchen ja überall rgb rgb ist ja so ein
ding das machst du dir vielleicht mal was ich dort wurde im wohnzimmer wo man fernsehen guckt oder
irgendwie sowas aber normalerweise reicht eigentlich dimmbar und hellig also dimmbar
und weiß wie heißt das also die farbe wie wie wie warm und kalt weiß ist
kann man noch einstellen schon mal die leute angeschaut ja die sind auch nicht verkehrt die
sind eine ecke günstiger habe ich aber keins aber es nimmt sich nicht viel aber hier kriegst du halt
komplette sache für die hälfte mit rgb aber diese live ex oder wie man das heißt dinge sind gut und
und wisst ihr was wisst ihr was an diese dinge mega scheiße ist so richtig beschissen das ist
die app war aber gar nicht mal wegen der app an sich sondern aus einem anderen grund also
ihr wisst ja ich verwende die offiziellen apps war sowas nicht ja ich habe das alles bei mir in
die heimat automatisierung eingebunden ohne ohne irgendwelche offiziellen apps aber was
richtig kacke in der app ist also falls irgendjemand vor hat die zu kaufen und die einzurichten bei sich
das braucht einen kleinen trick den habe ich auch nirgends wo gesehen denn da muss sich selbst muss
sich selbst drauf kommen dass das nicht also genau also wenn man nämlich die app einrichtet
also wenn man eine lampe in der app einrichtet dann was ich ob die hier irgendwo dieしく stets
ja ich nicht wirklich ja zumindest wenn man wenn man das einrichtet ist es so die app möchte von
einem unbedingt dass man ein account anlegt obwohl man die lampen eigentlich offline verwenden kann
was ziemlicher fälle ist dementsprechend habe ich mir einen account vorgenommen auf auf dem app information d Sora und疠
wandСильи spare 착amping candene one dsara im not courts und wir möchten desqueet also wirklich
sehr viel library massag credibility bw als es mitignant duc Frust rank ich finde das ist thought so While we are learning Dragon Ball board time
account angelegt aber ich will es ja gar nicht verwenden also und was man jetzt
machen kann in der app ist folgendes man kann die lampe enden und dann kommt
dann so einen pop-up ob ich da irgendwie ob ich euch wieder dann kommt dann
kommen die krassen hacker man moves genau hier hier sieht was also da muss
ich erst mal anmelden gut weil man sie überall anmelden muss weil das heute
standard ist dann sagt man neue lampe zufügen ok ok ok genauso und dann kommt
dieses menü hier wo drin steht man soll man soll jetzt quasi die lampe
einschalten und sich verbinden das problem ist wenn man das mit einem
iphone machen will dann ist das iphone der meinung man
möchte unbedingt homekit verwenden das ist diese diese apple smart home
geschichte weil es gibt keine möglichkeit nicht homekit zu verwenden
und selbst wenn mich hier unten drauf klickt das funktioniert nicht weil es
weil
die ganzen aktuellen lampen die verwenden nur homekit also dieses
my life doesn't support homekit ist gar nicht mehr der fall nur homekit soll ich
verwende kein homekit ich will auch der app keine berechtigung für homekit geben
und ich will auch kein homekit home anlegen nur um eine wlan lampe enden zu
können so und einfach enden über homekit ohne
homekit zu haben geht nicht weil dann resetet sich die lampe was man jetzt aber
machen kann das ist übelst übelst big brain man muss die lampe einmal factory resetten
factory resetten tut man die lampe in dem man fünf mal hintereinander schnell ein
und ausschaltet also an aus klick klick klick klick dann leuchtet die lampe
irgendwie grün blau gelb mal kurz und da weiß man dass ich factory resetten so
danach macht man sie aus macht sie noch mal an und lässt sie 15 minuten an wenn
man die lampe 15 minuten angelassen hat dann schaltet die sich in irgendeine
legacy mode und man kann sie ohne homekit adden weil sie dann ganz normalen wlan access point aufmacht
weil sie dann ganz normalen wlan access point aufmacht weil sie dann ganz normalen wlan access point aufmacht
und wenn du dann in diesen wlan access point reingehe ja allein schon wie
kompliziert dieses einmal und wenn du dann in diesen wlan access point reingehe
ist von der lampe dann erkennt die app das auch problem ist die app ist ohne
internetverbindung zu dumm die lampe richtig zu ändern was gut ist weil ich
connecte mich dann einfach zu einem wlan was ich temporär aufmache ohne
internetverbindung oder ich kann einfach den stecker rausziehen ist egal richte über die app
App die Lampe ein und dann sagt die Lampe, oh nein, could not add to App, aber die App
hat schon die richtigen WLAN-Settings in die Lampe kopiert, das heißt, die Lampe erscheint
nie in der App, normalerweise, ja genau, hier steht drin, wie es funktioniert, ohne Homekit,
ne, das ist mit Homekit hier, jetzt ist es ohne Homekit, normalerweise sollte die Lampe
dann hier drin sein, aber so weit kommt das nicht, aber die App hat die Credentials fürs
WLAN in die Lampe gesetzt, das heißt, danach kann ich einfach der App wieder alle Berechtigungen
entziehen und die Lampe hängt im WLAN und wenn die Lampe im WLAN hängt, dann kann ich
die LiveX, wie auch immer, Integration von Home Assistant verwenden und schreibe,
einfach hier unten die IP von der Lampe rein, ich gucke dann einfach in meinem Router ins
DHCP, was die Lampe für eine Adresse gekriegt hat, mache eine statische Reservierung und
trage dann die statische Sache hier ein im Home Assistant und dann habe ich die Lampe
drin.
Ja, diese Auto-Discovery übrigens funktioniert auch nicht, normalerweise sollten die Dinger
eigentlich per Broadcast discovered werden, die Lampen werden sie nicht, weil ich bin
ja, mein Home Assistant ist ja ein ganz anderes Netz wie das IoT.
Deswegen muss man die IP direkt da angeben, aber die machen es einem schon ganz schön
schwer, aber nichtsdestotrotz muss ich sagen, die Dinger machen wirklich qualitativ einen
ziemlich guten Eindruck bisher.
Es ist absolut nicht benutzerfreundlich.
So, hat unser Video eigentlich verarbeitet jetzt?
Ne, gibt es nicht.
Exzellent, mal schauen.
So, was wollte ich jetzt noch sagen?
Irgendwas wollte ich noch loswerden.
Achso, warte mal, es hat noch einer was gefragt, wo ich was zu sagen wollte.
Ähm, genau.
Ja, beheizte Klositze hat er leider nicht, aber beheiztes Wasser.
Irgendjemand hat doch was gefragt, vor allem, genau.
Also, äh, gibt es unter Linux eine Möglichkeit die Platte zu verschlüsseln, auf dem das
OS ist?
Bei Windows kann man das einfach machen.
Äh, gibt's?
Am besten ist, du verwendest eine Distribution, die das im Installer schon kann und für dich
macht.
Also, das kann so ziemlich jede halbwegs verbreitete Distribution.
Unter der Haube ist es eine Lux-Verschlüsselung, ja, aber, ähm, das musst du nicht selbst
machen.
Das kann man eigentlich.
Das kann man eigentlich während dem Installer auswählen, in der Regel.
Das nachträglich selbst zu machen, ist nicht so einfach.
Am besten ist, man macht es während der Installation, direkt voll verschlüsseln.
Aber das ist dann so wie in Veracrypt, also sprich, du musst beim Booten ein Passwort angeben,
dass es, äh, überhaupt anlockt und weiterbootet.
Ist eigentlich genauso.
Also, das ist dann wirklich voll verschlüsseln, egal wo was liegt.
Komplett, äh, ohne Passwort geht nichts mehr.
Der Nachteil ist aber auch, wenn du das Passwort vergisst, du hast gelitten.
Das ist ja bei Veracrypt auch so.
Wenn du bei Veracrypt dein Passwort vergisst, hast du Pech.
Da bringt dir auch die Recovery-CD nix.
Die Recovery-CD bei Veracrypt oder USB-Stick bringt dir nur was, wenn du das Passwort
noch weißt, aber die Festplatte irgendwie beschädigt ist.
Also keine Chance, wenn du es vergisst.
Aber so muss das auch sein.
Das ist auch das, warum ich kein Vertrauen irgendwie in BitLocker hab, weil bei BitLocker
hieß es ja mal, du kannst quasi, wenn du das Passwort vergessen hast, das recovern.
Und jede Verschlüsselung, die es dir irgendwie erlaubt, zu recoveren.
Wenn du dein Passwort vergessen hast, ist kacke.
Da stimmt ja irgendwas nicht.
Dann hast nicht nur du den Schlüssel haben, muss noch jemand anderes den Schlüssel haben,
weil sonst könntest du es nicht recovern.
Ja, deswegen bei mir gibt es nur Lux Encryption oder Veracrypt.
Was aber auch, was aber auch eine Idee ist, gar keine Vollverschlüsselung zu machen,
sondern nur Heimatverzeichnis.
Also du musst nicht, also wenn du sagst, hey, ich mach eh nur die interessanten Sachen in meinem Home,
dann kannst du auch einfach nur dein Home verschlüsseln.
Und das Ganze auch nur auf Dateibasis.
Das ist ein bisschen einfacher und kann man nachträglich ohne Probleme machen.
So, exzellent.
So, was guckt man jetzt?
Was haben wir zur Auswahl?
Huge Update Home Datacenter.
Irgendwie noch mehr Datacenter.
Was wie Elon Musk unser Gehirn aufrüsten will.
Feed kurz...
Oh, die zwei zusammen.
Exzellent.
Doppel Linus haben wir hier.
Einmal den originalen Linus und einmal hier den Fake Linus.
Haha.
Battlefield 6 News, was haben wir sonst noch, Raspberry...
Das Ding ist übel, das, ich wollte mir das mal angucken, weil ich halte das Ding für total sinnlos.
Das ist irgend so ein Teil, wo man den Raspberry Pi in eine Tastatur einbauen kann,
wo ich den Sinn überhaupt nicht verstehe von.
Kann man auch ein Tablet nehmen.
So.
Äh, das ist eine gute Frage, Pflanze400.
Er schreibt, ich wollte meine Backups auf meinen Server schieben.
Kannst du mir sagen, womit ich es am besten verschlüsseln kann und was sicher ist?
Möchte nicht, dass da jemand...
Außer mir draufschauen kann.
Da gibt's, gibt's verschiedenste Möglichkeiten für.
Ich verwende das hier.
Ich verwende das.
Äh, jup, das hier.
Das finde ich am besten, ist aber ein bisschen gewöhnungsbedürftig von der Bedienung.
Das ist ein reines Kommandozeilenprogramm.
Hat aber alles, was man sich wünscht von einem Backup-Programm.
Also sprich, du kannst inkrementelle Backups machen, du kannst Deed-Application machen, du kannst Encryption machen, du kannst...
Du kannst quasi alles machen, was du dir...
...wünschst von, äh, hier steht's ja genau, ähm, du machst, äh, Encryption, du machst Compression, du machst Deed-Application, so, und du kannst das dementsprechend auch relativ einfach synchen.
Ich hab einen Vee-Server bei einem Hoster.
Ja, Moment, willst du den Vee-Server backuppen zu dir heim?
Oder willst du auf den Vee-Server was backuppen?
Also, wenn du auf den Server was backuppen willst, ist, ist Borg-Backup wunderbar.
Borg-Backup geht sogar weiter.
Backup geht sogar umso besser, dass, wenn's in Linux auf der anderen Seite ist.
Ja, auf dem Server dort, ja.
Dann machst du dein Lokales über SSH, schiebst du dahin.
Also, das ist die eine Sache, die ist nicht so...
...ohne vielleicht für jemand, der jetzt nicht so Kommandozeilen-affin ist.
Aber das ist das beste Backup-Programm.
Was natürlich immer geht, ist...
...irgendwie nen Truecrypt-Volume.
Das Problem ist nur, wenn du nen Truecrypt-Volume machst, das lässt sich schlecht synchen.
Weil das immer so aussieht, als hat sich das komplette Volume geändert.
Die nächste Variante ist, du machst Datei.
Also, wie gesagt, ich find das hier am besten.
Wenn man das einmal aufgesetzt hat, ist das ziemlich easy zu verwenden.
Und man kann's auch erst mal lokal einrichten und gucken, wie's funktioniert.
Ach ja, und du kannst es dann auch nicht lesen auf dem Server, ne?
Also, sprich, du kannst das backuppen.
Du kannst dein Backup quasi über Borg, über SSH auf den Server schieben.
Dann hast du zwar dort ein Repo, aber das kann ohne den Key keiner mehr lesen.
Also, das ist komplett dedupliziert und verschlüsselt.
So, ähm...
Du kannst aber auch Datei-basiert machen, so was wie eng.fs oder so.
Dass die Sachen bei dir schon lokal...
Oder, oder, hier, was gibt eng.fs?
E-crypt.fs sind also die zwei Sachen, die es gibt.
Da kannst du die Dateien lokal bei dir verschlüsseln.
Und dann kannst du die quasi ganz normal synchen über irgendwie Dropbox oder so.
Aber ehrlich gesagt, ich würd mir Borg-Backup angucken.
Das ist vom Gesamtpaket her, find ich, das beste Backup-Programm, was es gibt.
Ja, wie sinnvoll...
Ein V-Server ist für Storage da einmal dahingestellt, weil die günstigen...
Das stimmt schon, was Maxris sagt.
Weil die günstigen V-Server, die sind jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig bestückt mit Storage.
Wobei, es gibt die ein oder anderen Storage-Boxes, wo man dann sogar so eine gesharete IPv4 bekommt mit NAT davor.
Die sind teilweise schon relativ günstig.
Ja.
Gibt's, gibt's ein paar.
Da muss man mal schauen, wo man günstig was bekommt.
Amazon Anleger.
Amazon Unlimited gibt's ja leider nicht mehr.
Sind nicht mehr Unlimited, nachdem dieser Typ sein Webcam-Pornarchiv da drauf gelegt hat und festgestellt hat, dass Amazon Unlimited doch nicht Unlimited ist.
Ist aber auch, ist schon ein bisschen her.
Da gab's doch diesen Typ, der so ein Programm, der das programmiert hat, dass quasi die ganzen Camgirl-Live-Sessions mitgeschnitten werden und auf Amazon hochgeladen werden.
Weil der wollte testen.
Also sein Ziel war, er wollte testen, ob Amazon Unlimited wirklich Unlimited ist.
So, da ist natürlich das Problem.
Um das zu testen, musst du erst mal überlegen, wie du petabyteweise Daten generieren kannst, ohne dass du sie selbst hochladen musst.
Also hat der Typ sich einen Server gemietet.
Hat einen, ich glaub, irgendein Python-Skript gebastelt, was quasi Webcam-Girl, Webcam-Porn-Girls-Sessions, Shows mitschneidet.
Und auf Amazon hochlädt.
Und da war er halt auf petabyteweise Amazons-Deutsch gekommen, bis dann irgendwann Amazon gesagt hat, okay, wir ändern jetzt unseren Plan, das ist nicht mehr Unlimited.
Der Typ selbst hat noch Unlimited bekommen, aber alle anderen haben kein Unlimited mehr gekriegt.
Ich hab ja ehrlich gesagt die Vermutung, dass Amazon selbst den Typ auf Unlimited gelassen hat, weil die sich das selbst angucken wollen.
Da haben die Amazon-Admins gesagt, ey, warum sollen wir das Archiv löschen?
Wir sind doch nicht blöd.
Und deswegen darf der Unlimited bleiben.
So, also gucken wir mal irgendein Video.
Excellent.
Mit was fangen wir denn jetzt an hier?
Datacenter, links Linus, Battlefield, was gucken wir uns denn?
Battlefield 4, Rambo Moments.
Wir können uns auch die News zu Battlefield, zu Battlefield 6 angucken.
Wo ich da so meine Zweifel habe.
Dass das wahnsinnig viele News sind.
Auch wenn er schreibt, ja, es sind wirklich News.
So wirklich viele News gibt es dazu ja nicht.
Gucken wir mal, was es da Neues zu gibt.
Hey, we got some actual Battlefield 6 News.
It's not a...
Actual, actual Battlefield.
It's not a rumor, it's not a conspiracy theory.
This is real information about the next Battlefield game.
Yesterday EA had their quarterly earnings call and they revealed some details about the next Battlefield game that I wanted to share.
Der spricht also über Battlefields, sagt er immer.
I'll share with you guys, because I think this is quite interesting.
So getting straight into it, there's two sections really.
The first bit is a few comments from Andrew Wilson, who is the CEO of Electronic Arts.
And he said the following.
DICE is creating our next Battlefield game with never before...
Okay, das ist die Typ, das...
Oh Gott, das ist typisches Marketing-Geschwubbel, ey.
Painschamp.
Das ist...
Da gibt's ja überhaupt...
Das ist so...
So generic 0815-Marketing-Gelaber.
Creating our new...
Never seen before scale, ja.
Bla, bla, bla, bla.
... or seen scale.
The technical advancements of the new consoles are allowing the team to deliver a true next-gen vision for the franchise.
We have hands-on playtesting...
True next-gen vision.
Wisst ihr, was ich ja gut finde?
Diese ganzen Stonks-Leute, die haben...
Die haben Talent dafür, aus...
Sachen sich groß und wichtig anhören zu lassen.
Ohne wirkliche Aussagen zu treffen.
Ich mein, du kannst hier einen auf nichts festnageln, letztendlich, ne?
Never before seen scale kann alles bedeuten.
So, ähm...
Und dann sowas...
Die echte next-gen vision.
Das ist so absolut nichtssagend.
... under way internally.
And the team has been getting very positive feedback on the game as we've begun to engage our community.
Das ist so 0815-Gelaber, ey.
0815-Gelaber, Alter.
Hahaha.
Das sind doch die...
Letztendlich, ähm...
Also, dass die intern testen...
Ja, und das sollte ja mal vollkommen normal sein.
Dass sie das selbst, nach so langer Entwicklung oder wie lang auch immer das ist, ganz gut finden, wär ja auch blöd, wenn nicht.
Und ganz ehrlich, je nachdem, was sie da für Leute einladen...
... sind das wahrscheinlich eh die übelsten Arschkriecher, die alles geil finden und feiern.
Also, insofern, äh...
Ja, weiß ich nicht, was da rauskommt.
Holst du dir das neue Black Ops?
Ja, ich hab den Fehler gemacht und hab das tatsächlich vorbestellt.
Richtig dumm.
Dabei wollte ich mir das eigentlich gar nicht holen.
Richtig hängengeblieben, ey.
Ja, das ist ganz wichtig.
Also...
Ich...
Ich glaube, es ist wichtig für die Multiplayer, dass die Augen realistisch sich von links nach rechts bringen.
Ganz, ganz essenziell.
Ja, das hat man schon gesehen.
Ich, ganz ehrlich, ich bin da kein großartiger Fan von.
Mein Battlefield ist jetzt mit 32 gegen 32 jetzt wirklich nicht klein.
Und wenn das Ganze noch größer und noch mehr wird, ist halt die Frage, inwieweit sowas wie Rush überhaupt sich sinnvoll spielen lässt auf den Maps.
Also, kommt drauf an.
Das ist die offizielle Schlussfolgerung, die ich davon machen würde.
Ich sage nicht, dass ich richtig bin.
Ich würde nur sagen, dass es sich um das Detail des Spiels handelt.
Den Niveau der Zerstörung.
Allerlei Sachen.
Es ist ein bisschen vage.
Das ist auf Grundlage.
Aber für mich ist das...
Was ist...
Es ist nicht auf Grundlage.
Ja, was heißt doch?
Es ist absichtlich, dass das alles immer sehr vage gehalten ist.
Weil ihr könnt euch ja noch an Fallout 76 erinnern.
Wenn dann einer Zeug erzählt, das nicht stimmt, dann wird es natürlich komplett zerrissen.
Ja.
Natürlich erzählen die trotzdem viel Zeug, was nicht stimmt.
Aber das ist halt super, super vage, was die da erzählen.
Das ist...
Das sind halt so typische Stonks-Aussagen.
Das ist so, so was weiß ich...
Wir arbeiten mit Hochdruck an der Lösung des Problems.
Oder...
Das sind auch so Aussagen, die absolut unsinnig nichts sagen.
Ja.
Wir werden eine echte Next-Gen-Vision abliefern.
Sowas ist bescheuert.
Das kann alles heißen.
... und größere Maps.
Und dann noch ein bisschen über die Next-Gen-Konsolen.
Das erste, was mir auf den Kopf kommt...
Das bedeutet, dass das nächste Battlefield-Spiel...
... wahrscheinlich nur auf PC, Xbox One Series X oder S und Playstation 5 erhältlich sein wird.
Für mich ist das der richtige Weg.
Ich will nicht, dass DICE...
Und mein Xbox One Series X ist ja die Neue, ne?
... für Battlefield.
Ah, das glaube ich nicht.
Das glaube ich nicht.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass sie die letzte Gen...
Also, wenn das jetzt rauskommt, irgendwann nächstes Jahr oder so...
... kann ich glaube ich nicht, dass sie die Last-Gen wirklich auslassen.
Weil...
Es sei denn, die haben sich bis dahin so krass verkauft.
Aber...
Das braucht einfach viel zu viele Spieler, die das...
Ja...
Die es nicht...
... spielen werden dann.
Wir sprechen von den nächsten-Gen-Konsolen.
Es geht nicht nur darum, bessere Grafiken und Raytracing zu haben.
Es geht auch darum, dass die PS5 und Xbox Series X...
... NVMe-SSDs haben.
Das bedeutet...
Ja, gut.
... unglaublich schnelle Ladezeiten.
Sie haben auch viele Erinnerungen.
Und das öffnet eine ganze Menge Spielmöglichkeiten...
... die an den alten Systemen nicht möglich waren.
Und das könnte...
Da bin ich ja mal gespannt.
Also...
Ich wüsste jetzt nicht...
... was eine SSD...
... bei Battlefield machen sollte...
... dass man da etwas machen kann...
... was nie vorher möglich gewesen sein soll.
Wobei...
Ganz ehrlich?
Doch.
Man könnte tatsächlich Maps machen...
... die sich...
Also...
Wo man...
Quasi...
Wenn man sich vorstellt...
Eine riesig...
Eine riesig große, lange Rush-Map...
Wo die Map dann quasi...
Bisschen wie in...
Wie hieß das?
Dieser Modus von Map zu Map in Battlefield 1...
Conquest?
Nee.
Conquest ist normal.
Wie hieß das denn?
Wo du eine Map gespielt hast...
... dann ging es danach gleich weiter.
Ja.
Sowas könnte man quasi ohne Ladezeiten machen.
Zwischen den...
Zwischen den Maps.
Wenn du dich darauf verlassen kannst...
... dass jeder so eine richtig...
Nice...
Äh...
Fette SSD drinne hat.
Frontlines hieß das, oder?
Nee.
Nicht Frontlines.
Operations.
Genau.
Sowas in der Richtung.
Könntest du quasi eine Rush-Runde machen.
Und quasi die neue Maps dann immer rein streamen oder so.
Das würde schon funktionieren.
Aber prinzipiell würde ich mal sagen...
... es ist jetzt nicht so...
... dass wenn jeder eine SSD drinne hat...
... dass du dein Battlefield jetzt was bahnbrechendes...
... Battlefield-Stylemäßiges machen kannst...
... was vorher nicht ging.
Und sie zeigen das Spiel im Frühling.
Toll.
Normalerweise veröffentlichen DICE und EA...
... ihre neuen Battlefield-Games...
... im Mai oder Juni.
Also ich erwarte...
... dass das das ist...
... wenn wir unseren ersten...
... echten, soliden Look bekommen...
... auf was sie hier kochen.
Also das war die erste Sektion.
Es gab auch noch einen Kommentar dazu...
... bevor wir zu einer Frage kamen...
... die gefragt wurde.
Und das war über die Entwicklung...
... der Firma...
... Netbookings...
... diese Art von Sachen.
Was?
Na gut, die Leute haben Corona...
... und sind daheim und spielen mehr.
Boah...
selbst gefeiere immer.
Dieses Gelaber ist immer das Gleiche, ne?
Das ist genauso, wie wenn
Blizzard was zu Overwatch erzählt.
Da tun die auch immer, als wäre Overwatch
das größte und beste
und tollste Game und alle sind
nur ultra begeistert und
die beste Community und
die Vision und bla und sonst was.
Und letztendlich ist
Overwatch, naja, nicht tot, aber
weit von dem
entfernt, was es sein könnte.
Es hat schon... Ach ja, ist übrigens das
Geile, Blizzard hat ja auch letztens mal wieder
erzählt, angeblich gibt es 10 Millionen
oder ne, ich weiß nicht, ob es Blizzard erzählt hat, irgendwo
hieß es, Overwatch hätte 10 Millionen
Spieler. Das ist komplett das Schwachste, das.
Also, es hat schon seinen Grund,
warum die keine wirklich realen
Spielerzahlen veröffentlichen.
Weil das eben nicht so ist. Wenn es so wäre,
überlegt euch mal, es wäre
wirklich so, dass Overwatch
5 Jahre nach Release, oder wann das rausgekommen ist,
oder 6, 4 oder 5
Jahre nach Release,
wenn das
wirklich 10 Millionen
Spieler, also aktive Spieler,
die dann auch öfters mal einloggen, hätte,
die würden, die, die, die
Chancenabteilung würde sich überschlagen
mit Rekordzahlen, wie geil sie sind.
Nachdem das nicht der Fall ist, kann man ausschließen,
dass es auch nur ansatzweise sich in diesen
Regionen, äh, bewegt.
Zumal man davon ausgehen muss, richtig,
wenn man sich andere Spieler, zumindest
mit täglich aktiven Sachen anguckt, ja,
wenn man zum Beispiel mal die Steam-Statistik
von CSGO anguckt, die sind ja,
die sind bei einem Zehntel davon.
Und ihr wollt mir doch nicht, oder was heißt ihr nicht, aber
ihr wollt mir doch nicht ernsthaft erzählen, dass
Overwatch 10 Mal mehr
aktive Spieler als CSGO hat.
Im Leben nicht.
Und wenn es so wäre, wie gesagt,
würde die Stonks-Abteilung sich mit
neuen Rekorden überschlagen, wie geil sie sind.
Waren sie nicht.
Die Overwatch-League ist auch so krass am
Abscheißen, seit sie auf YouTube sind.
Ähm, man muss sich ja mal überlegen,
jegliche, oder fast jeglicher
E-Sport
hat, ähm,
in der Corona-Zeit jetzt
ziemliche Viewer,
Zuschauer-Rekorde und
bessere Zuschauerzahlen erlebt.
Außer
Overwatch.
Overwatch nicht. Bei Overwatch
sind die Zahlen zurückgegangen und gehen zurück.
Man muss sich überlegen, dass die
Major, oder was heißt Major,
es gibt ja im Prinzip nur Overwatch-League, es gibt ja
nichts anderes, ja.
Wenn man sich überlegt, dass
Overwatch-League-Games, wo du quasi
Millionen bezahlen
musst, dass du mitmachen kannst, und das
Millionen-Ding ist, dass, ähm,
quasi Overwatch-League-Spiele
so viele Zuschauer
haben, wie ein
CS-Turnier sagt alles
aus.
Ich rede jetzt ja noch nicht mal davon, wenn
jetzt irgendwie
ein Major ist, oder so.
Wo dann irgendwie 100.000 plus zugucken.
Ähm, so ein 0815
CS-Turnier
mit guten Teams,
hat schon 30, 40, 50.000
Zuschauer teilweise. Und
in Overwatch ist halt
das, das normale High-End
äh, S-Tier
quasi League, die
äh, weniger hat als das
0815 CS-Turniere, ja.
Ja, Fantasy, geb ich dir voll und ganz recht,
die haben's mega verschissen.
Die haben's mega verschissen, generell
mit Overwatch. Das ganze Handling, was
E-Sport angeht, ist abdesand. Die haben
komplett versagt, meiner Meinung nach.
Die haben zwar, äh, viel Geld
reingesteckt, aber Overwatch ist der beste
Beweis für, dass viel Geld
reinstecken nicht automatisch
zu, äh, was
Gutem am Ende führt, ja.
Es gibt ja beispielsweise neben Overwatch League,
es gibt nichts, es gibt nichts, es gibt
kein Tier 2, kein Tier 3.
Es gibt zwar theoretisch Contenders,
aber, wenn man mal ehrlich ist, Contenders ist
People Love.
Lull, Keck W ist Contenders.
Contenders ist das einzige,
was es gibt, und
Contenders ist halt so ein Ding des, äh,
noch nicht mal Blizzard selbst irgendwie mag.
Da gibt's keine Werbung für und nix.
Und es gibt nichts. Es gibt einfach
kein, guck mal, es gab ewig kein,
kein Observer-Mode und solche
Geschichten. Es gibt nichts
E-Sport-technisch, außer
Overwatch League. Was auch dazu führt, dass
es im Prinzip, außer ein paar Koreanern,
keine Nachwuchsleute gibt. Wer, wer
spielt denn heute
noch, wer möchte denn heute Overwatch Pro
werden? Keiner. Das ist der Witz, ja.
Und wenn du dir anguckst, dass
teilweise eine der
besten oder, oder viele, viele sehr gute
Overwatch-Spieler jetzt einfach direkt zu
Valorant geswitcht sind, seit das rausgekommen ist,
sagt viel drüber aus. Und viele
Probleme, die das Game von Anfang an hat,
äh, also, äh,
äh, was heißt das?
Tut Blizzard ja noch nicht mal anerkennen,
dass es die gibt.
Valorant lebt noch, ja. Ist vielleicht nicht so
krass wie mit den, mit diesen
Boosts bei Twitch.
Aber Valorant gibt's noch. Gibt's immer noch.
Wird auch relativ aktiv gespielt.
Ähm, ja, also Blizzard
erkennt ja viele Probleme noch nicht mal an.
Mit diesen, die sie haben. Zum Beispiel
ist von Anfang an, ist,
äh, diese ganze,
dieser ganze 2CP-Spielmodus ist einfach
von Anfang an absoluter Schrott gewesen.
Ja. Und viele Sachen ist halt,
wo man sich so denkt, Blizzard weiß es halt
mal wieder besser. Aber das ist die typische
Blizzard-Philosophie, die sie bei so ziemlich allen
Games an den Tag legen.
Blizzard weiß es besser.
Mittlerweile ist es auch, es ist auch
besser geworden. Sie haben es ja in Overwatch jetzt
geschafft, dass es schnellere Patches gibt und alles.
Das ist schon okay. Es ist nicht mehr ganz so schlimm,
wie wurde nicht ein halbes Jahr. Abmühen
muss es mit immer dem gleichen Scheiß.
Aber, ähm,
das ist,
das ist einfach verschissen.
Ja.
Ähm, ja, muss ich dazu nicht sagen. Gucken wir uns nochmal
die restliche Battlefield-Geschichte an.
So, just curious, as you think towards next
year in Battlefield. Obviously, that's a
big theme for Fiscal 2022.
Can you provide an update about how
you're feeling about the development process?
And if there's any risk a year from now
that maybe that game doesn't launch
on time, it would be helpful to get
an update there. Andrew Wilson steps in
and answers. There's some stuff about
Apex there. Wisst ihr was Geiles?
Das, ähm,
weiß nicht, ob ich das, ob ihr auch so
diese Vermutung habt. Diese
Leute, es gibt ja manchmal
auf Reddit, kommt jetzt ein bisschen
random, ich weiß, aber es gibt ja manchmal
auf Reddit oder auch
von offizieller Seite
gibt's ja so, so Frage-Antwort-Streams.
Sei es auf Reddit,
dass mal irgendwelche Entwicklerstudios
so einen Ask-Me-Anything machen oder
dass es in einem offiziellen
ähm, Forums-Post was gibt, fragt
die Entwickler oder einen Livestream
gibt, so nach dem Motto, stell den Entwicklern
Fragen. Und ich hab den Eindruck,
dass
diese Fragen, die dort gestellt werden,
die sind so übertrieben,
so übertrieben positiv
stonks-like schon gestellt
und
mich würd nicht wundern, wenn im Vorfeld schon klar ist,
was beantwortet wird und was nicht.
Ich mein,
das ist so eine Frage, wie die hier gestellt ist,
das ist so, das hört sich fast
so an, so wie von, von
Stonks-Manager zu Stonks-Manager.
Ja, diese Fragen sind
überhaupt nicht
aus Spielersicht
immer gestellt. Das merkt,
das merkt man schon daran, wenn
es dann beispielsweise auf der Gamescom und so haben sie
sowas ja auch gehabt, so irgendwie so, so diese,
ihr kennt ja diese Fake-Interviews, wo dann halt
quasi auf der offiziellen Bühne
jemand von einem
offiziell angeheuerten
Moderator interviewt wird, wo dann
immer so ganz, ganz kritische Fragen
kommen. So nach, da sind dann so Fragen
wie, ihr habt ja die letzten Jahre
schon immer die beste Battlefield-Experience
abgeliefert,
wie, wie, ähm,
was habt ihr vor, dass dieses Mal
noch zu übertreffen? Das sind dann so Fragen,
die auf diesen Bühnen gestellt werden, so
WTF, was ist das für eine Frage?
Ich meine, okay,
es ist die offizielle Battlefield-Bühne
mit dem offiziellen Moderator, der den Typ halt
was fragen soll, was sich gut anhört,
ja, aber da sind diese
Fake-Interviews immer, die da so,
wo schon die Frage
so unglaublich positiv gestellt
ist, ähm,
wo der Typ
einfach nur noch drauf antworten muss, ja,
ist so. Genau,
wenn man so geil ist, wie ihr es seid, genau, das sind
solche Fragen, ja,
das ist immer, genau, und so sind diese Sachen
hier auch immer gestellt, die dann beantwortet werden,
aber auf die wirklichen Fragen,
so nach dem Motto, wollt ihr wieder
einen ordentlichen Rush-Modus einbauen,
ähm, was macht ihr gegen Cheater
und solche Geschichten, ja,
also wirklich das, was die Spieler vielleicht interessiert,
da kommt dann nix.
Es kommt nur so bla bla bla bla
und darauf kann man antworten. Das liegt aber auch daran,
weil die Leute echt
gut im Bla Bla machen sind, die da drauf
antworten. Den Battlefront, äh,
den Battlefront-Thread kenne ich, ja.
Das ist auch so ein typisches,
so ein typisches Stonks-Gelaber.
Den, den, den kennen vielleicht
auch, das ist der Battlefront-Thread,
wo die gemeint haben, ähm,
dass du
80 Euro, ups,
what the fuck?
Dass du 80 Euro bezahlen musst oder
ewig lang spielen musst, um Darth Vader zu anlocken.
So, und jetzt kommt, jetzt kommt, ihr guckt
euch mal die Negativ-Points an,
und jetzt guckt euch mal die Antwort
von,
EA an.
Also, es ist ihr,
es ist ihre Intention, also,
sie wollen, dass
die Leute ein Gefühl von, so von Ehre
und Erfüllung haben, wenn sie etwas
anlockt haben. Ja gut, Erfüllung hat
höchstens hier der EA-Bank-Account, wenn alle
80 Euro, äh, 80 Dollar dafür ausgeben.
Das ist so ein richtig
dummes Gelaber.
Das sind solche Sachen, die kannst
du dir einfach komplett schenken.
Das sorgt im Endeffekt nur dafür, dass
die Leute noch stinkiger sind, als sie
ohne,
ohnehin schon gewesen sind.
Ja, und jetzt hier,
genau, die, die Leute antworten
nur darauf, wenn es eine
Great-Question ist, und eine Great-Question
ist etwas, wo man den Entwicklern
vorher schon den Arsch gekrochen ist,
dass man quasi es wert ist, dass die Frage
beantwortet wird. Das sieht man bei ganz
vielen dieser,
dieser, dieser, dieser
FAQ-Runden, ja.
Wenn, wenn nicht eh schon im Vorfeld klar ist,
welche Fragen kommen und welche Fragen beantwortet
werden.
Das müssen wir uns jetzt nicht angucken,
da ist einfach, einfach nur, einfach nur,
das sind doch nicht mal Actual News, das ist
einfach nur, äh, äh, Stonks
heißes Luftgelaber.
Wie detached muss man von der
Spielerbase sein, um sowas zu beantworten?
Es geht noch schlimmer, guckt dir die
Antworten von, äh, vom Fallout 76
Report und Sachen an. Weil die haben's
ja richtig verständigt. Ich weiß übrigens gar nicht, was das Game
überhaupt noch macht.
Was macht denn Fallout 76 gerade so?
Es gibt's auf jeden Fall noch.
So.
Äh, Moment, wo, wo hab ich denn hier den, den,
das machen wir zu, zack.
So, äh, das
gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an, das gucken wir uns jetzt auch nicht an,
was gucken wir uns denn an?
Realer Irrsinn, Weide muss ich vom Ackermann, das hab ich
vorher schon geguckt, das ist ja richtig, richtig
fail.
Open in three seconds, Viking Security
Fingerprint Safe, excellent, den guck ich immer gern.
Ist der Typ eigentlich wirklich Anwalt?
Hm.
Oh, was für ein Sound. Was für ein Sound beim Öffnen.
Der Sound hört sich an wie so ein Gameboy Game Over Screen, oder?
Findet ihr nicht auch?
So wie so Game Over auf dem Gameboy.
Ah.
Also, das ist so der typische Fall von, wir haben eine super
sichere Tür gebaut, aber wir haben nicht die Möglichkeit, die Tür zu öffnen.
Also, das ist so ein typischer Fall von, wir haben eine super Seekura Tür gebaut, aber wir haben nicht die Möglichkeit, die Tür zu öffnen.
Aber es gibt noch einen Seiteneingang, der nicht geschützt ist.
Excellent!
Dann mach das jetzt wieder auf, indem man es einfach nur scharf anguckt.
Der ist ja da teilweise, ne?
Teilweise geht er an irgendwelche Schlösser dran.
So, okay, machen wir mal hier diese Sache rein.
Zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack.
Auf!
Wo ich mir denke, aha!
Okay, das ist wirklich crap, das Teil.
Okay, das ist ja richtig schlecht.
Easy, easy as fuck.
Easy as fuck.
Easy clap.
Übrigens, heute Mittag.
Okay.
Also heute Mittag oder heute Nachmittag, soll mal gucken, wahrscheinlich heute Nachmittag,
machen wir ein bisschen weiter mit dieser Geschichte hier.
Wir haben ja letztens im Stream was zusammenprogrammiert, wo man Videokameras streamen kann sich im
Browser und heute Mittag probieren wir mal ein bisschen Object Detection aus.
Ich habe nämlich das hier gefunden für Home Assistant, aber das werde ich nicht für Home
Assistant verwenden.
Das ist ein fertiger Docker-Container.
Das ist ein fertiger Docker-Container mit einem trainierten Object Detection.
Okay.
Detection, TensorFlow, also Algorithmus, wie sagt man das richtig? Das ist ein Docker-Container mit
TensorFlow Lite drin, trainiert auf Objekterkennung in Bildern. Und das Ganze kann man ansprechen über
eine ganz normale REST-API. Und wenn man das anspricht, bekommt man halt eben als Antwort
hier, ich habe eine Person erkannt, hier, dort und dort auf dem Bild. So, und was natürlich
daran gut ist, erstens, so ein Docker-Container lässt sich easy starten auf allen möglichen
Plattformen, die supportet werden. Und mit so einer REST-API ist es natürlich schön, das lässt
sich auch easy integrieren. So, und ich habe jetzt ja dieses Programm zum, hier, die Geschichte habe
ich ja noch ein bisschen erweitert, noch nicht gepusht auf Git, dass man da mittlerweile einzelne
Frames abgreifen kann und auch ein paar Frames decoden kann. Und wir werden da einfach mal
heute Mittag gucken.
Wie das ist, wenn man dieses Teil hier als Object Detection verwendet. Ich habe es nämlich schon mit einem statischen Bild ausprobiert, das funktioniert ziemlich gut.
Und dort jeden Keyframe von der Kamera reinfüttern und dann schauen wir mal, ob das erkennt, wenn Leute durchs Bild laufen, was eine viel bessere Motion Detection ist, als diese billigen Kameras haben.
Die ganzen billigen Überwachungskameras, die es gibt, die haben zwar alle eine Bewegungserkennung. Das Problem ist nur, die Bewegungserkennung bei diesen
Billig-Kameras, die haben zwar alle eine Bewegungserkennung, aber die haben zwar alle eine Bewegungserkennung, aber die haben zwar alle eine Bewegungserkennung.
Die gucken zum größten Teil einfach nur, was sich im Bild ändert. Und wenn dann einer das, keine Ahnung, zu fest ans Hoftor kommt, ist halt Object Erkennung. Oder wenn ein Busch im Hintergrund wackelt, ist halt Object Erkennung und sowas. Ist halt Motion Detection.
Was für ein Ding. Max, kennst du den Matthäus-Effekt?
Ne, kenn ich, sagt mir gar nichts.
Er beschreibt, dass Leute mit bereits vorhandenem Erfolg bzw. Reichweite im nächsten Projekt wahrscheinlich einen weiteren Erfolg haben.
Was für ein Ding. Max, kenn ich, sagt mir gar nichts. Er beschreibt, dass Leute mit bereits vorhandenem Erfolg bzw. Reichweite im nächsten Projekt wahrscheinlich einen weiteren Erfolg haben.
Du kriegst ja natürlich auch unglaublich viel mehr Geld als jemand, der ein bisschen kleiner ist, wenn du irgendwelche Promotions machst und sowas. Und dementsprechend bist du dann da auch bekannt und bei der nächsten Sache kriegst du wieder mehr. Also das eine kommt zum anderen. Das zieht sich alles so ein bisschen an.
Also ich glaube nicht, dass das nur ein theoretischer Effekt ist, sondern das ist wahrscheinlich sogar ziemlich gut belegt in vielen Fällen.
Aber ich meine, es ist klar, wenn ein großer Channel ein Game macht und der hat, keine Ahnung, 400.000 Viewer auf dem Video und es gucken sich einfach nur 30.000 Leute mal kurz an, dann bist du ja mal ratzfatz Platz 1 im Store.
Ist halt so. Es ist ja noch nicht mal, dass das was Schlechtes ist in dem Sinn. Ich meine, der Typ kann ja auch gar nichts dagegen machen.
So, was habe ich hier noch?
Ich habe versucht, Traffic als Proxy plus Docker für meinen Server daheim anzurichten. Du hattest das Ganze mal in einem Stream gezeigt, nur eben mit einem öffentlichen Server bei DigitalOcean.
Ja, ne, ich habe das daheim auch lokal laufen. Also das DigitalOcean habe ich nur gemacht, dass ihr am Ende einen Speedtest drauf machen könnt.
Was bei mir nicht funktioniert, ist bei Cloudflare eine IP anzugeben. Löst also nicht auf. Public IPs funktionieren allerdings.
Hab dann etwas recherchiert und bei der Flixbox bei DNS Rebinding eine... Alter, Moment, muss mal was trinken hier. Meine Güte, irgendwas im Hals.
So.
Also, hab dann etwas recherchiert und bei der Flixbox bei DNS Rebinding eine Ausnahme für meine Domain eingetragen. Hat nicht Gott.
Also, du kannst in einem Public DNS eine interne IP eintragen. Bringt halt meistens nichts, wenn man die Seite extern verwenden will. Ist ja logisch.
Was bringt es mir, wenn meine Sache auf 192.168.1.1 auflöst? Aber ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob man bei der Flixbox... Also normalerweise ist es kein Ding.
Es ist überhaupt kein Ding.
Also, du kannst... Bei Cloudflare hab ich es noch nicht gemacht, ehrlich gesagt. Aber bei meinem anderen DNS-Anbieter war das gar kein Problem.
Was du aber machen kannst, ist... Ich benutze ja beispielsweise nicht den DNS-Server von meiner Flixbox. Ich benutze den DNS-Server auf meinem MikroTik-Router.
Und dort kann ich ohne Probleme jede Domain, die es gibt, quasi überschreiben. Und dann sage ich dann beispielsweise hier, meine Domain ist...
Irgendeine interne IP oder mein Hostname oder mein FQDN heißt ja, ist irgendeine IP.
Intern. Und die kann ich sogar extern anders auflösen lassen. Also, was hier irgendwelche DNS-Rebinding-Geschichten... Keine Ahnung.
Also, hat die Flixbox nicht... Kann man in der Flixbox nicht statische DNS-Einträge machen? Geht das nicht? Kann man.
Ja, wenn man das machen kann, dann kannst du einfach in deiner Flixbox dein FQDN eintragen mit der internen IP.
Wie du willst. Dann musst du nämlich nicht nach außen auf Cloudflare, um das Ganze abzufragen. Das ist eh komplett einmal zu viel.
Weil es bringt dir ja gar nichts, wenn dein Cloudflare eine interne IP auflöst. Die interne IP kann ja dann DNS auflösen.
Dein internen DNS auf der Flixbox. Also, wenn du in der Flixbox statische DNS-Einträge machen kannst, dann kannst du in deiner Flixbox eintragen.
Plup.poggers.de.
Löst auf 10.1.1.1.
Dann musst du auch nicht jedes Mal zu Cloudflare und den DNS abfragen.
Äh, wieso bekommt Werbung auch Französisch? Was weiß ich?
Poggers.
Kifrin, 13 Monate.
Excellent Subscription.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Massive.
Subscription.
So, was unser Video hat verarbeitet...
Oh! Nach 7 Stunden hat es das tatsächlich geschafft. 1080p.
Ähm, okay. Ich hab echt irgendwas heute im Hals. Ganz schlimm.
Kann gar nicht noch mal reden, ne? Ob das schon Corona ist, äh, Kiste, hab ich nicht gemacht.
Ich hab mich jetzt einfach auf den Chat verlassen, dass das geht.
Fritzbox statisch DNS.
Mal gucken, ob das funktioniert. Ob es da irgendwo ein Image gibt.
Äh, nein.
Nein.
Leute, wo macht man statische DNS-Einträge?
In der Fritzbox.
Wo geht das?
Wo macht man statische DNS-Einträge?
Der Chat sagt, es geht. Also muss der Chat auch wissen, wo das geht.
Also wenn das geht...
Hier vielleicht... Netzwerk.
Ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung. Ich hab das in der Fritzbox noch nie gemacht.
Ja, da. Okay.
Also Chat meint hier.
Ich kann es jetzt nicht ausprobieren.
Kann man da vielleicht auch mal irgendwas von letztem Jahr finden?
Ja, also wenn du
statische DNS-Einträge machen kannst in der Fritzbox,
dann ist es kein Ding.
Wie gesagt, meine Fritzbox... Ich verwende DNS in meiner Fritzbox eh nicht.
Ich verwende den aus...
...dem MikroTik-Router.
Ja, wenn das nicht geht,
dann...
...weiß ich nicht.
Außer den eigenen DNS-Server betreiben.
Und die Fritzbox darauf umstellen.
Wenn Cloudflare es nicht erlaubt,
eine interne IP einzustellen,
dann, ähm...
Wobei mich das wundern würde, weil es...
Du kannst natürlich eine interne IP
einstellen bei einem public erreichbaren DNS.
Das ist überhaupt kein Ding. Es bringt halt keinem was.
Weil es die IP bei ihm dann nicht gibt.
Aber gehen tut das.
Bin ich bei Cloudflare noch eingeloggt?
Naja.
Ich hab jetzt auch leider kein Cloudflare...
Ich guck mal, ob ich meine Cloudflare-Zugangsdaten hier irgendwo hab.
Ich probier das jetzt aus.
Chat.
Ich probier das jetzt.
Es geht.
Genau. Hab ich jemand Cloudflare?
Cloudflare.
Ja.
Login.
Anmelden.
So. Chat. Ich blende euch mal kurz aus.
Weil sonst ist hier
LEAK.
Fuck. Ich hab mich vertippt.
Jetzt muss ich auch noch Bicycle-Captcha lösen.
Ok. Ich bin eingeloggt.
Exzellent.
Zack.
Ok. Ähm...
Ich mach euch wieder an.
Also.
DNS-Eintrag hinzufügen.
Bei Cloudflare.
Geht da eine interne IP?
Probieren wir mal aus.
Blub.
Das hier musst du ausmachen.
Also musst du umstellen auf nur DNS.
IP-Leak. MonkaS.
Oh nein.
By the way. Das ist nicht meine IP.
Das ist den Server, den ich bei 1&1
gemietet hab.
Ist hier dahinter.
Man beachtet übrigens auch
kekw als Domain.
Oder als Hostname.
So. Und dann kann man doch jetzt
einfach irgendwie sowas eintragen.
Ist doch eigentlich gar kein Problem.
Ja. Geht. Wo ist das Problem?
Ist doch überhaupt kein Ding.
So. Und wenn man jetzt hier...
Mal gucken, ob der schon auflöst.
Easy. Wo ist das Problem?
Funktioniert doch wunderbar.
Ok. Ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr, wer das gef...
Hier. Kiste HD. Wo ist das Problem? Hä?
Die Fritzbox blockt.
Ich hab auch ne Fritzbox.
Wobei. Aber nicht für Internetzugang.
Ja. Stimmt schon.
Ne. Die Fritzbox blockt das nicht. Oder?
Macht die Fritzbox sowas?
Das wär ganz schön fail, wenn die Fritzbox sowas macht.
Ernsthaft?
Warum?
Warum macht die Fritzbox solche Dinger?
Ernsthaft? Ok. Ok.
Ja gut. Ok.
Wenn du Google DNS abfragst und es kommt die IP,
dann geht ja prinzipiell alles.
Aber die Fritzbox... Hä?
Ok.
Das ist irgendein Fritzbox
Security Feature wahrscheinlich.
Das kenn ich nicht. Das Problem hab ich halt auch nicht.
Kann ich nicht über die Fritzbox ins Internet gehen, ne?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Ehrlich. Kein Schimmer.
So. Löschen wir das mal wieder.
Reserved IP.
Ja. Schön.
Löschen.
Die Fritzbox blockt das. Gut.
Tja dann.
Du gehst nicht über die Fritzbox
ins Internet, weil das Ding...
Das ist gar keine Kabelmode im Fritzbox.
Ich hab noch so ne...
Die billigste Fritzbox damals gekauft.
Die...
Die billigste Fritzbox damals gekauft
für DECT und VoIP.
Das ist das einzige, was das macht.
Ich bin ja die ganze Zeit schon überlegen,
ob ich mir nicht ne Kabelmode im Fritzbox kaufe,
die das dann alles zusammen machen kann.
Ja.
Weil dann bräuchte ich ein Gerät weniger.
Aktuell hab ich halt die Fritzbox für VoIP und DECT
und die Unity Media
ist Unity Media Modem halt
zum Verbindungsaufbau.
Und dahinter halt mein Mikrotik-Router,
der halt die eigentliche Sache macht.
Wo die Firewall-Regeln drauf sind,
wo die ganzen Interfaces, WLANs drauf sind.
Weil ich hab weder Bock,
das mit ner Fritzbox zu machen,
noch mit dem Unity Media Modem.
Das können die ja auch gar nicht.
Was unter Heimnetz, Netzwerk, Netzwerkeinstellung
gibt es in DNS Rebind-Schutz?
Aha. Siehste?
Chat. Chat kennt sich wieder aus.
Big Brain Chat.
Ackermans, ja.
So, guck mal weiter.
Unser Video ist verarbeitet.
Wir haben ein Video dazu aufgenommen.
Gestern Mittag,
weil jetzt demnächst Black Ops rauskommt,
haben wir uns auch mal kurz zu
Modern Warfare aus...
Hallo? Video?
What the...
Warum? Guck mal, das ist ein Bug
im YouTube Player. Seht ihr das?
Es geht erst ab 8 Sekunden los.
Hier vorne kannst du die anklicken.
So Leute, wir gucken uns jetzt mal
das Video an.
Und ich geb mal ein bisschen meinen Senf dazu.
Also, das haben wir bei ihm auf dem Channel gemacht.
Also, wer mal bei ihm vorbeigucken will,
ich schick euch mal den Link zum Channel.
Es wär schön, wenn ihr alle mal, die
am Start sind und sich das interessiert,
könnt ihr mal vorbeigehen, mal ein Like geben
und einen Kommentar lassen.
Immer gut für den YouTube Algorithmus.
Man kann das auf jeden Fall gebrauchen.
Erstmal 10k Bug Bounty.
Genau.
Ich kann nicht Sellout machen.
Das bin ja nicht ich.
Sellout geht nur
für sich selbst. Oder?
Sellout geht auch für
Raid Shadow Legends.
So, gucken wir uns das Ganze mal an.
So, herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen Video
auf meinem Kanal.
Ihr habt richtig gesehen, wir reden heute tatsächlich
über Call of Duty.
Das haben wir zwar schon lange nicht mehr gemacht.
Aber mit dabei hab ich auch
einen alten Hasen in der Call of Duty
Szene. Schrägstrich YouTube Szene.
Und
ja, sagt doch einfach mal was zu dem.
Gleich, gleich, gleich ist er am Start.
Hallo Leute, hier ist der Max.
Ich weiß, ist jetzt wahrscheinlich total random.
Aber wir wollten schon länger was zusammen aufnehmen.
Und nachdem ich es bei mir immer nicht auf die Reihe
bekommen hab...
Ist laut genug?
Ich merk's übrigens gerade im Hintergrund.
Ich hab das Kabel
von meinem Headset nicht richtig aufgehabt.
Weil das Kabel
vom Headset, das
reibt so an meiner Jacke,
die ich anhab. Deswegen macht's so komische
Geräusche. Ist doof.
Das klappt
eigentlich normalerweise,
wenn ich mir das Headset-Kabel
so um den Hals hinten hänge,
dann passiert das nicht. Aber da hab ich nicht dran gedacht.
Genau, also
ich sag schon mal danke, dass du überhaupt
da bist. Also es hat sich jetzt so
über die ganze MW-Zeit
Ich hab, nur kurz zur Hintergrundgeschichte,
ich hab damals über seinen Twitter
so ein Beta-Key
für MW gewonnen.
Und mit Ansage hab ich irgendwas geschrieben wie
ich brauch einen und dann hab ich
einfach einen bekommen und dann haben wir irgendwann
dann mal angefangen zusammen MW zu zocken.
Und ja, und jetzt sind wir hier
und haben jetzt eigentlich den ganzen MW-Zyklus
mehr oder weniger miteinander erlebt.
So viel wie er halt gezockt hat.
Ja, ich hab wie gesagt,
Ich hab zwar jetzt... Ist laut genug?
Leute? Passt so?
Nicht unbedingt da die 500 Stunden
drin oder so, aber
die Zeit wo wir gespielt haben, haben wir zusammen gespielt
und wir haben uns auch zusammen über das Game
aufgeregt. Wobei man ja mal fairerweise
sagen muss, es ist ja auch nicht alles schlecht.
Es wird ja, also Modern Warfare wird ja übelst
verteufelt. Es ist nicht alles schlecht.
Aber ich glaube das Spiel hat
schon nicht, zumindest für die Leute die länger
dabei sind, ich weiß nicht wie du das siehst,
nicht unbedingt alles das erfüllt
was man sich vielleicht erhofft hat.
Ne, also ich hab mir das letzte
CoD gefühlt vor
10 Jahren gekauft und
ich hatte auch wirklich gar kein Interesse mehr.
Also ich hab die ganzen Open Betas mal
wieder gespielt, so von Black Ops 3
anscheinend jetzt hier, ich weiß gar nicht mehr,
einfach irgendwas mit rumhüpfen war es damals.
Black Ops 3, ja?
Ne, da hab ich lieber Counter Strike gespielt, aber
dann kam Warzone raus
und wie gesagt,
nur wegen Warzone hab ich überhaupt
wieder angefangen zu spielen.
Und so war es eigentlich bei den meisten, was ich so gehört hab.
Kann ich nachvollziehen,
ja, also Warzone war ja auch, als das rausgekommen
ist, war auch die Phase wo ich sogar mal relativ
viel gespielt hab. Ich hab's ja am Anfang gespielt, wo
der Multiplayer, also noch in der Beta
dann den Multiplayer und ich hatte da so schnell
keinen Bock mehr drauf, aber Warzone hat
dafür gesorgt, dass ich mal zumindest mal
so 2-3 Monate ziemlich
oft, ich mein wir haben ja teilweise da irgendwie
6 Stunden am Tag gespielt oder so oder Wochen.
Das stimmt, wir haben wirklich relativ
viel Warzone gespielt, ne?
Und Warzone war
die einzige Zeit da am Anfang, wo ich mal wirklich
viel Modern Warfare gespielt hab.
Das ging
dann schon, ja. Und ich bin auch der Meinung, dass
Warzone letztendlich das Game gerettet hat.
Im Vergleich zum Multiplayer.
Ich mein, man kann jetzt das nicht vergleichen
mit irgendwelchen Nischen-Games. Ich mein, das ist immer noch
Call of Duty, ja, und das werden nach wie vor
Multiplayer-Leute spielen, aber
ich fand den Multiplayer so enttäuschend,
dass für mich
das Game durch Warzone gerettet wurde
und vor allem, ich glaube auch durch die Menge
an Spielern hat Warzone das Game gerettet.
Wenn du dir anguckst, wie viele Leute das auf Twitch gucken,
wie viele Leute das spielen, ist nichts im Vergleich zum Multiplayer.
Also ich fand
damals schon Blackout eine coole Idee
bei Black Ops, aber das hat eigentlich ja
das hatte so zwei Wochen Hype
und dann, ja, dann war's
eigentlich schon wieder vorbei, aber das hat quasi
eigentlich so den Grundstein durchgelegt, dass
es Warzone überhaupt
dann gab, weil die haben das quasi einfach nur
verbessert und
echt gut gemacht. Also das ist einfach
quasi PUBG,
wie es damals hätte sein sollen.
So ist COD geworden.
Ich frag mich das jetzt auch grade,
wie kommt's eigentlich,
dass das so gut angekommen ist?
Das kam, ich mein, Warzone kam jetzt ja zu einer
Zeit, wo jetzt
schon dieses ganze
Battle Royale nicht grad mehr das neueste
war und eigentlich auch
ziemlich besetzt so mit alten Sachen.
Ja, wie, Chat,
mal fragen, wie erklärt ihr euch,
dass Warzone sich so durchgesetzt hat?
Also was ich dazu denke, sag ich
jetzt gleich, aber ich mein, Warzone war
zu einer Zeit am Start, wo
schon überall Battle Royale
eigentlich ausgelutscht war.
Natürlich PUBG hast du noch,
Fortnite allen voran, dann hast du
Pax Legends, letztendlich war ja für
alle Leute schon irgendwo ein
Battle Royale-Game dabei, was
so, jeder konnte sich
so eins raussuchen, weißt du?
Aber was meinst du, woran liegt's,
dass ausgerechnet Warzone da jetzt nochmal so
eingeschlagen hat?
Ich find, dass allein halt COD schon so
ein Prestige hat, alleine bei der jüngeren
Community, dass die
quasi, wenn COD sowas macht,
dann machen die das halt erst,
wenn's gut ist, richtig.
Und zum Beispiel gab's ja noch
Firestorm bei Battlefield.
Hat jeder vergessen,
aber diese alte...
Firestorm, alter!
Beziehungsweise der Mode,
der dann im Spiel war, war
richtig gut, nur leider geht das
halt nicht mit nem 60 Euro
pay-to-play quasi,
das funktioniert halt eigentlich nicht.
Deswegen hat das auch nie was...
Die haben nie genügend Spieler gehabt,
aber das hätte eigentlich das Größte werden können,
weil Warzone ja erst später rauskam.
Und auch das mit den Platten und sowas
hatten die da schon drinne.
Das hatte gewisse Ähnlichkeiten.
Ich mein, die werden auch viel
voneinander abgucken.
Ja, mit Sicherheit.
Ist schon komisch, also ich, vielleicht noch kurz dazu,
eigentlich wollten wir uns ja ein bisschen
auf den Multiplayer auslassen, aber ich denk,
warum Warzone so gut angekommen ist,
das war nicht so hardcore
wie PUBG mit irgendwelchem Inventory-Management
und sonst was.
Inventory-Management ist sehr light,
was du in Warzone hast,
im Vergleich zu PUBG, wo du dann 3 Stunden
track-and-drop musst, so die einzelnen Pillen aufheben,
so nach dem Motto, und bei Warzone, ja,
hast du gar kein richtiges Inventar eigentlich.
Es ist kein Rumgespringe,
es ist kein Rumgespringe und Gebäude wie Fortnite,
was auch vielen nicht gefällt,
und Apex war wahrscheinlich
auch nicht für alle was,
deswegen diese Kombination aus
man kann schon, wenn man gut ist, was reißen,
plus, dass es zugänglich ist für jeden,
hat's glaube ich letztendlich rausgerissen
bei Warzone.
Ich hab da bei PUBG, ich hab ein bisschen gespielt
damals beim EA, ich hab immer übelst
Anfälle gekriegt, du wusstest nie, wo du jetzt
genau hinklicken musst, was welcher Hotkey irgendwie
macht, dann musstest du im Inventar
dann irgendwie noch Tetris spielen
zwischendurch, das ging mir auf den Sack.
Mag jetzt für die Hardcore-Leute
ein bisschen besser sein,
es gibt ja immer noch welche, die quasi
steif und fest behaupten,
PUBG ist das einzig wahre
Battle-Royale-Game, schön und gut,
jedem was gefällt, ja,
aber ich fand's halt echt nicht
zugänglich. Also ich find
auch, dass Warzone das so
einfach gemacht hat, also alleine bei H1Z1
damals hat das schon angefangen,
dass das Inventory irgendwann zu
heftig wurde, wenn man dann Sachen...
Was wir mit Tetris spielen meinen ist, dass du halt da ein Inventar sortieren musst.
Ja, gucken wir was, genauso musste ja in Diablo auch Tetris
im Inventar spielen.
Musste noch on the fly
und halt
zum Beispiel irgendwelche Bandagen
dann nur anlegen konnte,
wenn man die davor noch gecraftet hatte und sowas
und bei Warzone kann jeder
mit Controller mit 2 Klicks alles droppen,
alles aufnehmen und das macht das ganze
halt auch so einfach, deswegen
find ich eigentlich echt gut gelöst, weil
Fortnite war ja dann irgendwann auch so viel mit
Bauen und so weiter,
deswegen Warzone ist halt durch...
Man hört den Voice-Chat
ein bisschen im Hintergrund, ne?
Von diesem 2 on 2
Spiel im Hintergrund, ey.
Warzone ist halt
sehr casual, weil du durch den Gulag halt auch
eine gute Chance hast, direkt wiederzukommen,
wenn du einmal stirbst.
Stimmt, da hab ich gar nichts dran gedacht, ja.
Und durch den Buyback, den gibt's ja auch in keinem anderen Spiel.
Das heißt, durch den Buyback kann dein Team
dich ja auch immer wieder kaufen und dadurch wird es
wird halt dieses, du hast nur
ein Leben und wenn du stirbst, dann war's das
und musst du mal neu suchen, ist komplett rausgenommen,
weil es mehr so Arcadic wird.
Stimmt, eigentlich ist das
eine ziemlich gute Kombi, wenn man sich mal überlegt
so aus, ein Kill hat schon
einen recht hohen Impact jetzt in Warzone,
das ist jetzt nicht so, dass du instant respawnen kannst,
aber es ist jetzt auch nicht so
endgültig, wie jetzt in
anderen Games. Das wird wahrscheinlich auch was dazu beitragen.
Ja, also wenn ich zum Beispiel mal irgendwo
gesniped werde und dann sehe, dass ich dann
vielleicht, dass es gar nicht reichen
kann, dann geh ich halt auch mal lieber schneller
in Gulag, um dann wieder rauszukommen.
In den anderen Spielen ist dann halt das ganze Spiel vorbei,
wenn du einmal tot bist.
Ja, das stimmt. Aber jetzt zum Thema
Respawn und so.
Exzellente hier Pistol Shots, oder?
Guckt euch das mal an.
Die Gegner kriegen voll auf den Sack.
Dann, wenn man sich mal den Multiplayer
anguckt. Was ist denn so,
das Spiel hat ja ziemlich viele Multiplayer-Modi,
was ist dein Lieblingsspielmodus?
Multiplayer.
Also im normalen Multiplayer,
ich unterteile es immer, dass ich diese Gunfights
jetzt quasi nicht so richtig als Multiplayer
sehe, diese 2v2, 3v3
Maps, weil das ist
für mich irgendwie so ein anderer Modus.
Ich meine, diese klassischen Call of Duty-Modes
finde ich eigentlich immer noch,
also Sprengkommando, beziehungsweise Demolition,
immer noch den besten Modus.
Wenn man halt genau weiß, wo die Gegner spawnen.
Aber das ist mehr so meine persönliche
Präferenz, weil ich weiß ja, dass
die meisten Leute so Herrschaft oder sowas am meisten
feiern. Aber ich muss sagen,
dass in diesem COD hat mir eigentlich
so blöd sich's anhört, hat mir Kill Confirmed
am besten gefallen, weil ich ja
so viele Marken da einsammeln konnte,
weil niemand Marken eigene sammelt hat
in dem Spiel. Ich weiß nicht, also
die haben
alle nicht Objective gespielt,
dann habe ich es einmal auch hingekriegt, dass ich
über 80 Marken mal auf einer Map
gesammelt habe von 100.
Das liegt daran, dass in diesem,
also aus meiner Sicht ist das so,
das ist ja ein Spielmodus, wo
eigentlich die Leute motiviert werden sollen,
sich ein bisschen zu bewegen. Also sprich,
du kannst die eigenen Marken aufsammeln
und die Gegner Marken aufsammeln.
Also aus meiner Sicht ist das so,
das ist ja ein Spielmodus, wo
eigentlich die Leute motiviert werden sollen,
sich ein bisschen zu bewegen.
Also sprich, du kannst
die eigenen Marken aufsammeln
und die Gegner Marken aufsammeln.
Also sprich, du kannst
die eigenen Marken aufsammeln
und die Gegner Marken aufsammeln.
Normalerweise, wenn man die Runde gewinnen will,
sollte man von ausgehen, die Leute stürzen sich
auf die Marken. Aber nachdem das
Gameplay von Modern Warfare an sich
jetzt, wie drückt man das jetzt mal aus,
jetzt nicht gerade zum mobil sein
lädt, ist
wahrscheinlich dieser Modus so, dass den
keiner richtig spielt. Außer wenn du halt
voll auf Objective gehst. Wir haben jetzt
ein paarmal zusammen gespielt, auch diese
traditionellen Multiplayer. Muss halt sagen,
du bist halt nicht nur auf Objective gegangen,
du hast auch noch gleich die meisten Kills dabei gemacht.
Ja, also, man hat's halt
irgendwann drauf, wenn man 10 Jahre lang
So geil, wie er sich selbst lobt.
Ja, also, irgendwann
irgendwann hat man's halt einfach drauf,
wenn man das eine Weile spielt. Easy.
Richtig zuchtet.
Beziehungsweise halt
alleine, dass man jetzt seine Sensitivität
genauso einstellen kann, wie es damals
in Competitive Counter Strike
bei mir war, dann kann ich
halt quasi genau das gleiche Aim
mitnehmen auf den Multiplayer
von COD, wo halt Casuals mit dem Controller
spielen. Also quasi einmal
einmal über den Schreibtisch für eine
halbe Drehung oder wie? Easy.
Also ich spiel mit 640 DPI,
das ist gar nichts, aber dafür ist
mein Mousepad gar nicht so groß.
Achso. Ja gut, stimmt, ich weiß ja, wie
haben wir das gleiche Mousepad.
Weil was ich sonst von den Counter Strike Spielern
kenne ist halt, die haben halt wirklich so ein Mousepad,
das geht so irgendwie einmal die Treppe runter in den Garten
und dann passt so eine halbe Drehung so nach dem Motto.
Also solche, ich hab
zu Hause so ein 1 Meter Mousepad, aber
ich hab's nie gebraucht, aber ich seh auch,
dass meine ganzen Kollegen alle auch
ein 2 Meter auf 2 Meter Mousepad haben.
Aber vielleicht bin ich da halt anders,
aber es ist wahrscheinlich eh nur
Gewohnheitssache.
Klar, wie viel das ist.
Ähm, wir haben ja auch ein bisschen die
2 und 2 Modus gespielt.
Ich komm mit diesen riesen Mousepads nicht klar, ne.
Ich hab das auch mal probiert, so ein richtig fettes
Mousepad, was so quasi noch
unter der Tastatur durchging.
Weiß nicht, ich bin damit nicht klar gekommen.
Ich mein so ein Mini Mousepad, wie man jetzt
irgendwie vom PC Spezialist
Media Markt sonst was bekommt,
ist jetzt auch nicht das.
Aber so diese riesen Mousepads, ich hab da gar keinen Bock
immer meinen Arm 3 Kilometer
zu bewegen für eine halbe Drehung.
Wie groß ist deins jetzt? Ich hab das hier.
Mal, ich hab gerade
dieses Teil hier, Logitech
G... Moment, das ist
die Maus. Wo ist denn das Mousepad?
Das da. Das da.
Weil das die Maus auflädt, das Mousepad.
Das ist nicht sonderlich groß.
Also das könnte tatsächlich manchmal bisschen größer
sein.
Also ungefähr 30x30.
Das ist aber echt ganz praktisch.
Weil komplett Wireless Maus
und komplett Maus aufladen über das
Mousepad.
Das ist wirklich nice, also
ich hätte gar nicht gedacht, dass das was ist,
was ich brauche, aber jetzt wo ich's
hab, will ich's auch nicht mehr ohne.
Wie dick sollte ein Mousepad
sein? Ist eigentlich vollkommen wurscht.
Genau. Und
ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen,
weil du gerade meintest, dein Lieblingsmodus ist
Kill Confirmed oder auch
bisschen Demolition.
Alter, ich hätte mir unbedingt das Kabel vom Headset um den Hals
hängen müssen, das Rumgewackel
vom Kabel ist übelst ätzend.
Mir persönlich hat
das noch mit am meisten Spaß gemacht.
Wie die Typen im Gameplay im Hintergrund rubschreien.
Weil du konntest, das ist
der einzige Spielmodus,
wo du, zumindest einer der
wenigen Spielmodi, wo du noch gut
im Kopf dir überlegen kannst,
wo Gegner sind und was die
Gegner jetzt machen. Ich bin ja generell so
jemand, der nicht unbedingt jetzt, vielleicht auch,
ich mein, ich bin jetzt mittlerweile 36,
der nicht jetzt durch die ultrakrassen
360 No Scope Reaction
oder sonst was killt, da irgendwie jetzt noch die Sachen reißt.
Ich bin ja jemand, der gerne überlegt,
was Gegner jetzt machen,
wo der Gegner jetzt langkommt,
bevor der weiß, wo ich langkomme, so nach dem Motto.
Und das ist so der einzige
Modus, wo ich finde, dass das in
Modern Warfare im Multiplayer so halbwegs
geht, dieses 2&2.
Genau, also der 2&2 Modus
ist wirklich das Beste, das die seit
Jahren produziert haben.
Abgesehen jetzt von Warzone an sich selber,
ich mein für den Multiplayer selber.
Naja, 36, ich weiß gar nicht, warum die Leute
immer so verwirrt sind, ne? Immer wenn ich
sag, ich bin 36, sagen alle, Max, lull,
du hörst dich viel länger an, das glaub ich nicht.
Doch. Ja, ich bin 36,
blende Twitch Emotes ein, sag
keck weh, anstatt zu lachen,
ups, und verwende
Poggers als Emote.
2&2 Turniere,
ich weiß nicht, ob es die schon davor gab,
ich hab gehört, irgendwas, das in Black Ops
schon mal gegeben haben soll,
aber so in dem Ausmaß,
das ist ja schon die ganze Beta, weil ja nur 2
wie 2 Turniere. Ja. Und
ich find auch, die machen am allermeisten
Spaß, vor allem das,
der Turniermodus, den seht ihr jetzt auch gerade im Hintergrund,
wenn nicht alles schief läuft,
allein dieser Turniermodus,
dass man ein komplettes Bracket hat,
mit 4 verschiedenen
Spielen, wenn man alle gewinnt, ist man
quasi das beste Team von dem ganzen
Turnierbaum. Und alleine, dass es
sowas halt auf Casual in
einer halben Stunde hat man das durch, wenn's
drauf ankommt, und
das macht einfach so dieses
kurzweilige Arcade-Element,
wieder rein, was ToD eigentlich schon
immer ausmacht. Das ist auch eine gute,
das ist eine wirklich gute Idee. Wie gesagt, am Anfang,
ich hab ja schon gesagt, das ist nicht alles schlecht,
auch wenn das Spiel extrem viel geflamed wird, und ich find,
das hat auch viel Verbesserungspotential, ja, aber
solche Sachen find ich wirklich gut, und das
könnten andere Games sich echt mal eine Scheibe von
abschneiden. Ich hätt mir damals in Overwatch gewünscht, dass
die so ein bisschen automatisiertes
Turnierformat einfügen, ja, wenn du jetzt nicht grad
Oh, das wär so geil in Overwatch gewesen,
hättest du mal ein bisschen mehr
Competitive gehabt, außer eben,
äh, tja,
Overwatch League, ja, Contenders ist ja auch kaum da,
so einfach so für die normalen Leute, die
ein bisschen zusammenspielen wollen mit ihren Kollegen,
so ein bisschen Competitive halt gegen andere gute
Gegner spielen, äh, aber
es gab ja keinerlei, keinerlei
Support in dieser Richtung,
in Overwatch. Das Turnier war,
das ist so ein, also was er hier im Hintergrund spielt,
ist so ein automatisch generiertes, ähm,
oder ich weiß nicht, ob's ein automatisch generiertes
ist, aber so ein
In-Game-Tournament. Da kannst
du dich In-Game für anmelden und mitspielen.
Ich glaube, zu gewinnen gibt's da glaube ich
nix, vielleicht irgendwelche Achievements oder so,
weiß ich nicht, ob's da was zu gewinnen gibt,
irgendwelche Skins, Achievements, eventuell,
aber, das war's dann aber auch.
XP und Blueprints, ja.
Äh, S-Team,
S-Tier-Team oder sowas bist und bei den richtig guten
Sachen mitspielen kannst, gab's da halt nicht viel,
und es gibt bestimmt Leute,
die wollen Games so, sagen wir mal
semi-competitive spielen, die wollen jetzt
nicht den 8-Stunden-Arbeitsersatz
Dryad-Modus machen vielleicht, aber schon
mit ihren Kollegen ein bisschen, äh,
gegen gleich gute spielen.
Deswegen find ich, fänd ich das ne geile Sache,
wenn das mehr Games so machen.
Und das, das ist ja genau das,
was auch Warzone ausmacht, dass
man da auch kurz 20 Minuten um
quasi den Sieg kämpft zusammen,
Da kriegt er, oh, der Gegner hat rumgeflamed,
da kriegt er ein richtig krasses Headshot um die Ecke.
... auch gewinnen kann und dann
somit direkt noch ein Erfolgserlebnis hat.
Wenn man jetzt stumpft, die ganze Zeit
TDM spielt, die 800. Runde
am Strick of Shipment, ist es
eigentlich völlig egal, wer gewinnt, da geht's
eigentlich nur darum, dass jeder so
in seinem eigenen Film
seine Waffen levelt und das war's.
Also, es juckt niemanden,
ob du da gewinnst, ob du verlierst,
ob der eine jetzt 15 Kills mehr hat oder nicht,
das juckt kein Mensch mehr im Multiplayer.
Außer die Typen, die rumschreien, wenn du sie killst, ne?
Ja, außer die, aber das macht dann
wieder Spaß und das ist auch wieder ein Element,
das hat ToD richtig gut gemacht,
dass dieser Voice-Chat so
aktiv wurde. Ich hab gehört von anderen,
dass der tot war die letzten
Jahre und durch dieses, durch diese
kurze Freischaltung vom Mikrofon, wenn man
jemanden umbringt,
hat man ja diese zwei, drei Sekunden,
wo man hört die Reaktion von Gegnern.
Das finde ich eigentlich übelst geil in Warzone, wenn die Leute dann
rumschreien, wenn sie gekillt werden.
Und das hat den ganzen
Voice-Chat so lustig wieder gemacht.
Also, es ist schon sehr salzig,
aber es macht schon Spaß.
Ja, das ist ja, dass die Leute
angepisst sind schnell und bisschen toxic
rumflamen, das hast du ja in jedem Spiel, was
PvP ist im Endeffekt,
also wo du gegen andere Leute spielst.
Die sind ja teilweise, teilweise
in Handy-Games flamen die Leute rum,
das ist ja normal.
Also, wenn ich FIFA spiele...
Kennt ihr das, was aufwitzig ist?
Ich glaube, ich sag's im Video auch gleich noch.
Was auch immer lustig ist, wenn du
gegen andere Leute spielst und du gewinnst,
egal wie knapp,
also, was weiß ich, in der letzten Sekunde
mit einem Punkt gewinnst
du, dann ist es automatisch
easy.
It's AF to easy
learn to play. It's.
Es ist immer it's.
Wie knapp und wie hart das Game war,
es ist immer it's.
Wenn du aber verlierst,
dann wird geflamed.
Am Wochenende
mal ein, zwei Spiele, dann
krieg ich Nachrichten von den Gegnern,
entweder haben die mich komplett zerstört
und schreiben dann, haha bist du schlecht,
oder ich bekomm die Nachricht mit irgendwelchen
liebsten Beleidigungen, was mir denn einfällt,
dass ich gegen den gewonnen hab.
Okay, also, so krass muss man's dann
vielleicht auch nicht machen.
Aber es ist auch so,
in den anderen Games auch,
entweder es ist it's am Ende,
selbst wenn du nur um einen Punkt gewonnen hast,
war es it's, natürlich, was sonst?
Und was weiß ich,
it's learn to play,
und ansonsten musst du rumflayen,
warum er gewonnen hat.
Irgendwie in allen Multiplayer-Spielen,
weiß auch nicht, was da los ist.
Was wir vielleicht auch nochmal kurz ansprechen sollten,
ist ein Thema,
was ja viel kritisiert wird bei Modern Warfare,
weil die Maps irgendwie nicht so
Alter, die Modern Warfare Maps sind so kacke.
... als letzter Schluss sind.
Wenn ich da zum Beispiel mal an so tolle
Ausgeburten des Map-Designs denke,
wie Piccadilly oder sowas.
Oder diese, wie heißt denn
das Ding hier, dieser Palace,
dieses Riesending,
wo die Leute nur
den ganzen Tag rumlaufen,
wo es 10 gegen 10 gibt.
Wie heißt denn die Map, ich bin nicht drauf gekommen.
Heißt die nicht vielleicht sogar Palace?
Ja, genau.
Wo das nie bis zum Punkte-Level geht.
Das ist total Fail.
Diese ganzen Map-Designs
sind so schlecht dieses Jahr,
also ich hab eigentlich Maps,
wo ich mich freue, dass ich sie spiele,
sind eigentlich nur Rast oder Shipment,
wenn man mal ganz ehrlich ist.
Shoothouse finde ich noch, okay,
es gibt Schlimmeres, weil Shoothouse
ist so die einzige Map, die aus diesem
COD wirklich noch Bestand
haben wird. Vielleicht auch noch
Gunrunner, das wird competitive
richtig das Spiel, also da wird immer
versuchen und zerstören drauf zu spielen.
Ist auch mit die beste Map, finde ich.
Ja, also für Competitive ist Gunrunner
eigentlich die beste Map geworden.
Aber dann gab es ja noch so ein Nachmachen
von Scrapyard oder Hardhead, also
habe ich mich wirklich drauf gefreut,
weil eigentlich alle alten Maps
quasi die besten Maps waren
im neuen MW.
Aber die haben die ja auch nicht hinbekommen,
weil Scrapyard finde ich richtig krebs
zu spielen. Scrapyard ist übelst
reudig jetzt geworden im Remake.
Aber du kannst einfach in MW auch viel zu viel
in den Ecken hocken und rumcampen
und machen, was halt in MW2
nicht ganz so extrem gewesen ist.
Ania Palace, ja genau,
Hergi, genau das meine ich.
Die Map ist so schlecht.
Und Hardhead ist einfach
so dunkel und viel zu groß
geraten, dass man irgendwie so
gar nicht den MW3-Vibe
wieder zurückbekommen kann.
Ja, man sieht halt auch, wenn man sich so Sachen
wie Strike oder so anguckt, das mit dem Heli da in der Mitte,
aus COD 4,
das ist halt
eine Map, die kommt aus einem Spiel,
wo du nicht so viel rumklettern kannst.
Oh, das war POG-Headshot, guckt euch das mal an hier.
Eine Map,
die kommt aus einem Spiel, wo du nicht
so viel rumklettern kannst, wo du nicht so viel
um die Ecke gucken kannst und nicht halt
so viel möglichst...
Wie sie rumschreien im Hintergrund.
Und das ist halt natürlich ein Unterschied,
ob du jetzt drei, vier Winkel hast,
wo du was machen kannst auf der Map
oder quasi an jeder Ecke irgendwo drüber gucken kannst.
Deswegen finde ich, funktioniert halt Strike
in dem Game auch nicht richtig. Guck mal!
16 zu 5, der andere
Typ hat 0, Alter!
Nicht gecarried, obwohl es eine
der besten Maps in COD 4 war.
Also die ganzen Remakes...
Ja, gut. Du hast ja schon gesagt, Shipment.
Ich finde, es sagt einiges über die Maps aus,
wenn Shipment die Map ist,
über die man sich am meisten freut.
Ja, aber das ist die Map, wo halt jeder
drauf seine Waffen grindet, weil der da...
Aber jetzt, da wollte ich eigentlich noch ein bisschen
mehr drauf rumreiten in dem Video, haben wir da nicht gemacht.
Aber ich finde, es sagt wirklich viel über
die Maps in dem Spiel aus, wenn
Rust und Shipment die beliebtesten
Maps sind. Ich meine, Shipment ist
absoluter Dreck, wenn man es mal
Map-Design-technisch sieht.
Rust auch.
Da ist ja Nuketown noch besser.
Und Nuketown ist
schon, fand ich von Anfang an, ziemlicher
Müll. Aber okay. Aber wenn Shipment
und Rust die beliebtesten Maps
sind in einem Spiel, wo
man tatsächlich Maps
drin hat, die zumindest
handwerklich gut gemacht sind, also
praktisch, vom Gameplay her nicht so,
das sagt alles aus. Also da hat man die restlichen
Maps verkackt. Wenn Shipment und Rust
wirklich die beliebtesten Maps sind,
spricht das nicht für die anderen Maps.
Und was man auch daran
sieht, ist, dass viele Leute nur noch Multiplayer
spielen, um Waffen zu leveln.
Die spielen Warzone und spielen die Multiplayer nur zum Waffenleveln.
Und dann ist natürlich
sowas wie Shipment toll, aber ansonsten
spielt die Multiplayer
keiner mehr des Multiplayer-Willens.
Was für Sprint schon richtig heftig
ist und
ich finde noch eine Sache dabei,
die man halt beachten muss, ist auch das
Skill-Based-Matchmaking. Haben wir noch gar nicht drüber geredet.
Wow, wow, willst du das wirklich
aufmachen jetzt? Nur
so viel dazu. Also dank
Skill-Based-Matchmaking findet
man halt Gegner, die quasi,
oder halt andere Spieler, die quasi
auf dem selben Niveau, wie man selber
ist. Und wenn man dann halt einigermaßen schon
seine Laufwege und sein Movement hat,
spielt man dann auf einmal gegen Leute, die
das genauso haben. Und dann
macht sich nämlich die Map quasi
erst richtig bemerkbar, ob
die Fehler hat oder ob die quasi so
Vorteile, also unfaire
Vorteile irgendwo hat, wenn man sich
einfach nur vercampt zum Beispiel. Wenn man nämlich
gegen Leute spielt, die
schlechter sind als man selber, dann kann man die
egal ob man einen Nachteil hat, dann kann man
den Nachteil quasi so wieder gut machen.
Aber da man ja quasi auf dem gleichen
Level spielt,
hat man so durch Skill-Based-Matchmaking
eigentlich nur die ganze Zeit einen
Fifty-Fifty-Krampf, würde
ich eher sagen. Ja, es ist halt
genauso ist es im Endeffekt.
Das ist auch das, warum mir Skill-Based-Matchmaking
nicht gefällt, weil es einfach permanent
ultraanstrengend ist. Und keiner
so wirklich, also nie
jemand wirklich mal richtig
herausragend gut ist. So
langweilig einfach nur. Anstrengend und
langweilig in einem, auch wenn es sich
widersprüchlich anhört. Es ist halt
für alle Seiten megaanstrengend. Also du musst
quasi komplett alles geben, permanent,
dass du so auf deine
so 50-50 kommst im Endeffekt.
Ich meine, die Games, wo du mal
irgendwie 30-5
hast oder so. 30-5 ist so ein Score,
das konntest du vielleicht mal 2010 hochladen.
Scheiterhaufen aus Money sagt,
er versteht nicht, warum Rust so beliebt ist.
In MW2 war es beliebt,
weil die da alle 360 No-Scope
Sniper-Duelle gemacht haben. Ansonsten verstehe ich
den Sinn auch nicht, weil Rust ist eine ziemliche
Kack-Map. Genauso wie Shipment.
Danach nicht.
Danach unter 100 zu
1 oder so, ging dann eine Zeit lang nichts
mehr auf YouTube, ja. Aber jetzt mal
ganz im Ernst. Jetzt, wenn du 30-5
in MW2 hast, da ist das schon,
also auf einer normalen Map, jetzt nicht unbedingt Shipment
oder Rust,
dann ist das schon ein ziemlich, ziemlich guter Score.
Also,
ich finde da auch, dass die KDs,
wenn ich mir mal in diese
Statistiken reingehe, habe ich, also
die KDs waren früher alles. Heutzutage
guckt sich das fast keiner mehr an,
weil, wenn man gegen Gleiches spielt, dann
hat man halt im Endeffekt
eher gegen 1 eine KD als
eine 4,5er KD.
Also, ich hatte damals in MW2
über 300.000 Kills und
glaube ich eine 7,5er
KD overall.
Aber jetzt hänge ich bei, ich glaube
1,7 oder sowas rum. Und das
ist schon richtig gut.
7,5er KD. Easy. Easy
Flex, ja.
Das kannst du aber
voll vergessen, ne. Also,
wenn man sich das mal anguckt.
MW2 7,1 KD.
Modern Warfare 1,5.
Es ist halt schon ein Unterschied. Man merkt
halt einfach, dass man gegen gute Gegner spielt.
Im Vergleich zu dem, was
meine ganzen Kollegen haben.
Und ich finde aber auch,
dass das auch ein bisschen so den Spaß
nimmt für den normalen Multiplayer, weil jedes Spiel
ESL Finals gefühlt sind.
Ja, genau. Ja.
Sehe ich auch so.
Kann halt... Easy.
Es ist halt auch anstrengend,
also, dass es wirklich Arbeit hat.
Wie die im Hintergrund rumschreien im Gameplay, Alter.
Wenn du diesen Multiplayer spielen willst und da auch fokussiert
bei der Sache bist. Also, das ist wirklich anstrengend auf Dauer.
Und was ich halt auch
früher immer gut fand am
Call of Duty Multiplayer. Du hast Runden,
da hast du halt extrem krass auf den Sack gekriegt.
Aber du hast dann auch Runden gehabt, da hast du übelst
die Gegner zerstört. Und
jetzt ist es immer so ein Zwischending.
Klar, du hast mal
ab und zu Runden dazwischen, die ganz
gut sind. Aber
das ist irgendwie nicht mehr das gleiche.
Und eine Sache, die müssen wir
auch erwähnen, wenn wir grad noch
hier kurz bei dieser Skill-Based-Matchmaking-Geschichte
sind. Was uns übrigens auch in Black Ops
gehalten bleibt.
Man hat es übrigens schon in der Black Ops Beta gesehen,
was Skill-Based-Matchmaking angeht.
Du hast eine Runde gespielt
und danach war wieder komplett
Pause-Champ.
Also, Pace-Champ
war es direkt danach.
Weiß nicht, ob ihr das auch hattet. Eins, zwei
Runden gespielt, danach ging es schon wieder
komplett bergab.
Eine Sache, die das ganz stark
ausgelöst hat, mehr als in Call of Duty
davor, ist diese ganze Reverse-Boosting-Geschichte.
Das ist halt
absolut witzlos mittlerweile.
Wenn du da guckst, dass du auf YouTube
Gameplays hast, die so
weit fernab von der Realität
sind, wo du halt quasi
siehst, okay, der Typ, der hat sich jetzt einfach
mal 50 Runden selbst gekillt oder hat sich
einen neuen Account gemacht oder spielt mit einem Kollegen
auf einer anderen Plattform, der Level 1
ist, zusammen. Das ist halt so
ein Ding,
da sieht man, dass das eigentlich nicht das ist, was
die Leute wollen im Multiplayer.
Ja, ich glaube, das kann man gar nicht so allgemein
sehen, wie ich das da sage. Was
die Leute, die ich, also inklusive
mir und die ich kenne nicht wollen,
es gibt bestimmt, es hat ja seinen Grund, dass
Skill-Based Matchmaking drin ist,
es gibt bestimmt genug, denen das gefällt,
weil die sind ja
bei Activision auch nicht doof.
Also was so
Metriken auswerten und Zahlen auswerten angeht,
das können die mit Sicherheit, weil
umso mehr Zeit die Leute in dem Game verbringen,
umso mehr kaufen die sich Scheiß und umso mehr Geld gibt's.
Also, das ist
nichts, um die Leute abzufacken,
Skill-Based Matchmaking, das erfüllt nicht,
mit Sicherheit, seinen Sinn, nämlich
mehr Geld für Activision.
Alex V sagt im Chat, ich hab zu AW-Zeiten
Reverse-Boosting-Accounts verkauft,
damit kann man bestimmt sogar in Modern
Warfare Geld machen.
Top Idee, wir
programmieren einen Machine Learning Reverse
Boost Bot und verkaufen's
dann auf eBay, easy.
Easy.
Also, ich glaube, das ist
das 20. Mal.
Und wenn ich dann mit dem spiele, dann krieg ich auch mal
einen 150-Kill-Gameplay hin.
Aber es fühlt sich halt dann auch nicht so an,
weil man dann auch gegen Easy-Bot spielen kann
und genau das Gleiche rauskommt.
Ist auch nicht der Sinn der Sache.
Deswegen ist sowas wie diese 130-Plus
Warzone-Killgames...
äh, weiß ich jetzt auch nicht,
was ich davon halten soll.
Also, ich persönlich find das jetzt nicht so
so ein großes Achievement.
Also, ich mein, das ist bestimmt nicht einfach
zu erreichen, trotzdem.
Aber so richtig
auf die Fahne schreiben würde ich mir halt auch nicht,
dass ich so offensichtlich irgendwas
am Spiel modifiziert hab,
dass ich gegen Leute spiele, die
eigentlich nicht mich als Gegner verdient haben.
Ja, ich denk,
das seh ich ähnlich.
Diese Reverse-Boosting-Geschichte,
was mir da
ein bisschen auf den Sack geht, ist
gar nicht so sehr, wenn einer das macht,
sondern wenn's dann Leute
gibt, die so tun, als hätten sie es
nicht gemacht, aber offensichtlich
Reverse-Boosted das Gameplay verwenden.
Das find ich halt immer affig.
Da, da gibt's genug große YouTube-Channels,
die permanent irgendwelche Wins
hochladen, so nach dem Motto, ähm,
ich spiele Solo-Warzone
gegen Dreierteams
und sowas. Easy Win!
Wo ich mir auch denk, jaja, garantiert.
Garantiert Easy Win und garantiert
nicht in irgendeiner Art und Weise Reverse-Boosted.
Wenn die sagen würden, Reverse-Boosted,
das zumindest nicht abstreiten würden,
dass es Reverse-Boosted ist,
das, äh, dann wär das ja noch in Ordnung.
Letztendlich gibt's das Spiel her.
Aber wenn das dann Leute sind, die sagen so nach dem Motto,
ähm, komplett 100%
legit, äh, quasi
never Reverse-Boosted in my life, so nach dem Motto,
nee. Wenn ich dann die
Gameplays seh, wo du halt wirklich
vier Leute hast, die mit zu den Besten in der Welt gehören
und die irgendwie gefühlt
schon 500 Games am Stück
gecrindet haben und jetzt halt mal ein
super krasses Gameplay dabei ist, was
halt in diese Region geht. Genau, und das sieht man
nämlich auch, wenn man sich mal wirklich die richtig guten
Spiele anguckt auf Twitch, auch
die Warzone-Spiele, die haben schon
krasse Runden. Äh, Korean
Savage ist tatsächlich so ein Kandidat,
ja, der unter anderem, ja, eigentlich
Reverse-Boosted nicht, aber dann guckst du dir Gameplays an,
eins gegen vierer Squads, Easy Win, ja.
Ähm, ja, wenn du dir wirklich
die guten Spieler auf Twitch anguckst, die haben
krasse Runden, ja. Aber wenn du dir beispielsweise,
ich guck ja ab und zu nochmal Huskers
und wenn du dir das anguckst, der wird teilweise so
unsinnig weggecampt
in diesem Spiel, ja, wo der
auch nichts dagegen machen kann und das
kann man glaube ich schon, äh,
mit gutem Recht sagen, dass das eines der
besten Spieler ist, die es in dem Game,
zumindest in Warzone aktuell gibt,
wie unsinnig der teilweise stirbt.
Und die machen halt keine
Reverse-Boosting-Gameplays, der spielt
dann entweder halt solo und carryt
alles oder spielt mit richtig guten Leuten
und die spielen halt alles
oder nichts. Die landen dann irgendwo auf
der Map, wo ultra viel los ist, machen
am wenigsten 12, 13, 14, 15 Kills
oder aber sterben direkt.
Und, ähm,
das sind dann so Sachen, das kann ich da noch irgendwie
wirklich anerkennen, die Gameplays, da sag ich so, Alter, der Typ ist krass,
der hat übelst drauf und das sind legit
richtig geile Gameplays.
Aber im Gegenzug, wenn ich mir das
auf YouTube angucke, ähm,
die regelmäßig
und dann auch teilweise, wo nicht mal
die Lobby drauf ist und sowas, regelmäßig solche
Gameplays hochladen, äh, und dann
quasi auch noch so tun, als wäre das
alles mit rechten Dingen zugegangen,
obwohl sie offensichtlich
reproduzierbar gegen absolute
No-Hand-Bobs-Leute spielen
und dann sagen, nein, nein, nichts
Reverse-Boost, nichts, neuer Account, alles legit,
das finde ich dann affig.
Äh, NoLimitXO, dankeschön,
6 Monate Subscription, huge.
Weiß ich dann auch anzuerkennen,
ja, sag ich, ey, super gemacht, aber
wenn ich dann Gameplays sehe von Leuten auf YouTube,
die, ähm,
irgendwie 1 vs.
äh, Quads,
Ich, ich wiederhole mich, merke ich gerade.
...spielen 1 vs.
Dings, sich da queuen, und, ähm,
du dann nur Leute hast, die quasi
komplett ohne Hände durch die Levels rennen
und sowas da regelmäßig kommt,
es ist ja nicht so, als würden die anderen das
irgendwie regelmäßig raushauen,
also, das hat schon so ein bisschen
merkwürdigen Beigeschmack, dass da die Sache nicht mit
rechten Dingen zugeht.
Ja, also, abschließend
dazu kann man eigentlich nur sagen, dass
durch skill-based matchmaking eigentlich
diese ganzen Quad-Nukes
und alles wegfallen, dass
auch Leute wie, ich habe einen
Kollege gesehen auf YouTube, der hat eine
Nuke in Suchen und Zerstören erreicht
auf Konsole, und der spielt wirklich
wie ein Profi,
und der hat auch dann innerhalb von einer Woche
an die 300.000... Wie Profi spielen heißt,
äh, um jede Ecke jump-shotten und sliden,
zumindest.
...subster durch hinbekommen, von 0.
Nicht schlecht. Nicht schlecht.
Und deswegen sieht man auch schon, früher hättest du für
eine Nuke in Suchen und Zerstören
lass es doppelt so viele Aufrufe
sein bekommen.
Und heute kriegst du da...
Also, das ganze Internet schaut auf dich,
als wärst du der Messias in COD.
Ja. Ja.
Ist schon was dran, ja.
Ja, gut.
Ich hab nur noch den Battle Pass
würde ich jetzt noch ansprechen,
dann hätten wir es eigentlich schon komplett einmal
analysiert, das Spiel. So, der Battle Pass
gab's ja davor in COD.
Ja, Killmoves, gäbe ich dir recht. Ich finde
skill-based matchmaking an sich,
nicht schlecht. Jedes Spiel mit einem Ranking-System
hat ja skill-based matchmaking, sonst gibt's
kein Ranking-System. Ich find's halt doof,
dass Call of Duty das einen aufzwingt,
obwohl man
nicht competitive spielen möchte
in diesem Sinn, ja. Ähm, wenn es
eine Rangliste gäbe, dann hätte
es ja auch seinen Sinn. Also sprich, gäbe es
eine Rangliste,
äh, oder zumindest mit
verschiedenen Divisions, was will ich, äh,
Gold, Platin, Diamond oder so,
dann hätte das seine Daseinsberechtigung.
Ähm, weil da könnte man sagen,
Alter, ich bin Gold, hier Platz 5, was auch immer.
Das wäre natürlich eine coole Sache.
Dann, dann hätte es auch einen Gegenwert,
äh, quasi hier permanent
rumzuschwitzen. Aber einfach nur für
Quickplay?
Auch schon, aber mehr so als Season Pass
mit DLCs. Ja.
Und ich finde, dieses Battle Pass-Modell
muss ja eigentlich eine richtige Goldgrube
sein, weil im
Spiele, der sowieso nur
den ganzen Tag grindet, macht das
nichts aus, diesen Battle Pass zu erspielen
oder einmal für 10 Euro zu kaufen.
Und er hat dadurch über die ganze
Lebensdauer von dem Spiel
neuen Content. Jedoch
für die Leute, die dann quasi
den kaufen und dann noch Levels
dazukaufen, weil die eh nicht so viel spielen,
für die haben die dann wiederum so Geld gemacht
und können dadurch aber dann auch alle
40 Tage komplett
neue, neuen Content raushauen.
Also ist eigentlich Win-Win.
Ja, ich finde das System jetzt auch nicht...
Also Battle Pass Level kaufen ist eh
Fail. Also ich weiß, das machen genug,
aber eigentlich bringt's über, also eigentlich ist es
total bescheuert. Ja, aber wie gesagt, machen
genug, Hauptsache einfach, weil man's auch
fertig haben will. Mal angenommen, man ist bei 95
und die Season läuft ab und man will so 100 haben,
aber trotzdem, eigentlich total blöd.
Nicht übel,
zumal es ja auch irgendwie so ist, dass wenn du den durchgespielt
hast, dass du dann irgendwie nichts umsonst
dir quasi leisten könntest, so.
Wenn du... Man weiß nicht,
wie viele das wirklich machen. Also
Say, die Leute,
die sich da hypen lassen, das sind
höchstens noch die, die da letztendlich
existenziell mit
anhängen. Also sprich, wenn ich einen Channel hätte,
der sich hauptsächlich um irgendwie Call of Duty
Inhalte dreht, dann würde ich auch gucken,
dass das
irgendwie gut ankommt.
Ja? Und
du hast natürlich immer noch die übrig gebliebenen
Fanboys, die alles geil finden und feiern. Aber ich...
Gerade bei Modern
Warfare hat man gemerkt, dass das
schon
ziemlich
umgeschwungen ist und nicht gerade zugunsten
von Activision. Also, das hat ja
extrem viel
auch Geflame abbekommen.
Klar, du hast immer welche, die alles
mega feiern, ja. Aber
anteilmäßig ist das, finde ich, nicht mehr so
viel wie früher. Früher hast du ja
eine Sache gesagt, die dir nicht gefällt,
da kamen dann gleich die Leute aus ihren Löchern und haben
dich übelst fertig gemacht, so nach dem Motto
Max, warum spielst du dieses
Spiel noch, wenn du es so scheiße spielst? Ah, learn to
play. Ich weiß nicht, ja, hast du
immer gleich Leute gehabt, die sich übelst angepisst
gefühlt haben, weil du irgendwie ihr
Gottersatzspiel geflamed
hast, ja.
Träumst und kriegst 1300 zurück,
also so habe ich seit... Anzeige ist raus, genau.
Ich hätte keinen Sinn,
jetzt Skins zu kaufen in dem Spiel.
Ja, nee, nicht unbedingt.
Und was man
aber daran auch schön sieht ist,
dass die halt ganz stark draufsetzen,
dass die Leute halt durch Inhalte irgendwie
zum Grinden
getrieben werden. Ich will nicht sagen
gezwungen werden, weil gezwungen werden ist das ja letztendlich
nicht, aber es hat schon
ein bisschen was, die ganze Aufmachung,
wie das gemacht ist,
natürlich sitzt da keiner von Activision hinter dir und sagt
Alter, setz dich jetzt hin und grinde,
aber es juckt schon in den Fingern, ja,
und auf der einen Seite
sieht man da ein bisschen drüber hinweg, dass
man im Multiplayer nicht wirklich Spaß
hat, weil man hat halt permanent Unlocks und sonst
was, aber auf der anderen Seite
muss man sich halt auch fragen, okay,
ist das halt,
hat's das Game halt nötig anscheinend,
dass es sowas geben muss, ja, wenn der
Multiplayer an sich nicht... Ja, gar nicht mal
hier ECRBS,
als der, als Alter4Games noch die Videos
zu Call of Duty gemacht hat, da waren so krass viele
Fanboys in den, in den Kommentaren,
die da rum gehatet haben, das war der Wahnsinn.
Zumal er die Sachen
ja auch immer noch gut begründet hat.
Da war, oh, da war richtig viel
Geflame damals am Start.
Am besten, am besten
find ich immer noch so die Leute, die sagen,
oh, du findest das Game doch nur schlecht, weil du
scheiße in dem Spiel bist.
Das hatte so komplett nichts mit dem
Videoinhalt zu tun, aber hauptsache mal,
hauptsache mal irgendwas rausgehauen.
Dazu beiträgt, dass man das spielen
will.
Also ich find, dass dieses COD war
das, was mich am meisten animiert
hat zu spielen mit der Battle Pass
oder zum anderen wirklich
dann auch mal diese 2v2 Turniere
mit, wegen dem Gunplay alleine, weil
das hat COD mittlerweile wirklich drauf.
Alter Shipment. Das macht mich alle
total gut anfühlen, find ich.
Aber, aber sonst
so aus reinem Spaß den
Multiplayer alleine anwerfen hab
ich jetzt von meinen
ich sag jetzt mal 100 mal, wo ich das
Spiel aufgemacht hat, würde ich das vielleicht 2
mal davon deswegen gemacht haben.
Ja, ja, das
kann ich, kann ich so unterschreiben. Ja, wir haben ja
auch recht viel 2v2 gespielt und das
ist der Modus, der mir neben Warzone am meisten Bock
macht. Ja,
dann hoffen wir mal auf jeden Fall, dass
nächste Woche am Freitag kommt
Black Ops Cold War raus
mit 2v2 angekündigt.
Hoffen wir mal, dass die das
auch drauf haben und vielleicht sogar
noch besser machen, irgendwie. Easy, easy.
Win, würde ich sagen.
GG Eats.
GG Eats, genau.
Gut. Ich hab
nichts mehr auf meinem Zettel und ich glaub,
das Video wird jetzt auch lang genug sein, dass
wahrscheinlich alle schon eingeschlafen sind.
Ne, wir wachen
eigentlich gerade auf.
Hat mich gefreut, das mit dir aufzunehmen. Ich denk,
wir haben das gut analysiert.
Denk ich auch.
Und ich verabschiede mich
an dieser Stelle schon mal und überlass dir das
Schlusswort. Das ist immer, das ist immer das geilste
was soll ich denn da jetzt sagen
zum Schluss. Ja, ich hoffe euch hat's
gefallen. Vielleicht krieg ich's demnächst auch wieder
gebacken, mal Videos zu machen. Macht's
gut, bis dann. Tschüss.
So.
Tja. Vielleicht krieg ich's
dann wirklich gebacken, jetzt mal
wieder Videos zu machen. Mal schauen.
Tja. Also Leute, wenn euch das
gefallen hat, könnt ihr mal ruhig bei ihm vorbeigucken.
Ich poste nochmal das Link zum Video.
Er freut sich über jeden Daumen und jedes Comment.
Also wäre ne nice Geschichte.
Und ich glaub, wir haben das auch ganz gut
trefflich zusammengefasst, die Sachen zu
Modern Warfare. Was ist das
für ein Video?
So, dann schauen wir uns mal an, ob das Ding funktioniert, was
wir uns hier mitgebracht haben.
Also quietschen tut das schon mal.
Oh.
Oh nein, ich ahne Schlimmes.
Moved on. Oh Gott.
Nein, das kann ich mir, das kann ich mir nicht anhören.
Das ist, das ist nicht, das ist nicht wirklich.
Das kann ich mir nicht anhören. Das ist zu cringe.
Das ist zu, das halt ich dann aus.
Oh Gott.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, das kann ich mir nicht anhören.
Das ist unmöglich.
Unmöglich.
Das geht nicht.
Das ist zu anstrengend.
Hast du das
Drum Video schon gesehen, ja?
Ich find das aber nicht lustig.
Du meinst dieses Endgame
Dings Video mit, naja.
Keine Ahnung. Ich kenn das aber.
Okay, komm, komm.
Wir müssen uns jetzt geben.
Twitch Chat.
Those days that are gone.
Twitchimo.
Oh, das ist so fail, Alter.
Long ago.
Make you feel.
So alone.
Oh Gott, ist das schlecht.
Alter.
Vorhand.
Also wenn das nicht Fremdschäme ist, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Besser.
60er Jahre.
Aber es funktioniert. Ja.
Und wäre die Platte besser, wäre der Sound auch besser wahrscheinlich.
Ja.
Oh, das ist wirklich hochgradig Painschap.
Max und Chat hat von euch mal
versucht,
Solaris GPIO Pins auf einem Raspberry Pi Zero anzubringen.
Nö.
Hab ich noch nie gemacht.
Bist doch hier unter uns.
Ja, trotzdem.
Okay, gucken wir uns mal an.
Der Bauer, was hat der Neues?
Der Auer, der Auer ist es ja.
Neues Overclocking Feature verändert Ryzen komplett.
Easy.
Komplett.
Mit Ryzen verändern, okay.
Willkommen zu einem weiteren Video.
Heute endlich sind die neuen AMD Ryzen 5000 CPUs da.
Es wird mega spannend.
Ich kann euch jetzt schon sagen, das ist die beste Ryzen CPU,
die es je gab.
Das ist ja fast wie bei der Windows Installation früher.
Windows 95 ist das beste Windows,
das es je gab.
Windows 98 ist das beste.
MME ist das beste Windows, das es je gab.
Wir werden richtig viele Informationen in dieses Video packen,
deswegen rede ich gar nicht lange drum rum.
Wie üblich seid ihr hier falsch, falls ihr die typischen Gaming Benchmarks
oder sonst welche Benchmarks erwartet.
Wir behandeln so diesen typischen Abseits-Content.
Das heißt, wir schauen uns direkt an,
wie ist der Boost-Takt,
dann wie übertaktet man diese CPUs,
weil gerade auf diesem Board
ist Crosshair 8 Dark Hero.
Da gibt es eine Sonderfunktion.
Wie heißt dieses Mainboard?
Dann wie übertaktet man diese CPUs,
weil gerade auf diesem Board
ist Crosshair 8 Dark Hero.
Crosshair 8 Dark Hero.
Alter, was für ein Name.
Es ist ein fucking Mainboard.
Da gibt es eine Sonderfunktion
und ihr erinnert euch mit Sicherheit,
in der Vergangenheit habe ich immer gesagt,
ey, wenn ihr Ryzen CPUs übertakten wollt,
lasst es, weil dann verliert ihr den Single Core Boost.
Das ist jetzt alles anders.
Es wird richtig richtig geil.
Also seid gespannt und wir legen direkt los.
Und zum Schluss, wenn die Zeit reicht,
dann squeezen wir sogar noch ein bisschen
Extreme Overclocking mit rein.
Los geht's.
Wenn er keinen Flüssigstickstoff hat, wer sonst?
Das Video wird unterstützt vom Webhosting-Dienstleister
und Rechenzentren-Betreiber Hetzner
und seinen Hosting-Produkten für Privat- und Geschäftskunden.
Der aktuelle AX51 NVMe Server
Moment, Hetzner?
Ey, die sollen mich auch sponsoren.
... ist mit den starken Ryzen 7 3700X
Genau so würde ich es auch machen.
Aber hier richtig schön oldschool noch mit DVI und VGA, exzellent.
10 bis 15 Minuten nach Buchung.
Das komplette Rackdesign und speziell auch die Kühlung ist komplett von Hetzner hier in Deutschland entwickelt
und bietet neben 24-7-Support eine schnelle Internetverbindung, DDoS-Schutz und eine konkurrenzlose Preisleistung
mit einem Einstiegspreis von nur 62,64 Euro im Monat.
Mehr Informationen findet ihr über den Link in der Beschreibung.
Beim Vorstellungsstream von den Ryzen 5000 CPUs haben viele von euch gefragt,
werden wir die gleichen Probleme sehen können wie bei Ryzen 3000 damals zum Start,
dass der Single-Threaded-Boost nicht so gut war wie das, was beworben wurde.
Ich kann euch vorab schon mal sagen, es ist alles viel, viel besser.
Und die Single-Threaded-Performance von diesen CPUs ist absolut geisteskrank.
Und auch beim RAM hat sich ein bisschen was getan.
Ich habe jetzt hier ein Corsair Vengeance RGB Pro Kit drauf.
Corsair Vengeance RGB Pro, die habe ich übrigens auch.
Aber ich komme immer noch nicht darauf klar, was für krasse Namen mittlerweile
so 0815-Hardware hat.
1.000 MHz, vorher war ja immer so das...
Killer, Headshot, Fatality, Crossplay, Pro oder was auch immer.
Es gibt bestimmt irgendwie so einen Hardware-Namen-Generator mittlerweile.
Sowas könnte man wahrscheinlich easy programmieren.
Da klickst du drauf, kriegst irgendwie einen Hardware-Namen raus.
Bei 3.800 MHz bei den AMD Ryzen CPUs, da war so das Limit drüber,
war dann die Performance wieder schlechter.
Und das ist jetzt ein bisschen besser.
Das heißt, 4.000 MHz RAM-Kits könnt ihr auch veröffentlichen.
Mit sehr, sehr guter Performance.
Aber schauen wir uns doch mal den Cinebench an.
Also nochmal kurz zum Setup.
Wir haben hier den 550X, 16-Kerner-Mainboard, ist ein Corsair 8 Dark Hero.
Aktuell die BIOS-Version 0099.
Das ist das Aktuellste, was ich von Asus bekommen habe.
Und RAM seht ihr, wir haben Dual Channel, 32 GB, 4000 C8.
Also Leco, zur PHP über Kati kann ich dir gar nichts sagen.
Wie üblich dauert das Ganze beim Cinebench R20 relativ lange im Single.
Schaut euch mal das hier an.
Boost Clock, was ihr hier sehen könnt.
Boah.
Wir sehen auf ganz vielen Kernen.
Fünf.
Da werden uns schon mal vier Hertz angezeigt.
Boah.
Das ist wirklich, wirklich krass.
Warten wir mal, bis die Performance durchgelaufen ist.
Ja, 626.
Das ist einfach nur total krass.
Wirklich holy shit.
Ich weiß nicht, was AMD gemacht hat, aber absolut geisteskranke Performance.
Schauen wir uns jetzt mal noch kurz einen Multi-Core-Score an und beobachten dabei so ein bisschen den Takt.
So wie ihr jetzt sehen könnt,
das ist für unser Overclocking gleich wichtig.
Wir haben so Taktraten um die 3,9 bis 4 GHz im Multi.
Und dann haben wir knapp unter 10.000 Punkte im Multi.
Wie ihr gerade bereits bei Hardware-Info gesehen habt,
Leco, ist das Kati 1 oder 2?
Boost-Takt beim Ryzen 5950X,
gemessen sogar über den beworbenen Boost.
Cinebench R20 mit AVX ist dabei allerdings selbst nur bei Single-Threaded-Belastung immer noch relativ hart.
Wir messen deshalb, wie schon in der Vergangenheit,
nochmal extra mit Cinebench R15 ohne AVX,
einfach nur, damit wir vergleichbare Werte zu den reichsten 3000 CPUs haben.
Sieht eigentlich richtig aus.
Die Grafik, die ihr jetzt hier sehen könnt, ist zwar auf den ersten Blick ziemlich verwirrend, aber unser...
What is happening?
Alles klar.
Uns interessiert eigentlich nur der obere Bereich zwischen 4800 und 5100 MHz.
Wir sehen hier den maximal anliegenden Takt während dem Cinebench R15 Single-Threaded.
Wenn wir jetzt nur den oberen Teil betrachten,
dann sehen wir, dass der Ryzen 5950X im Durchschnitt den Boost von 4,9 GHz auf jeden Fall erreicht
und in einigen Fällen sogar deutlich übertrifft,
mit einer kleinen Spitze sogar von 5040 MHz.
Das Ganze hier wieder Stock, also ohne zusätzliche Boost-Funktion oder sonst was.
Nur XMP war hier aktiviert.
In den meisten Fällen ist der Boost-Takt irgendwo zwischen 4900 und 4950 MHz.
Freut mich auf jeden Fall mega, dass der Boost diesmal so gut ist.
5 GHz ist sehr ordentlich, ja.
Das eigentliche Problem, warum ich ja immer davon abgeraten habe, Ryzen-CPUs zu übertakten,
ist ja die Art, wie die CPUs funktionieren.
Die Ryzen-CPUs haben immer zwei verschiedene Betriebsmodi,
einmal den normalen Mode und einmal den OC-Mode.
Wenn ihr die CPU manuell übertaktet auf allen Kernen,
dann geht die CPU automatisch immer in den OC-Mode.
Das sieht man auf vielen Mainboards, dann auf der Debug-LED, da steht dann einfach OC dran.
Und das hat eben zur Folge, dass der Boost-Takt,
dass der Boost-Takt deaktiviert wird
und dass ihr permanent immer statisch auf allen Kernen den gleichen Takt habt,
was dann Multicore-technisch natürlich gut ist,
zum Beispiel im Cinebench oder beim Rendern.
Allerdings bei manchen Games oder leichteren Applikationen
habt ihr das Problem, dass euer Boost-Takt eben fehlt.
Und in diesem Fall habt ihr ja gesehen,
das sind fast 1 GHz Unterschied zwischen...
Also, Leko, ich helf dir mal kurz.
Ich probier's mal, ich probier's mal.
Ich muss mal kurz hier...
Ich muss mir mal das File angucken, ob ich da irgendwas finde, was nicht stimmt.
Also, das sieht prinzipiell eigentlich ganz gut aus.
Ich mach mal ein offizielles Exempel für an, wie das Ganze aussehen müsste.
Nehme ich Command-Line-File.
Ja, super, tolles Beispiel.
Schreibt man das Reverse-Proxy jetzt vorne hin?
Wow, das sieht aber wie aus.
Also, man schreibt das Reverse-Proxy anscheinend schon mal vorne hin.
Ach nee, das ist für, das ist für das hier.
Oh nee, das müsste ich mich jetzt erstmal mit beschäftigen.
Keine Ahnung, aus dem Kopf.
Aber das ist im Prinzip ja gar nicht so verkehrt aussieht.
Wenn es auf Port 5000 nicht geht, aber auf Port 443...
Also, Telnet geht ja, weil du eine TCP-Verbindung zum Proxy machst.
Das ist normal.
Telnet ist kein HTTP, das macht das standardmäßig auch gar nicht.
Ist denn da überhaupt ein Webservice dahinter, hinter 5000?
Ich mein, Kati macht, das ist ein HTTP-Proxy, ne?
Web-Zeugs.
Also, wenn da auf Port 5000 sonst was läuft, was nicht HTTP ist, dann geht's schon mal gar nicht.
Dann kann man, kann bestimmt noch TCP-Loud balancen, aber weiß ich nicht, wie's geht.
Nee, da müsste ich jetzt erstmal auch nachgucken, wie das ausschaut.
Kann ich dir jetzt aus dem Kopf nicht sagen.
4 GHz und 5 GHz, was wir da reden.
Und, ähm, bei dem OC-Mode ist eben der Boost deaktiviert.
Und jetzt gibt's bei diesem Board, und soweit ich auch weiß, ist das wirklich das einzige Board, wo das funktioniert.
Wenn andere Hersteller das auch haben, könnt ihr mich gerne korrigieren.
Aber beim Crosshair 8 Dark Hero gibt's eine Funktion, wo die CPU dynamisch zwischen dem normalen und dem OC-Mode switchen kann.
Und das ist wirklich absolut brillant gelöst.
Weil jetzt können wir Multicore-Overclocking machen und gleichzeitig den Boost behalten.
Und damit ist es so absolut die perfekte Lösung.
Und 16 Kerner, wo wir hohen Multicore-Takt haben und bei Bedarf auch einen hohen Single-Core-Boost.
Krass, einfach nur krass.
Zeig ich euch jetzt, wie das geht.
Geht natürlich als...
Exzellent.
Das ist aber richtig gut.
Das ist das, was die bei Intel schon eine Weile haben, dass du Multicore-Boost machen kannst.
Und da hattest du ja bei den alten Ryzen das Problem, dass dann der eigentliche Turbo-Boost oder wie auch immer der Kram da heißt bei Ryzen, dass man den ja damit ausgeschaltet hat.
Also sprich, man konnte alle Kerne auf einen gefessten Takt setzen.
Was dann aber dazu geführt hat, dass es dann bei Single-Core langsamer geworden ist.
Weil er das nicht mehr hochgeboostet hat.
Ja.
Aber das scheint jetzt anders zu sein.
Als erstes mal ins BIOS.
Dann laden wir DOCP, um unseren RAM richtig einzustellen, beziehungsweise eben dieses XMP.
Bei mir ist es 4000 MHz C18.
Und dann geht es weiter mit Precision Boost Overdrive, beziehungsweise PBO.
Das aktivieren wir hier erstmal.
Precision Boost Overdrive.
Und dann gibt es hier...
Wer sich diese Dinger dafür immer ausdenkt, diese Benamung, da weiß doch echt kein Mensch, was dahinter steckt.
Oben drüber noch den sogenannten...
F-Max Enhancer.
Das ist ein Feature von Distilled.
Bewirkt, dass ihr im Single-Threaded Load, also zum Beispiel Cinebench R20 mit einem Thread,
habt ihr da noch einen bisschen höheren Takt.
Das auch auf Enabled stellen.
Dann gehen wir zu CPU Core Ratio per CCX.
Und hier haben wir jetzt die zwei CCDs.
Also CCD 0 und CCD 1.
Beim 550X haben wir ja zwei einzelne...
What? Das ist...
Okay, das ist sogar mir zu wirr.
Aber...
Er weiß, was er macht.
Also wir vertrauen mal dem Profi.
...Chiplets mit jeweils acht Kernen.
Und die können wir hier getrennt übertakten.
Zielfrequenz von dem ersten Chip sind 4.675 MHz.
Zielfrequenz vom zweiten Chip 4.600 MHz.
Also das ist das Maximum, was ich bei mir ausgelotet habe.
Und jetzt gibt es hier die coole Option Dynamic OC Switcher.
Und das ist das, wovon ich gesprochen habe.
Da können wir die CPU dazu bewegen, dynamisch zwischen dem normalen Modus und diesem sogenannten OC Mode hin und her zu gehen.
Der OC Mode bewirkt, wie gesagt, dass wir das Overclocking hier auf allen Kernen fix haben von circa 4.6 GHz, sagen wir jetzt mal.
Und im normalen Modus ist es dann eben so, dass wir den hohen Boost-Takt von 5 GHz haben.
Hier haben wir jetzt einen Current Threshold, also eine Strombegrenzung, sage ich mal, in Ampere.
Die steht jetzt bei 45 Ampere.
Und immer, wenn die CPU über 45 Ampere braucht, also das ist dann eine starke Last, wie Cinebench zum Beispiel.
45...
Sind das Milliampere?
Sind das 45 Ampere?
Na gut, wie viel...
Na gut, nee, das passt schon.
Wie viel Spannung hat denn so eine CPU?
1,3 oder so, ne?
Ja klar, natürlich.
Okay, dann sind das wirklich 45 Ampere.
Ja, okay, das ergibt dann Sinn.
Das ist ja dann gar nicht so viel.
Das sind ja dann bloß irgendwie, frag mich nicht, 50 Watt oder so.
Wobei es immer noch ordentlich Abwärme bei einer CPU gibt.
Dann geht sie in den Modus, dass die 4,6 GHz anliegen.
Unterhalb dieser 45 Ampere geht die CPU in den normalen Modus und kann dann weiterhin auf 5 GHz boosten.
Und ist natürlich dann vom Takt hier multitechnisch geringer.
Ganz oben, Core-VID, das ist dann die Spannung, die wir für diesen Fall anlegen.
Wir starten jetzt hier mit 1,32 und verwenden unten nochmal einen Offset.
Die CPU-Core-Voltage, wie gesagt, im Offset-Mode.
Und hier nochmal ein Offset von plus 0,2.
0,13 Volt.
Dann sind wir so weit fertig.
Ah, jetzt, alles klar.
10 Einstellungen übernehmen.
Alles klar.
Vollkommen selbsterklärend, warum das so eingestellt wird.
So muss es sein.
Dann schauen wir uns das im Windows an.
Und bevor es jetzt wieder Leute gibt, die rumheulen.
Oh mein Gott, Roman verwendet wieder so hohe Spannungen.
Diese Spannungen habe ich von AMD und von Asus empfohlen bekommen.
Und ich glaube, die wissen das besser als manche, sage ich mal, Hater da draußen, die sich immer beschweren, dass ich so relativ hohe Spannungen verwende.
So, und jetzt schauen wir uns die Geschwindigkeit in Cinebench an.
Und ich kann euch versprechen, das ist wirklich krass.
Als erstes checken wir natürlich die Spannung.
Als erstes checken wir natürlich mal, ob unser Single Core Boost jetzt noch da ist mit diesen Einstellungen.
Und man kann ganz klar sehen, hier jetzt 4,95.
Ordentlich, ja, boostet immer noch.
Hier waren schon mal 5 Gigahertz anlegend.
Also man sieht, mit unseren Einstellungen ist der Boost auf jeden Fall noch da.
Und der Rest von den Kernen, der ist so bei 3,3 bis 3,6 Gigahertz.
Genauso, wie wir das haben wollen bei einer leichten Last.
Und da seht ihr jetzt 630 Punkte im Single.
Ich habe auch schon ein Multi mal gemacht.
Jetzt sind wir bei 11.000 Punkte.
Im Multi ist es so ein bisschen eine Besonderheit.
Ich lasse das jetzt nochmal kurz laufen.
Da seht ihr jetzt gleich hier die Taktraten, die anliegen.
Am Anfang direkt die 4,675 und die 4,600.
Allerdings, wenn die CPU Temperatur zu hoch ist...
Ach, Leko, ich glaube, mir ist gerade aufgefallen, was nicht stimmt.
Geht mal hier HTTP davor an.
HTTP.
Probier das mal aus, ob das was bringt.
Reverse Proxy, HTTP, Doppelpunkt, Doppelslash, Port.
Probier das mal so.
Mir ist gerade eingefallen.
Ich habe gerade nochmal...
Nebenbei auf dem zweiten Rechner draufgeguckt.
Schreibt mal HTTP davor.
Hoch wird es.
Dann sieht man, taktet sich die CPU ein bisschen runter.
Ich habe jetzt gerade nur eine 280er AIO dran.
Das bedeutet, wenn ich jetzt eine Custom-WACU hätte,
dann wäre das hier noch mal besser und ich hätte noch mal mehr Performance.
Ich bin hier gerade so ein bisschen...
Custom-Wasserkühlung.
Ja, für den Bauer ist das schon Standard, dass man mindestens Wasserkühlung hat.
Bei ihm ist ja das nächste Abgehör erstmal Stickstoff.
Ich habe immer einen riesen Bogen von Wasserkühlung gemacht.
Ich kann euch ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so sagen, warum.
Ich haue mir zwar die fettesten Noctua-Lüfter drauf,
aber Wasserkühlung war eigentlich nichts.
Wow.
Das wird ordentlich warm für Wasserkühlung trotzdem.
90 Grad, 87 Grad, 88 Grad.
Das ist schon mal eine Hausnummer.
Aber das zeigt, was auf jeden Fall rein theoretisch möglich wäre,
wenn ihr noch bessere Kühlung hättet.
Aber trotzdem 11.100 Punkte.
Und wie anfangs angesprochen und versprochen,
werden wir auch ein bisschen Flüssig-Stickstoff-Overclocking noch reinquetschen.
Ich habe hier noch mal ein Crosshair 8 Dark Hero, diesmal komplett ohne Kühler.
Und das werde ich jetzt mal ein bisschen vorbereiten.
Und dann versuchen wir mal, was wir aus dieser CPU mit Flüssig-Stickstoff nach rausholen können.
Ich habe zwar nur 11 Liter hier, aber für den ersten Eindruck sollte das auf jeden Fall reichen.
Ach, ist ja nichts. Nur 11 Liter. Easy.
Das Dark Hero übrigens aus, für die, die es noch nicht gesehen haben,
das gibt es auch, glaube ich, schon wirklich verfügbar.
Also das ist ja nicht an das NDA von Ryzen 5000 gekoppelt.
Gibt es eigentlich 3090 wieder zu kaufen?
Ich habe ja immer noch den Plan, mir einen neuen Rechner zu Ende des Jahres zu bauen.
Hier, guck mal, 10 Angebote verfügbar.
Gibt es wieder. Easy.
Ja.
Das wird ein teures Vergnügen, sage ich euch.
1,8K für die Grafikkarte.
Was kostet denn 50?
X.
900 für die CPU.
Warum soll ich die Karte nicht wollen?
Meinst du jetzt die speziell oder eine 3090?
Nee, eigentlich ist eine 3090 total overkill und lohnt sich eh nicht, weil ich 1080p spiele.
Und für 1080p ist halt Fail.
Lohnt sich eigentlich überhaupt nicht die speziell.
Okay.
Warum?
Achso, na gut, man kann ja auch irgendwas...
Kostet ja 100 Euro mehr, wie der Rest.
Hol dir doch erstmal einen 1044p Monitor.
Ich bleibe bei meinem 1080p mit 240Hz.
Beste.
Mehr...
Mehr Herz, mehr FPS, besser...
Größer, mehr Auflösung.
So, und ähm...
Das wird ein teures Vergnügen, wie gesagt.
900...
Euro für eine CPU.
Dann, ähm...
So ungefähr 1,7-1,8K für die Grafikkarte.
Dann bestimmt nochmal 400...
300...
200-300 Euro für ein Mainboard, je nachdem was das kostet.
Bei 240Hz hast du doch echt bescheidene Farben.
Der gelt...
Also...
Nicht bei 240Hz.
Das macht eigentlich kaum einen Unterschied.
Ob ich da jetzt 60 oder 240Hz bei dem Monitor eingestellt habe.
Aber...
Die Farben an sich sind allgemein bei dem Monitor jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig da so gut.
Und mir geht es jetzt hier auch weniger darum, dass ich...
Da jetzt die optimale Preis-Leistungs-Verhältnis kaufe, ja.
Wie gesagt, bei 1080p lohnt sich eine 3090 jetzt nicht so wirklich.
Aber...
Ich will es ja einfach haben.
Das ist das...
Macht es dann schon immer so viel aus, ja.
Ja, 1440p...
240Hz geht auch.
Da braucht man aber den passenden Monitor für.
Und den habe ich nicht.
Und schon wieder einen neuen Monitor will ich mir eigentlich auch nicht kaufen.
Ups, warum mache ich das jetzt in Fullscreen gerade?
Gucken wir aber erstmal hier.
Flüssig-Stickstoff-Übertaktung vom Auer fertig.
Und das ist soweit auch schon, ich sag mal, einigermaßen vorbereitet für Flüssig-Stickstoff-Overclocking.
Normalerweise würde ich den ganzen Bereich jetzt noch isolieren.
Da jetzt das aber Richtung Winter, Herbst zugeht und die Luftfeuchtigkeit bei mir eigentlich echt gering ist,
spare ich mir die Isolation um den Sockel.
Das heißt jetzt erstmal Wärmeleitpaste auftragen und so weiter.
Und dann den Flüssig-Stickstoff-Kühler montieren.
Und das hier sind übrigens die besagten Vengeance-Pro-Sticks.
Laut Corsair sind die auch extra für die neuen CPUs.
Ram-Riegel.
Da ist auch ein Ryzen-Logo drauf.
Und wie gesagt mit...
Okay, ob jetzt ein RAM explizit für eine neue CPU...
Warum auch immer, der RAM für Ryzen, das ist reines Marketing würde ich mal sagen.
Der RAM ist da kein großer Unterschied.
Es ist halt RAM.
Es ist relativ zackiger RAM, aber...
Der funktioniert mit allen anderen auch.
Hat man da auch echt gute Performance bei den CPUs.
Guck mal, ist das Shep?
Ne, das ist Absicht, ne?
Das ist Absicht.
Die Slots sind wohl in der Mitte tiefer?
Oder warum ist das so?
Warum sind die Slots in der Mitte tiefer als außen?
Warum ist das?
Warum ist das so Shep?
Hat da irgendeiner eine sinnvolle Erklärung für?
Das würde ja heißen, die RAM-Slots sind in der Mitte tiefer als außen.
Seht ihr das hier?
Hat da irgendeiner eine sinnvolle Erklärung für?
...CPUs.
So, noch ein bisschen...
Ah, Spachtelmasse.
...chloridic stream...
...auf die CPU.
Und dann montieren wir gleich den Flüssig-Schicksal-Kühler.
Bei mir kommt jetzt auch zum ersten Mal dieses wunderschöne Netzteil hier zum Einsatz.
Und zwar ist das ein Seasonic TX1600, also ein 1600 Watt Netzteil.
Boah!
Exzellent!
Bei den Ryzen 5000 CPUs nicht notwendig, die sind ja immer noch sehr, sehr sparsam.
Gerade wenn man bedenkt, wie viele Kerne diese CPUs haben.
Dennoch, bei Flüssig-Schicksal-Overclocking, man möchte ja nicht limitiert sein.
Und ja, bin gespannt.
Ja, der macht das auch so.
Einfach mehr nehmen, als man braucht.
So, und so würde ich das jetzt bei meinem nächsten Rechner auch machen.
Ich brauche das garantiert nicht.
Ich brauche auch garantiert keinen neuen Rechner.
Das ist vollkommen ausreichend, was ich da habe.
Aber...
Ja, es geht.
Cooles Teil auf jeden Fall und brachiale Größe.
Nee, der alte Rechner wird neuer Streaming-Vorschau-Rechner.
Ich tausche das ja immer durch.
Die CPU ist jetzt für das Base-Setting soweit erstmal einigermaßen runtergekühlt.
Also wir haben jetzt hier knapp minus 80 Grad Celsius.
Man sieht auch, Kühler ist schon ein bisschen eingefroren.
Board geht noch, ist eigentlich noch gar nicht so viel Eisbildung da.
Also Kondenswasser dementsprechend eigentlich auch noch gar nicht.
Die Ausgangskonfiguration ist sehr ähnlich dem, was wir gerade eben schon hatten.
Nur mit dem Unterschied, dass wir jetzt nicht mehr eben diesen OC-Switcher haben.
Ordentlich, ja.
Sondern permanent gleiche Spannung, gleiche Kerne oder gleiche Taktrate auf allen Kernen.
Wir haben jetzt hier 16 Kerne mit jeweils 5 Gigahertz.
Hier immer noch 4000 C18, also da haben wir nichts geändert.
1,45 Volt, das ist unser Startpunkt.
Probieren wir mal kurz den Cinebench R20, ob alles stabil ist.
Sieht gut aus.
Und da haben wir schon mal 12.500 Punkte.
Vielleicht explodiert das Haus.
Guter, ordentlicher Start.
Wir sind jetzt immerhin schon mal bei 5,5 Gigahertz auf allen 16 Kernen.
Boah, ey, das haut aber gut rein, ey.
Das ist schon mal sehr, sehr geil.
1,65.
Wir müssen mal schauen, ob das schon Cinebench stabil ist.
Ja, schon fast 14.000 Punkte.
Krass, das geht voran.
Ordentlich.
14.180 Punkte.
5,65 Gigahertz.
14.400.
5,725 Gigahertz.
Die gehen locker auf 3.000.
Die gehen locker auf 3 Volt hoch.
Echt?
MonkaS, was ist mit MonkaS los?
Wieso?
Sieht doch aus wie immer.
Hier haben wir jetzt nochmal ein Ergebnis mit 5,8 Gigahertz, 14.500 Punkte.
Und wenn wir jetzt hier mal runterscrollen, dann sehen wir das CPU Core Current, also
der Strom im Kern, 255 Ampere.
Zusammen mit der Kernspannung liegen wir hier bei happigen 450 Watt Leistungsaufnahme.
Bei mir sieht das wie im Chat aus.
MonkaS sieht ganz normal MonkaS aus.
Ich refresh mal kurz.
Ne, sieht eigentlich ganz normal aus.
Ich habe mich gerade mal entschieden, bei 5,85 Gigahertz mal noch einen Single-Core-Run
zu machen.
Der hat zwar ein bisschen gedauert, aber ich bin mal gespannt, was dabei rauskommt.
750 Punkte.
Wow.
Ordentlich.
Das ist wirklich gut.
Also so eine Zahl habe ich noch nie gesehen im Single-Core.
Ich glaube, das ist wahrscheinlich auch das Höchste, was jemals erreicht wurde im Single-Core-Run
beim R20.
Krass.
Absolut krass.
Zum Schluss schaue ich einfach mal noch so zum Spaß, was rein theoretisch maximal möglich
ist bei der CPU.
6G.
Bei 1,8 Volt und 6 Gigahertz auf allen Kernen.
Ja, das ging schneller, als ich dachte.
Übrigens ist die Temperaturspanne bei diesen CPUs anscheinend relativ groß.
Also bei mir ist Target immer so um die 150 Grad Celsius.
Wenn ich deutlich tiefer gehe, ab so minus 155, geht es irgendwann aus.
Gibt es solche Kühlung auch für Daily-Use?
Ne, ich glaube nicht.
Okay.
Das ist keine Daily-Use-Geschichte.
Das ist so eine Wir-zeigen-was-wir-haben-Geschichte.
Ich glaube, das ist nichts, was irgendjemand Daily-Use macht.
Das heißt, ich muss vor allem das mal checken.
Okay, jetzt bin ich bei minus 148 Grad Celsius.
Das ist eine Besonderheit, finde ich, bei diesen CPUs.
Das war in der Vergangenheit bei anderen CPUs nicht so.
Also die meisten haben ungefähr den gleichen Temperaturbereich.
Das heißt, zum Beispiel ein Broadwell-E, der endet irgendwo bei minus 90 bis minus 120
Grad Celsius.
Stimmt.
Zumal auch der Stickstoffverbrauch so hoch wäre und das wäre ordentlich teuer.
Celsius, in dem Bereich sind so alle CPUs und es gibt auch keine CPU von Broadwell-E,
die dann minus 180 Grad zum Beispiel schafft.
Bei den CPUs gibt es CPUs, die schaffen nur minus 80 Grad und es gibt CPUs, da kann ich
den Kühler komplett voll machen und die laufen minus 200 Grad Celsius.
Also da gibt es anscheinend eine sehr, sehr große Temperaturspanne.
Das heißt, man müsste eigentlich CPUs selektieren und schauen.
Welche CPU geht am tiefsten, weil die sich tendenziell natürlich deutlich höher takten
lassen, weil ich höhere Spannungen verwenden kann und dadurch die Leistungsaufnahme natürlich
sinkt.
Das Ganze ist physikalisch bedingt.
Bei manchen CPUs endet die Grenze einfach früher.
Die gehen dadurch ja logischerweise auch nicht kaputt, sondern wenn die dann wieder in dem
wärmeren Bereich sind, dann kann man einfach resetten und das Ganze funktioniert wieder.
Scheint übrigens so, als wäre das RGB-Licht auf den Corsair Sticks nicht XOC-kompatibel.
Also das System läuft da gerade.
Alles gut.
Aber RGB ist irgendwie aus.
RGB geht nicht bei minus 150 Grad.
Billig-Riegel, ey.
Weg damit.
Wir brauchen ordentliche Overclock-Ramm-Riegel.
Keine Ahnung warum.
Chic.
Okay, da muss ich jetzt flüssig Schickstoff wohl aufhören, weil da ist es zu gefährlich,
wenn die Katze kommt.
Ja, soviel zu unserem ersten Ryzen 5000 Video.
Ich bin absolut begeistert.
Die CPUs sind richtig, richtig gut und ich denke auch mal Intel wird es jetzt richtig,
richtig schwer haben.
Ja, also die aktuellen Ryzen-CPUs, wenn man das nicht anders so anguckt, ist ja erst seit
ein paar Tagen raus, kann da Intel nicht mithalten.
Mal gucken, was Intel macht.
Intel hat ja irgendwie angekündigt, sie wollen demnächst auch wieder irgendwas Neues haben.
Es könnte sein, dass die rein im Gaming-Bereich demnächst wieder vielleicht ähnlich gut
sind, aber ich glaube, man kann nichts falsch machen mit einer aktuellen, mit einer AMD-CPU.
Auf jeden Fall interessant.
Lasst mich gerne mal wissen, was ihr von den Ryzen 5000-CPUs haltet.
Chic macht schon wieder ein bisschen Randale, das heißt, muss mich gleich mal ein bisschen
um den kleinen Tiger kümmern.
Damit sind wir auch am Ende von diesem Video angekommen.
Ich hoffe, es hat euch gefallen.
Exzellent.
Und ich sage bis zum nächsten Mal.
Bis dahin.
Ciao, ciao.
Exquisite Musik dabei noch, ja.
So muss das sein.
Tja, da ging es schon mal ordentlich.
Mal gucken, wie viel da geht, so für normal tägliches Benutzen.
Aber wie gesagt, ich hatte ja extra den 8700K.
Ich habe den ja damals auch geköpft, Flüssiglegierungen, Metalldings, Zeug drauf gemacht und alles.
Und jetzt habe ich ihn gar nicht übertaktet.
Jetzt habe ich ihn einfach nur normal laufen auf Stock und der reicht immer noch.
Also eigentlich keinen Sinn.
Einfach keinen, eigentlich gar keinen Sinn, dass ich mir neuen Rechner hole.
Ich kann keine Videos liken, sonst würde ich liken.
Ihr seid aber alle dazu eingeladen, die zu liken, die euch gefallen, weil ich bin nicht
eingeloggt.
So, was haben wir sonst noch Schönes zu bieten?
Wie Elon Musk unser Gehirn aufrüsten will.
Ich will mein Gehirn nicht aufgerüstet haben.
Okay, das suckt.
Das gucken wir uns ja nicht an.
Oh, was war das?
Hello everybody, this is TechHut.
Oh, das ist ein Video, da muss ich flamen.
Ich weiß jetzt schon, dass ich flamen werde, wenn ich das Video gucke.
Weil die meisten Leute, die von Windows zu Linux switchen, denen fällt dann auf.
Oh!
Oh! Sieht ja erstmal aus wie Windows. Oh, ist doch nicht Windows. Oh, ich switche wieder zurück. Das war 90% der Leute so.
Wie hast du den Tab wieder hergestellt? Ctrl-Shift-T. Egal. Gucken wir mal.
1, 2, 8. Moment, Moment.
Mate-Desktop. Und das war wirklich cool. Das erinnerte mich sehr viel an die Windows 98 oder sogar die Windows XP.
Gut, dass man seine Brustbehaarung sieht.
Start-Menü mit, wie es formatiert wurde. Aber ich habe immer wieder zurück zu Windows gewechselt, weil es immer wieder eine Art Kompatibilität-Issue gab.
Ich war in der Schule, es war der Hauptcomputer in meinem Haus.
Also die ganze Gaming-Geschichte wird da schon mal unter Linux nicht funktionieren.
Ich weiß, das läuft mittlerweile.
Merkt gerne.
Aber gerade was Anti-Cheat angeht, ist es einfach vorbei.
Sony Vegas Video-Zeug könnte ich nicht machen unter Linux.
Affinity-Design, Affinity-Foto funktioniert auch nicht.
Ganz ehrlich, GIMP ist GIMP.
Okay, Diablo 2, das läuft tatsächlich unter Linux.
Die Elgato Capture Card ist, glaube ich, unter Linux auch nicht so die allerbeste.
18. Ich habe es lange nicht mal aktualisiert.
Das Memeboard hat einen eigenen Ordner, wusste ich gar nicht.
Ja, du kannst da schon viel machen, aber ich könnte damit nicht das machen, was ich mache.
Und deswegen ist es ja schon eine Weile bei mir so, ich verwende einfach beides.
Ich verwende hier Windows und wenn wir Sachen machen, die ein bisschen technisch sind, verwenden wir einfach die Linux-VM.
Und die Linux-VM, die ist ja gerade hier mit, was haben wir da drin?
Eine mit 4 CPU-Kern und 16G RAM ist das schon sehr ordentlich brauchbar.
Braucht ein bisschen, bis sie gestartet ist, weil halt so viel RAM drin ist.
Aber ansonsten, ja, kann man Super-Tux-Cards sogar in der VM spielen, wenn man will.
Nee, aber für mich ist das die beste Kombi.
Linux in der VM für irgendwelche Programmiergeschichten und halt Technik-Krams und der Rest ist halt Windows.
Das Allerwichtigste ist, dass man das...
Und seit Windows mehrere Desktops hat, kann man auch ziemlich gut hin- und herswitchen zwischen der VM und den Desktops.
Warum nicht Dual-Boot?
Na, weil ich dann sowas hier nicht machen könnte.
Ja, das Problem bei Dual-Boot ist ja, dass man Dual-Booten muss zwischendurch.
Wann kommt die Partnerschaft von Hexner?
Ey, ich wäre sofort dabei, wenn Hexner will.
Ja, ich wäre sofort dabei.
Linux mit Windows-VM und GPU-Partnerschaft.
Passt so. Nein, das ist nicht so schön.
Du brauchst einen zweiten Monitor und musst den Monitor umschalten.
Und eventuell noch USB für die Maus.
Also, am angenehmsten ist es für mich tatsächlich Windows und Linux in der VM.
Es ist eigentlich kein Unterschied groß zu Native Linux.
Ich verwende auf der Arbeit täglich das Linux auf meinem Notebook.
Und mal ganz im Ernst, der Unterschied zwischen meinem Linux-Notebook auf der Arbeit und...
...hier, dem Linux in der VM, das merkt man nicht.
...used it and, like, my mom was in college at the time.
So she needed easy compatibility with, like, Microsoft applications, which at the time Linux didn't provide all that well.
Ist ja jetzt auch nicht.
Bei LibreOffice kannst du auch knicken, was das Ganze angeht.
Generell, ich finde ja überhaupt Office...
Ein bisschen vorher.
Generell, Office-Programme, ihr wisst ja, ich verwende überhaupt keine Office-Programme, wenn es nicht unbedingt sein muss.
Mittlerweile kann man wenigstens Office...
...365 im Browser benutzen, wenn es unbedingt sein muss.
Wie machst du das mit den Hotkeys?
Doch, ich verwende die Windows-Taste.
Windows-Taste, Control, Windows-Taste, Pfeil links, rechts.
Ist Windows-Desktop-Switchen.
Und in der VM-Desktop-Switchen ist Windows-Taste 1, 2, 3, 4.
Also die einzige Sache, wo man wirklich einen Unterschied merkt zwischen der Linux-VM und Linux-Native auf dem Notebook,
ist, weil man irgendwelche 2D-, 3D-Accelerated-Dinger macht.
Weil, sagen wir mal so, die OpenGL-Implementierung hier in der VM ist nicht sonderlich toll.
Und Zugriff auf Hardware-Decoder hat man auch nicht.
Also sprich, wenn man Videos abspielen will mit Grafiken...
... oder mit Karten-Decoder, dann geht das nicht.
Dementsprechend ist Videos gucken in der VM hier ein bisschen doof, weil die ziemlich viel CPU-Last verursachen.
Also gehen wir mal beispielsweise hier bei mir auf YouTube und machen mal ein Video auf.
Stellen das mal hoch hier.
Ja, ja, YouTube, geh mir nicht auf den Sack immer mit diesem kleinen Kacka.
Stellen das hier mal hoch auf 1044 HP, sieht man schon, das macht ordentlich CPU-Last.
Es läuft, aber es macht ordentlich CPU-Last.
Und das könnte man mit einer aktuellen Browser...
... und viel rumgefuddelt und mit einem Native Linux besser hinbekommen.
Weil mittlerweile haben sie es ja geschafft, dass Decoder-Support in der richtigen Kombination...
... mit der richtigen Grafiker, dem richtigen Grafiker-Treiber, dem richtigen Browser, den richtigen Zwischen-APIs...
... und der richtigen Browser-Version halbwegs funktioniert unter Linux.
Und vorausgesetzt, dass man guckt das richtige Video an.
Also generell ist Browser und GPU...
... Accelerated Decoding von Videos unter Linux so ein Ding.
Das hat ewig gebraucht, bis es überhaupt halbwegs geht.
Und mittlerweile funktioniert das auch nur, sagen wir mal so, zur Hälfte der Fälle.
So, also erzähl mal.
Das ist vor allem bei Workstation, was ich hier drauf habe.
Ja.
Ja, ist ja im Prinzip heute immer noch, ja.
GIMP finde ich grausig.
Es gibt jetzt ein paar Video-Editeer-Dinger,
aber ich habe mich mittlerweile so an Sony Vegas gewöhnt.
Das habe ich mir auch mal angeguckt, ich fand es eklig.
Ich meine, man kann damit arbeiten ein bisschen, ja.
Aber es ist, naja.
Ich kriege voll Anfälle, wenn ich GIMP verwenden muss.
Ich kenne Looking Glass, das kann man machen, ja.
Aber es ändert nichts daran,
dass man eventuell noch Maus-Tastatur durchpassen muss.
Ja.
Und wie gesagt, das ist ein bisschen,
wenn ich eine Grafikkarte durchreiche,
dann würde ich es auch direkt über einen Native Monitor spielen.
Das ist ja das Problem, wenn du es umgedreht machst.
Du bist ja gezwungen, unter Windows zu spielen,
wenn du quasi GPU-Pass-Through machst.
Oder was heißt gezwungen, ja.
Wenn du Sachen mit Anti-Cheat hast,
geht es ja unter Linux gar nicht gescheit.
Und dann hast du halt das Problem, dass du immer,
by the way, manche Windows-Spiele mögen in der VM auch nicht,
kommt auch noch dazu.
Dann hast du das Problem,
dass du halt die Sachen unter Windows in der VM spielen musst,
weil du eben,
wenn du Linux als Main-System hast,
umgedreht ist das viel einfacher.
Ja, Flo96, ist klar,
als hättest du das jetzt geglaubt, ne.
Umgedreht ist es halt viel einfacher,
wenn du Windows als Host hast
und Windows alles Mögliche machst
und Linux in der VM,
weil Linux funktioniert super in der VM.
Und du hast so das Beste aus beiden Welten.
Also ich wüsste nicht,
wozu ich es umgedreht machen sollte.
Der einzige Sache wäre,
dass man halt,
dass man halt Hardware-Decoder-Support im Browser hat.
Wieso benutzt du eigentlich die VM und nicht WSL2?
Weil WSL2 für Kommandozeilen-Sachen vielleicht noch geht,
aber zumal,
also sagen wir mal so,
halbwegs Kommando,
das Windows-Terminal ist halt auch mega Sack.
Selbst das Neue ist immer noch ziemlicher Sack.
Aber spätestens bei grafischen Programmen hört es halt auf.
Du kannst zwar den X-Server installieren,
aber das ist viel, viel harder,
wirklicher als das in der Linux-VM laufen zu lassen.
Also die Grafikausgabe ist,
das merkst du auch,
wenn du Fenster resizest,
dann ruckelst rum und so.
Also das ist viel, viel weicher,
wenn du das in der VM machst.
Ja, siehst du, Basti,
das ist schön, dass das alles geht,
aber warum sollte ich mich überhaupt
mit dieser Thematik auseinandersetzen,
wenn ich das Beste hinbekomme,
inklusive, dass ich garantiert keine Latency habe,
nichts anderes,
was mir da so anpassen muss,
wenn ich einfach Windows benutze und Linux in der VM.
Das Einzige natürlich,
was mir da so als Gegenargument einfällt,
ist, man möchte halt unbedingt Linux haben,
weil halt Linux und Open Source
und Linux besser und sonst wie,
dann ist es okay, dann kann man das machen,
dann muss man sich halt mit Windows in der VM rumschlagen.
Es ist deutlich einfacher,
Linux in der VM zu betreiben
und alles das zu machen,
was man unter Linux machen will
und dann unter Windows
das zu machen, was man unter Windows machen will,
auf dem Host,
als umgedreht,
weil Windows in der VM
viel ekliger zu konfigurieren ist
und du mehr machen musst,
dadurch, dass du halt die komplizierten Sachen,
wie Spiele unter Windows machen willst.
Genau, weg von Windows als Hauptsystem,
genau, das ist das Einzige,
was dann auch der Grund ist letztendlich.
Wenn man damit keine Probleme hat,
Windows als Hauptsystem,
und ich bin da mittlerweile schmerzfrei,
ich nehme die Kombination,
die am besten funktioniert
und für mich funktioniert am besten
die Kombination Windows als Hauptsystem
und Linux in der VM.
Auf der Arbeit ist es anders,
auf der Arbeit habe ich nur Linux
auf meinem Notebook installiert
und habe noch eine Windows VM für Zeugs,
was ich ab und zu mal brauche.
Da ist es genau umgedreht,
aber da mache ich auch die ganzen Sachen,
die ich hier daheim auf Windows mache, nicht.
Reicht die kostenlose Version von VM?
Theoretisch schon,
du kannst auch VirtualBox verwenden,
aber ich finde die,
wie man so schön sagt,
die User Experience,
finde ich besser
mit VMware Workstation.
Gefällt mir einfach besser.
Kostet auch nicht so die Welt.
Die haben bei Weihnachten immer,
die haben vor Weihnachten
immer so eine Aktion.
Irgendwie habe ich so den Eindruck,
dass das kein legit Key ist.
Ich weiß auch nicht.
Ich traue mich gar nicht,
die Seite aufzumachen.
Moment, da gehen wir mal
mit meiner Linux VM drauf.
Okay.
Das Software Kong,
klingt schon unglaublich
vertrauenserweckend, oder?
Der Software Kong.
Wollen wir uns mal
den Software Kong angucken.
Kannst du mal
VMware Workstation zeigen?
Ja, hier.
Da, VMware Workstation.
Es hat halt,
es sieht halt aufgeräumter aus
als VirtualBox.
Aber ansonsten kann es
Snapshots machen,
alle möglichen Sachen.
Das ist schon relativ ähnlich.
Software Kong.
Alles akzeptieren, easy.
Ich bin ja geneigt dazu,
das mal zu kaufen
und zu gucken, ob es funktioniert.
Ich meine, das ist einfach mal.
Aktivierung online.
Zur Umfänglichkeit
ist keine Registrierung möglich.
Hä?
Ja, was denn jetzt?
Ach nee, Aktivierung online.
Keine.
Ja gut, dass man sich
registrieren kann oder so,
ist ja egal.
Schon billig.
Was kostet es denn
für 50 Geräte?
Kaufachtung, easy.
Was war das andere hier?
Das war auch Gamivo.
Warum zeigt es es mir
hier gar nicht erst an?
Das sieht auch wahnsinnig
vertrauenserweckend aus.
Ja.
Null.
Ja gut.
Also, dann würde ich mir
lieber,
dann würde ich mal
so ein Key ausprobieren hier.
Bevor ich mir das kaufe
für 200 Euro,
dann einfach hier, easy,
mal so ein Key kaufen.
Wisst ihr,
wir haben sogar Leute im Chat,
die sagen,
dass Gamivo gut funktioniert.
EA Soft.
Was genau hat
Forever Workstation
mit EA Soft zu tun?
Ah, EA verkauft Visio Keys.
Haha.
Ja, ist klar.
Ganz bestimmt.
Also, das ist ja nicht EA.
Das ist so, das ist so
ein Shop,
der einfach mal
das EA Logo hat.
Höchst seriös.
Dr. Folder.
Wer wollte,
wer wollte nicht schon immer
mal Dr. Folder haben?
Was ist denn überhaupt
Dr. Folder?
Für 73 Cent.
Was zum Teufel ist Dr. Folder?
Es gibt so viel Scheißsoftware
unter Windows.
Dr. Folder.
Das ist so eine typische
Windows-Software,
wo es einfach nur so viel Kacke
gibt unter Windows.
Ja,
beinahe.
Also, ganz ehrlich,
für 16 Euro
gibt es ja wohl kaum was Besseres
für Desktop-Virtualisierung
als Forever Workstation 16 Pro.
Und ich glaube,
Forever Workstation 16
ist auch das Aktuelle.
Genau,
nämlich erst hier
vor einem Monat rausgekommen,
vor zwei Monaten.
Also, was erzählt der jetzt noch?
Warum?
Warum ist er denn jetzt geswitcht?
Aber wo ist der große Unterschied
zu Forever Workstation Player?
Das weiß ich aus dem Kopf nicht.
Das gibt es aber.
Das ist,
da ist Forever
sicherlich ganz scharf
da drauf,
uns das zu erzählen.
Versus Player.
Komparsion.
Genau.
Zeig her.
Forever Workstation Pro
versus Forever Workstation Player.
Also.
Äh,
hallo,
gibt es da nicht einfach mal
eine Tabelle?
Eine Tabelle,
Tabelle gibt es nicht.
Tabelle ist overrated.
Brauchen wir nicht.
Ah,
guck mal hier.
Der Chat.
Der Chat hat es schon wieder gefunden.
Ja,
da ist es.
Also.
Also,
der Unterschied zwischen
Workstation Pro
und Player
ist,
was ist Massenbereitstellung?
Ah,
dass man Batch,
Batch,
die
VMs anlegen kann.
Ah,
verstehe.
Lizenzcode
und Lizenzfuchs
nicht mehr erreichbar.
Das habe ich mitgekriegt.
Hardwarerat hat da irgendwas
von geschrieben, ja.
Ich bin da kein Kunde,
aber habe ich mitbekommen.
So,
Haus- und Gastfreigabe geht.
Anpassbare Oberfläche
geht nur mit
VMware Workstation.
Okay,
ich weiß nicht genau,
was die damit meinen.
Vielleicht,
dass man hier irgendwelche Sachen
umstellen kann.
Einklick-SSH
zu LinuxVM.
Was,
was ist,
was ist denn
Einklick-SSH?
Warum brauche ich
einen SSH-Connect
über VMware Workstation?
Was bringt mir das?
Hat das schon mal
jemand gemacht?
Was passiert denn dann?
Kriege ich da ein Konsolenfenster
oder wie?
Ah ja,
ich kriege ein Konsolenfenster.
So was Unsinniges,
alter.
Braucht,
das ist ein Feature,
was die bewerben.
Das ist ja hochgradig unsinnig.
Okay,
dann haben wir
DirectX 10.1
und OpenGL-Unterstützung.
Das haben beide.
Okay,
also,
das braucht kein Mensch,
ja.
So,
was,
was haben die sonst noch mehr?
Verschlüsselte VM,
virtuelles Netzwerk umbenennen.
Okay,
das könnte ganz praktisch sein,
braucht man aber auch nicht unbedingt.
So,
Snapshots,
ah,
du kannst keine Snapshots machen.
Okay,
das ist das Killer-Feature.
Ohne,
VMs ohne Snapshots,
zackt.
Okay,
das ist der Grund,
warum man VMware Workstation will.
Snapshots.
Snapshots ist eines der wichtigsten Features
bei VMs überhaupt.
So,
wenn VMware Player keine Snapshots kann,
ist das schon mal
useless.
Gleichzeitiges Ausführen
mehrerer VMs
braucht man auch.
Ich habe total oft
mehrere VMs an.
Ausführen
verschlüsselter
VMs
brauche ich nicht.
Version virtueller Maschinen
braucht man auch ab und zu.
Verbindung zu vSphere,
ja,
wenn man ESX hat,
okay.
Ja,
aber allein schon,
allein schon diese zwei Sachen
sind K.O.-Kriterium,
warum ich keinen
VMware Player verwenden kann.
Was sind Snapshots?
Ja,
du kannst zum Beispiel
hier sagen,
ähm,
oh,
vielleicht soll ich das mal
alles löschen.
Du kannst ein Snapshot anlegen
und wenn du dann deine
VM kaputt machst,
kannst du zum Snapshot zurück.
Das ist immer ganz praktisch,
wenn man Sachen ausprobieren will,
wo man nicht weiß,
was passiert.
Also,
ich könnte jetzt ein Snapshot machen,
die VM kaputt machen
und,
äh,
den Snapshot wiederherstellen
und dann wird die VM wieder da.
Und der Snapshot
hat auch den RAM-Inhalt,
das heißt,
man ist wirklich exakt
dort auf diesem Bild wieder.
By the way,
wo wir gerade dabei sind,
äh,
ich lösche mal,
das ist ja uralt,
jetzt,
von 2000,
tja,
ich,
ich lösche mal die Snapshots,
weil die brauchen nach einer Zeit
ordentlich Speicherplatz.
Ja,
One-Click-SSH ist lächerlich,
aber der Rest
gleichzeitig ausführbare VMs.
So,
also,
das war's
zu seinem Windows.
Ich hoffe,
der zeigt jetzt bald mal
ein bisschen,
ein bisschen mehr
von seinem Linux,
weil ich will mir nicht weiter
seine Brustbehaarung angucken.
Okay,
was hat er?
Windows 10 Customization,
da hat er recht,
Windows 10 Customization
sackt.
Da kann man nicht viel machen.
Äh,
falls sich noch irgendjemand
an,
äh,
wie hieß das früher,
ähm,
StyleXP,
glaube ich,
äh,
wie hieß das früher,
ähm,
StyleXP,
erinnert?
Was war das,
glaube ich?
Da konnte man extrem viel umstellen,
ja,
hier in seinem Windows XP,
bis zu Windows XP war das.
Da konnte man sau viel machen,
ja.
Das ist natürlich,
das ist natürlich
bei Windows 10
überhaupt nicht.
Und
Linux ist ein Paradies
für Customizer,
das stimmt.
Also,
Customizing,
äh,
Customization ist unter Linux
echt das Beste.
Ah,
es fängt ja schon
mit der großen Auswahl an.
Welchen Desktop
verwende ich zum Beispiel?
Ja,
ich habe jetzt hier E3
und,
ähm,
wahrscheinlich wird kaum einer E3
verwenden,
aber ich finde es halt gut,
dass man sowas wie E3
verwenden kann.
Unter Windows hast du den Standard Desktop
und gut ist.
Man kann theoretisch
Custom Shells verwenden,
aber die sind alle
so richtig schlecht
unter Windows.
Wir haben ja mal ein paar ausprobiert
und das ist top hier.
Das Custom,
also das ist wirklich
ein riesen Vorteil,
wenn man gerne Sachen
customizt,
ist Linux mit das Beste,
was man machen kann.
Da ist Mac
und Windows
bei weitem nicht so viel.
Das ist ja fast noch schlimmer.
Also Mac OS ist ja
der Einheitslook extrem.
Also es gibt,
ich weiß gar nicht,
ob es großartig,
ob du überhaupt
sowas machen kannst
unter Mac OS.
Also Mac ist,
es sieht alles gleich aus,
ja.
Bei Windows 10
kannst du ein bisschen
was einstellen
und unter Linux
kannst du halt alles
komplett,
fast alles so machen,
wie du willst.
Das ist wirklich
ein großer Vorteil.
Ja,
das kann man nicht
drum rum,
das hat er recht.
A couple things
you could change,
like the,
you could change
like the general colors,
kind of.
You could change
your wallpaper,
you could move
your taskbar around
and resize it.
There are things
that you could do,
but not,
Zumal man ja auch sagen muss,
dass unter Windows
alles außer dieses
Default-mäßige
übelst scheiße aussieht.
Guckt euch das mal an,
ey,
das sieht mega hässlich aus.
Nearly,
to the extent,
Du siehst ja auch,
dass das Dark Theme
unter Windows
nicht überall greift
und so,
das ist richtig Fail.
I actually had
a good time
configuring the
visual display
and all that
of Windows
was way back
in Windows 7
with a program
called Custom Pack Tools.
That was the last time.
Das sind so typische
Windows Tools,
das sind so Sachen,
die gibt es nur unter Windows.
Und soll ich aber ehrlich sagen,
ich finde den Windows 7 Look
immer noch besser,
immer noch hübscher
als den Windows 10 Look.
Sie haben ein bisschen
Fensterrahmen
hier verschwendet,
aber ich fand den Windows 7 Look
hübscher.
Windows 10 wirkt
einfach so,
ich sage jetzt flach,
weil es klingt jetzt doof,
weil das heißt ja auch Flat,
also das ist ja so
so Flat Design mäßig,
aber so,
so charakterlos aus
irgendwie Windows 10.
Ich kann nicht sagen,
dass das jetzt großartig
hässlich wäre oder so,
aber es ist einfach
langweilig.
Also mir gefällt
der Windows 7 Look
immer noch besser.
Und ganz ehrlich,
ich fand auch den Windows 10
Look
immer noch besser.
Ich fand auch den Windows 10
Look
immer noch besser.
Ich fand auch den Windows 10
Look
immer noch besser.
Und ganz ehrlich,
ich fand auch den Windows
XP Look
immer noch besser.
Der sah halt für viele Leute
war da viel zu bunt,
aber da konntest du richtig
viel customizen.
...
Also in der Linux kannst du customisieren, was sonst was, was das Zeug hält.
Aber nur das Betriebssystem wechselt wegen Customization, ich weiß ja nicht.
Es gibt so viele Themes, Addons, Extensions, so viel, was man mit dem System aus der Box machen kann.
Auf meiner Produktion-Maschine benutze ich KDE Plasma, weil es einfach so lustig ist, damit zu tinkern, es gibt so viel, was man machen kann.
So viele verschiedene Themes, es ist fast unendlich und es gibt so viele community supported Widgets und Addons, dass man nicht super in den Code hinein muss.
Man kann einfach alles installieren, probieren, wenn man es nicht mag, kann man es entfernen, es ist großartig.
Auf meiner Laptop, wo ich schreibe, nutze ich Sibaro und heute ist es eh schlecht, ich wollte nachher noch ein bisschen Proggers-Stream machen, dann machen wir das neue oder so.
... und Homework machen, ich habe ein Gnome und es funktioniert einfach und es sieht schön aus.
Manjaro, beste.
Und mit Gnome kannst du immer noch Extensions und ein paar Themen verändern, aber wie gesagt, es ist fast unendlich, was man mit der Customization machen kann.
Das stimmt, customisieren kannst du viel, wobei der Vorteil gleichzeitig auch Nachteil ist,
dass du halt unter Linus an vielen Sachen die Dinger hast, die auf den ersten Blick gut aussehen, aber dann feststellst, dass unter der Haube halt die Hälfte fehlt.
Es ist ein Vorteil, 3000 Sachen zu haben, aber von diesen 3000 Sachen sind halt 2900 Sachen nicht fertig.
Ist Ubuntu immer noch am umsteigerfreundlichsten?
Also ich würde sagen, was Ubuntu basiert, das ist nicht schlecht, Ubuntu selbst würde ich nicht verwenden.
Ubuntu selbst ist grausam mittlerweile.
Ubuntu Desktop gefällt mir überhaupt nicht, also sowohl von der Optik her sieht es scheiße aus, als auch Features, die sie ausgebaut haben.
Du kannst noch nicht mal Desktop-Icons mittlerweile richtig anlegen, auf Ubuntu total hängen geblieben.
Ich würde dir Linux, wenn du einfach ein bisschen Linux anfangen willst, nimm Linux Mint, da kannst du nicht allzu viel verkehrt machen.
Das ist Ubuntu basiert, oder Debian mittlerweile, es ist zumindest Debian, Schrägstrich Ubuntu basiert.
Mit Mint kann man zum Einsteigen eigentlich nicht viel verkehrt machen.
Und das bringt uns zu Nummer 3, ich werde ein bisschen über Microsoft reden, weil Windows 10 als kore Operationssystem wunderschön ist.
Bevor wir weiter gehen, eine Sache, die ich bemerkt habe, ist, dass die große Mehrheit der Leute, die diese Videos sehen,
Ah, Sellout, Sellout-Mode.
Es ist gratis, kostet nichts und du kannst immer unsubscriben, also klicke bitte auf den Abonnieren-Button unten.
Ich liebe Windows 10, ich liebe die PowerShell, ich liebe, wie alles ausgestattet ist.
Ich liebe sogar das visuale Appell des Startmenus und die Idee, die da drin ist.
Das ist das Ding, ich liebe die Idee.
Habe ich schon gesagt, dass ihr auch bei mir subscriben könnt, wenn ihr noch nicht subscribed habt?
Ich mag nicht, was sie damit gemacht haben.
Und der Grund dafür ist, dass es nur mit Ads befasst ist.
Ja gut, das stimmt!
Das finde ich auch beschissen unter Windows, dass da Candy Crush und sowas vorinstalliert ist.
Aber ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, so ein riesen Deal ist das für mich jetzt nicht. Das meiste kannst du ja entfernen.
Und es gibt ja auch schon, haben wir jetzt schon öfters gesehen, irgendwelche Uninstall-Skripts, wenn man da keine Probleme mit hat, irgendwelche random PowerShell-Skripts auszuführen.
Also, es ist viel unter Windows lächerlich, sehe ich auch so zum Beispiel, dass sie immer noch keinen ordentlichen Package-Manager haben.
Ich will jetzt ja Windows auch nicht zu sehr loben, ich bin ja nun wirklich kein Windows-Fan.
Aber gerade bei diesen drei, vier vorinstallierten Dingern, ich finde, da wird ein bisschen zu viel Wind drum gemacht.
Built-In-Adware.
Lightchain 09, zwei Monate, dankeschön, exzellent Subscription.
Wo hab ich meinen Knopf?
Doch, Ubuntu als Server ist das Beste für mich.
Wir haben auf der Arbeit zwar nur Red Hat, aber alles, was ich privat mache, ist nur Ubuntu-Server.
Wenn es jetzt sackt.
Paketmanager. Jetzt mal ernsthaft.
Wirklich, ich verstehe es nicht.
Warum macht man einen Paketmanager,
der keine
Pakete deinstallieren kann?
Das ergibt doch keinen Sinn.
Das ist so eine typische Microsoft-Logik,
die sich mir überhaupt nicht erschließt.
Wieso macht man eine Registry, in der sich Müll sammelt?
Eine Registry ist überhaupt kein Ding.
Das ist ja auch
ein hartnäckiges Gerücht, dass das irgendwie
eine größere Registry den Rechner langsam
macht.
Und es gibt
eine Registry, weil es einen zentralen
Ort braucht, um Konfig zu speichern. Das ist unter
Linux ja nicht anders. Unter Linux sind es
halt Konfig-Files im Heimatverzeichnis.
Letztendlich ist das eine andere
Philosophie im Ansatz her, aber
den Zweck erfüllen beides.
Und du hast unter Linux
auch im Heimatverzeichnis, wenn du mal unter .config
guckst, ordentlichen Wildwuchs an
Random-Config-Dateien, wo kein Mensch weiß, was die eigentlich
genau machen.
Ich muss Issue unter 100
Hä? Warum geht das auf
ein Pull-Request? What the fuck?
Warum geht das Issue 122
auf ein Pull-Request? Hä?
Das verwirrt mich jetzt.
Das ist die gleiche... Ernsthaft?
Das ist mir noch nie aufgefallen, dass Issues und
Pull-Requests die gleichen Nummern haben.
Das ist mir noch nie aufgefallen.
Setzt mal, Chat. Hier lernt man wieder was.
Excellent.
Ich meine, es ist lächerlich, ne?
Man macht einen Paketmanager,
der nichts deinstallieren
kann. So unglaublich sinnlos.
Da kann nur Microsoft drauf kommen.
Impf-Rexi. Twitch Prime-Abo. Dankeschön.
Das ist huge. Massive Subscription.
Here, big brain.
120, okay.
Moment. Die brauchen
eine... Was ist ein Draft?
Nochmal auf Deutsch.
Entwurf. Entwurf.
Die brauchen eine Entwurf-Spezifikation
für ein
absolut basic feature
von einem Paketmanager. Das ist so fake.
Das ist so ein typischer Microsoft-verkackter.
Eine neuer Microsoft-Affiliatsname.
Upgrade an installed app.
Ja. Wie?
Der kann auch... Moment.
Moment. Moment. Moment. Moment.
Sehe ich das richtig?
Die haben einen Paketmanager,
die haben einen Paketmanager rausgebracht,
der
keine Pakete updaten kann
und den er keine Pakete eininstallen kann.
Jetzt mal ganz ehrlich,
wozu braucht man dann den Paketmanager?
Was ist die Daseinsberechtigung dieses Paketmanagers,
wenn der keine Pakete updaten und
deinstallieren kann. Es ist ja
komplett unsinnig. Zumal
es ist ja nicht so,
es ist ja nicht so, als gäbe
es nicht schon Package
Manager für Windows, die das können.
Auch das, was die hier schreiben,
so nach dem Motto, das ist, das ist
äh,
stimmt nicht.
Da muss man halt ein Format
entwerfen,
die das, dass das kann.
Ja, ich mein, mal angenommen, ich will 7-Zip
über den Paket Manager installieren.
So, dann ist ja es
nicht mitgetan, dass
ich, ähm,
nen
7-Zip-Exe runterlade
und die irgendwo aufs System schiebe. Das ist ja nicht Sinn und Zweck
von einem Paket Manager alleine.
Du brauchst dann
Install-Skripts, Remove-Skripts,
Update-Skripts, alles mögliche.
Also, im Prinzip so,
wie das ein Debian, wie das
ein Upt oder ein Debian-Paket Manager
auch macht.
Ein Debian-Paket besteht aus der Software,
die installiert wird, inklusive
Install-Skripts,
Uninstall-Skripts und sowas müssen die da auch machen.
Das geht ja, das ist ja nicht so,
als würde das nicht funktionieren.
Dann ist halt nicht auf einen Schlag
das gesamte Internet
im Paket Manager, was es an Windows-Exe gibt
oder an Windows-Installer gibt, sondern
du musst halt
jedes Paket,
was aufgenommen wird,
muss halt jemand nen Install,
Uninstall-Update-Skript,
hinzufügen und
Maintain und pflegen.
Aber das ist ja grad der riesen Vorteil und Sinn
von nem Paket Manager, dass ich das
nicht selber machen muss.
Wenn ich das selber machen muss, dann brauch ich auch kein Paket Manager.
Totaler Schwachsinn.
Also, was da Microsoft wieder
verkackt hat, ist
unglaublich. Also, wie man das
wirklich schaffen kann, nen Paket Manager rauszubringen,
der wie auch immer 10.000
Sterne hat, wozu?
Äh, ne, versteh ich nicht.
Ja, genau. Warum nicht?
Warum hat das überhaupt so viele Sterne?
Jetzt, ernsthaft.
Das ist ein Paket Manager, der keine Pakete
managen kann. Fail.
Windows. Okay, gucken wir uns das Video nochmal
kurz fertig an.
Ja, diese Microsoft-Account-Geschichte
ist auch reudig. Wie gesagt, ich sag ja nicht,
dass Windows gut ist oder dass es toll ist, was
Microsoft da macht. Das ist übelster Kack.
Aber es ist halt
nun mal so, dass vieles unter Linux
jetzt auch nicht so das gelobte Land ist, wie da manche
tun. Du hast einfach andere
Probleme.
Das Beste ist,
ich sag euch jetzt mal
die ultimative
Wahrheit zu dieser
Geschichte.
Zumindest mal. Also,
es ist egal, was ihr verwendet.
Nehmt das,
was für das, was ihr machen wollt, am besten ist.
Das ist das einfachste,
das einfachste
und das problemlosste, was man machen kann,
wenn man sich ein bisschen davon löst,
dass man so
ideologisch irgendwas
besser oder toller oder so
findet. Also sprich,
wenn man jetzt sagt, ich muss
alles unter Linux machen,
hat man ziemliche Probleme
bei den Sachen, die halt nicht so einfach unter Linux
sind. Sagt man jetzt, ich hasse Linux,
ich hasse Kommandozeile, ich will
alles nur unter Windows machen, hast du
das Problem, dass manche Sachen halt einfach unter Windows
sacken.
Ganze Netzwerktechnik-Geschichten
sacken, Terminal-Sachen sacken,
Skripting unter Windows sacken. Also, es gibt vieles,
ja, normale Administrationstätigkeiten
für Linux-Systeme unter Windows sacken.
Also,
ja, das ist genauso, wie wenn ich beispielsweise
irgendwelche Design-Sachen machen will und es gibt
die beste Software für meinen Zweck für Mac.
Dann nehme ich ein Mac.
Ja.
Nehmt einfach das, was
am einfachsten ist,
ohne sich zu sehr
dran aufzuhängen, dass man
unbedingt die eine Sache
nehmen muss, weil ja der andere Hersteller
der Teufel in Person ist.
Letztendlich nehmen die sich ja da alle nicht so viel.
Gutes Beispiel
dafür ist
hier bei mir daheim die
Verteilung von Geräten.
Ich habe jede Menge Tablets mit Android,
aber ich selbst verwende
einen iPhone. Meine Mutter hat auch einen
iPad. So. Und warum?
Weil ich einfach jeweils die Geräte
dort benutze, wo
ihre Stärken liegen. Für die
tägliche Benutzung für jemanden, der technisch
unversiert ist, habe ich gesehen, wir haben
ein Android, die hat ja vorher ein Android-Tablet
verwendet, dass sie mit iOS einfach
um Längen besser klarkommt.
So. Aber
für irgendwelche
Automatisierungsgeschichten,
wo ich die Android-Tablets hier verwende,
da scheißt iOS richtig
ab. Du kannst unter iOS schlicht
und ergreifend nichts automatisch richtig
ordentlich automatisieren.
Geht einfach nicht. Das ist nicht
Apple-Philosophie. Apple-Philosophie
ist, du musst viele Sachen bestätigen,
du musst viele Sachen von Hand auslesen,
Sachen im Hintergrund triggern, geht schon mal
gar nicht. Dementsprechend
eignen sich iOS-Sachen nicht wirklich gut
für Automatisierung.
Da ist Android viel besser. Es sind halt
unterschiedliche Philosophien, die da dahinter
stecken. Und warum sollte ich jetzt sagen,
ich muss alles mit iOS
machen oder ich muss alles mit iPhones und
iPads machen oder warum sollte ich sagen,
ich muss alles mit Android-Geräten machen?
Warum? Warum? Wozu?
Man raubt sich
damit ja quasi
der Möglichkeit, einfach das Beste aus beiden Welten
zu verwenden. Man nimmt Android,
da wo die Stärken von Android liegen
und man nimmt iOS, da wo die Stärken
bei iOS liegen.
Fertig. Wenn es nach mir geht,
gibt es überhaupt gar keine Diskussion,
was ist besser. Man nimmt einfach
das, was für den jeweiligen Anwendungsfall
am besten passt. So diese allgemeine
Diskussion, was ist ultimativ
besser, gibt es eh nicht.
Du musst gucken, was will ich machen und was ist
am besten für diesen Anwendungszweck.
Und dementsprechend hat sich die Diskussion, was
insgesamt das Beste ist, eigentlich schon erledigt.
Das gibt es nämlich gar nicht, das Beste
insgesamt. Es gibt nur das Beste für diesen
Anwendungsfall.
Und gerade, das kannst
du auf alles mögliche ausdehnen, auch ob
Xbox oder Playstation, Android oder
iOS, was auch immer,
Linux oder Windows,
Nvidia oder AMD,
was auch immer. Nvidia oder
AMD. Wenn ich irgendwelche CUDA-Sachen
programmieren will, für GPU-Accelerated
Sachen, muss ich natürlich Nvidia
nehmen. Also man muss
gucken, was ist das Beste für die
jeweilige Anwendungswahl. Fertig.
Und weniger gucken,
was ist, ähm,
was fanboye ich
mehr. Weil letztendlich fanboyen
bringt euch gar nichts.
Muss ich leiser machen. Das hat auch ein bisschen
gedauert, bis ich das gemerkt habe, aber von
fanboyen hat keiner was.
Weil die Hersteller scheißen
auch auf die Fanboys. Es ist ja nicht so, als
hätte man davon was, irgendwas
zu fanboyen. Also ob man
jetzt, ähm,
Xbox fanboyt,
oder irgendwie Playstation,
sonst wie, es ist doch nicht so,
dass Phil Spencer morgens bei dir auf der
Matte steht und sagt, du bist unser treuester
Fanboy. Ich huldige dir
und du kriegst jetzt umsonst eine neue Xbox oder so.
Bescheid. Hat eigentlich
keinen Sinn. Und auch wenn man Spielehersteller,
Entwickler und so irgendwie
großartig fanboyt,
verklärt das eigentlich nur
den Blick auf das, was scheiße läuft.
Und man gibt
mehr Geld aus, als man eigentlich ausgeben sollte.
Darauf sind wir nicht zufrieden.
Wir setzen ja auch viele Sachen.
Deswegen, fanboyen
an sich ist immer, ist immer
zum Nachteil von einem.
Aber ich, äh, ich bin da eh nicht
normal, glaube ich, weil
es gibt auch keine, jetzt mal,
geh mal weg von irgendwie Technik
Sachen und so.
Es gibt paar Bands, die höre ich gerne.
Ja, was weiß ich, die Ärzte höre ich
gern, ich höre irgendwie, äh, Dings,
die Retro Chili Peppers gern.
Oder auch
sich Heavy Metal Zeug oder so.
Aber,
ganz ehrlich, ich will mich, ich würde nie
auf die Idee kommen, dass ich sage,
oh ja, äh, ich brauche jetzt irgendwie
von dem, von denen brauche ich jetzt irgendwie
ein unterschriebenes T-Shirt oder sowas.
Brauche ich nicht.
Also ich habe auch noch nie irgendwie Bands
großartig gefanboyt.
Wobei, das stimmt nicht.
Wobei, das stimmt nicht, das stimmt nicht.
Also, die einzige,
aber da war ich, da war ich noch, da war ich noch
jung, ja. Äh, nee, warte mal,
das war nicht, ich hab gar kein, ich hab gar
kein jung Emoji, Alter.
Da war ich noch jung. Die einzige,
in die ich war übelst so, wie
sagt man da so, Celebrity Crush
oder so. Die einzige, in die ich war übelst
verknallt war damals so, von den
Bands, äh, war die
Sängerin von Evan, wie spricht man die aus?
Evanescence?
Amy Lee oder so heißt die.
Die fand ich damals übelst,
übelst geil. Also,
das ist aber schon, ist schon
ewig her.
Mittlerweile ist die, glaube ich, auch alt.
So alt wie ich, äh, ich,
Puma. Das war so die Zeit,
wo alle so Emo-mäßig angezogen waren.
Ja, das war die einzige,
wo ich spielte so, ja.
Nee, aber ansonsten bin ich da überhaupt nicht so, was
Bands und, und Sachen angeht.
Irgendwas unsinnig zu fanboyen
ist, die ist
ungefähr so alt wie ich jetzt, ja, ja, ich weiß.
Und die sieht auch so
aus, mittlerweile.
Tja.
Früher fand ich die echt nice.
So 2000 rum oder so.
Oder nee, nee, 2000,
2000, frag mich nicht, 2003 oder so rum.
Da war die echt
hot.
Aber, ja, das ist...
Gibt's eigentlich
noch Emos? Ich sehe überhaupt keine
Emos mehr überall, nirgendswo mehr.
Früher, Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof, bist du rausgegangen,
hast du zig, hast du zig Emos
am Start gehabt, heute gibt's keine mehr.
Nee, ich bin 36.
Is out.
Convenient, but you're really
trading convenience for that.
Kind of privacy concern.
To go through and fix all this, it requires...
Okay, also er hat Linux wegen Customization
and Privacy, kann ich sogar auch ehrlich verstehen, ja.
There's a lot you could do, you could get help
pretty quick. Also ich muss sagen, die Begründung
von ihm leuchtet mir tatsächlich ein,
das muss ich gar nicht flamen.
Er sagt, er verwendet Linux,
weil die Programme, die es unter Linux
gibt, ihm ausreichen oder ihm sogar besser gefallen.
Und er Customization
and Privacy mehr schätzt als den Rest.
Vollkommen in Ordnung, kann ich mich mit...
Kann ich verstehen.
Ja, muss ich gar nicht flamen, passt schon.
Was ist das?
Was kubanische Zigaretten secured?
What the fuck?
This is the lockpicking lawyer
and I have something really fun for you today.
A few days ago, I received an email
from Brian in Florida.
He said he was sending me something special
secured in an electronic smartphone locker.
Huge brainer, Brian.
He asked that I pick it up from the post office quickly
and see if I could defeat it before the timer ran out.
Freedom.
As you can see, we have
41 hours and 13 minutes left
until this automatically opens.
Now, I'm not sure what I was expecting to find.
Sind heute alle E-Girls.
Da ist schon was dran,
wenn ich mir so diesen Emo-Look von damals angucke
und mir heute ein paar Streamerinnen
hier auf Twitch angucke,
gewisse...
gewisse Parallelen sind da zu erkennen, ja.
It certainly wasn't some Cuban cigars.
All I can say is that sometimes...
Rauchen in 2020, lull.
...to be the lockpicking lawyer.
So, let's see if we can figure out
how to non-destructively get to the cigars
without waiting 41 hours.
Now, if we look at the main locking mechanism right here,
there is very little flex in it.
I doubt that I could slip any sort of shim in there,
even if this was shimmable.
Das ist ja auch nur wirklich nicht dafür gedacht,
dass es super sicher ist, oder?
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen.
Das ist eher so ein Gimmick,
dass die Kinder nicht mal nebenbei
ein Zigarre rausholen.
Das ist ja auch nur ein Gimmick.
Moving to the back, we can look at the hinge.
Vor allem, warum muss das überhaupt mit einem Smartphone?
Warum muss man das mit einem Smartphone machen?
Ja, das hast du rausgebrochen in null Komma nix hier.
It doesn't look like this is something that just pops out,
like some of these plastic hinges do.
I suspect if I push any harder, it's going to break.
Looking at the bottom,
I can see there appears to be a panel that can be removed.
And at either end,
is a rubber foot,
which I suspect covers some sort of screw.
Let's pry that rubber out
and see what sort of fastener is underneath.
Das erinnert mich voll an Zahnarzt,
immer der Typ mit seinen Tools.
Hopefully it's not a security fastener.
Nope, it just looks like a Phillips screw.
That doesn't quite reach down there.
So ein Set habe ich mir auch letztens gekauft,
von so kleinen, ganz, ganz kleinen Bits
für alle möglichen Sachen,
so für Handy aufmachen,
und für, da gibt es ja teilweise die abgedrehtesten Stecker für Schrauben.
Dreieckig, zweieckig,
ich wusste gar nicht, dass man zweieckige Schraubenlöcher machen kann.
Ich wusste noch gar nicht, dass man ein Ding mit zwei Ecken bauen kann überhaupt.
Another set of screwdrivers?
Nee, kein Schlitz.
Nee, nee, nee, kein Schlitz.
So ein komisches...
Moment, ich zeig's euch mal.
Mal gucken, ob man da sieht, was alles drin ist.
Ich hab mir das nur wegen den Bits gekauft,
weil das Werkzeug an sich macht jetzt nicht so einen wahnsinnig geilen Eindruck,
aber die Bits sind halt praktische, praktische Konstellation hier.
So was hier.
So Dinger zum Beispiel, ja.
Oder so was hier.
Wo ich gar nicht wusste, dass das vorher überhaupt existent ist, ja.
Also es gibt schon abgedrehte Dinger.
Let's try this one.
Okay, that feels like it's coming out.
Wahrscheinlich kann man einfach von hinten aufschrauben
und kann das Geschloss komplett umgehen.
Was sagst du zu den neuen AMD-Karten?
Nicht so viel, weil ich mir noch keine Benchmarks angeguckt hab.
There we go.
Excellent. Ohne Batterie.
Okay, we got this panel off.
Let's get in here. Batterie.
And here is the mechanism.
I can see the motor that runs this.
I can't manually turn it, probably because there's a gearbox.
Nor can I push on the locking lug.
So that probably would not have been shimmable.
I think probably our best bet here
is just to put some power right into the back of that motor.
I could do it with an external battery.
Ja, du kannst einfach den Motor laufen lassen, oder?
Und dann ist es gut.
Or I could just bridge the battery that's in here to the motor wires.
But I want to try one thing first.
I wonder if we just...
Aber ganz einfach, das Ding macht eh nicht einen super sicheren Eindruck.
Unplug it to take the power out and plug it back in.
Wenn man den Strom abmacht, vielleicht kann man es dann von Hand drehen.
I heard the motor move. Let's check it out.
Einfach an- und abstöpseln. Excellent.
Okay, folks, obviously this wasn't meant to be or built to be a real security device.
Genau, das kannst du ja einfach aufbrechen oben.
It's just a fun little novelty for, I guess, testing your self-control.
That said, I've seen more than a few actual security devices,
with the exact same vulnerabilities.
In any case, that's all I have for you today.
Brian, thank you so much for the great package.
To everyone else, if you do have any questions or comments,
please put them below.
If you liked this video and would like to see more like it...
Rauchen ist ja mittlerweile total out.
Wenn du überlegst, es ist noch gar nicht so lange, aber es kommt einem übelst lange vor.
Es gab 2000...
Ich glaube, so bis 2010 in dem Dreh rum war es noch normal,
dass im Zug geraucht wurde.
Also in passenden Abteilen und so, ja.
Das ist noch gar nicht so lange her.
Was hat man hier sonst noch Schönes?
Realer Irrsinn, weil, muss ich vom Acker machen, okay.
Ach, glückliche Kühe auf einer grünen Wiese.
Bei Bauer Dillinger in Bayern...
Ich spreche ja immer, ey.
...ist die Welt noch in Ordnung.
Das ist eigentlich alle Jahre...
Exzellent, Co.
...momente von der Weidehaltung, wie man sieht...
Moment, muss man da wirklich jetzt Untertitel machen?
Man versteht doch alles.
...momente von der Weidehaltung, wie man sieht...
...wie die Tiere glücklich sind und voll das Tatendrang, voll das Leben...
Warum braucht der einen Untertitel?
...richtig Gas geben.
Richtig Gas auf Gras.
Oh, Payne's Champ, Alter.
Es geht bei Bauer Dillinger.
Richtig Gas auf...
Oh, ist das schlimm.
Aber nur für maximal fünf Jahre.
Dann muss die Weide umgepflügt werden.
Das, was ich gerade gemacht habe, war am ganzen Vormittag ein Schwachsinn.
Aber, ja, ich kann nicht aus.
Es geht nicht anders.
Nein, es geht nicht anders.
So will es die EU.
Denn wächst auf einem Acker mehr als fünf Jahre lang Gras,
wird die Fläche automatisch zu streng geschütztem Dauergrün.
Das ist allerdings nicht so viel wert.
Blöd für den Pächter.
Das sind doch so geile Regularien, Alter.
...meinen Verpächtern das nicht zumuten, dass die einen riesen Wertverlust...
Ja, vor allem müsste er das wahrscheinlich bezahlen.
Da steht bestimmt ein Vertrag drin.
...sprich 30.000 Euro kostet Grünland, 100.000 Euro kostet Ackerland...
Und deshalb muss auch Landwirt Peter Oberhofer aus Landshut sein.
Das sind so geile Regeln, Alter.
Weide umpflügen.
Wenn man bedenkt, was das Geld kostet und was da Steine im Weg gelegt werden,
für nichts überlegt man sich ernsthaft, ob man das da weitermacht.
Die EU-Verordnung heißt zwar zur Erhaltung von Dauergrünland,
führt aber zur Zerstörung von vorhandenem Grünland.
Denn keiner will die billigen Weiden zum Dauerzustand machen.
Also schnell vorher umpflügen.
Das empfiehlt auch das Bundeslandwirtschaftsministerium.
Das Pflügen einer mit Ackerfutter bestellten Fläche mit Ackerstatus verhindert die Entstehung von Dauergrünland.
Allerdings kann dies nur berücksichtigt werden, wenn es rechts...
Das ist so typische Amtsdeutsch-Geschichte hier.
Wenn man das schon liest, ey.
Das Pflügen einer mit Ackerfutter bestellten Fläche mit Ackerstatus verhindert die Entstehung von Dauergrünland.
Was ein Bullshit-Satz, Alter.
... mit Monatsfrist angezeigt wird.
Innerhalb eines Monats schafft es auch ein Gutachter noch rechtzeitig zum Grünland...
Es gibt auch noch Gutachter für diesen Kram, ey.
... er stellt fest, ob wirklich das ganze Gras zerstört wurde.
Neues Gras kann im selben Arbeitsgang direkt wieder in die Erde.
Und da haben wir jetzt die Sämaschine.
Und da säen wir jetzt gleich wieder neues Sackgut ein.
Also wenn man da her schaut, wieder drehen, kommt neues Sackgut raus.
Und so wird aus...
Sehr sinnvoll. Sehr sinnvoll.
Okay, das sind auch so richtige Arbeitsbeschaffungsmaßnahmen.
... Grünland zunächst Ackerland und unmittelbar...
Ups.
Genau, Ackerland...
Ackerland-Gutachter.
... war wieder Grünland. Schon etwas aufwendig.
Und weil das auch gegen die Betriebsphilosophie ist, dass man das alle fünf Jahre einfach zerstört, was man wertvoll aufgebaut hat.
Ach, drauf geschissen.
Es wächst doch Gras über die Sache.
Oh, die Wortspiele sind so dermaßen schlecht.
... auch nur für fünf Jahre.
Das ist aber so ein typischer deutscher schrägsten EU-Verordnungskram, ey.
Mega sinnlos in diesem einen Fall. An sich bestimmt gut gedacht, dass da nicht einfach Sachen platt gemacht werden, die man vielleicht besser da sein sollte.
Aber dann zu unflexibel oder zu wenig Agile, dafür irgendwie mal eine ordentliche Maßnahme zu finden.
Ja, Fail. Nichts...
Massive Fail.
So, was haben wir ansonsten hier noch?
Ich will nicht, dass Elon Musk mein Gehirn aufrüstet.
Gut gedacht, aber schlecht umgesetzt.
Zumindest nicht die passenden Ausnahme-Dinger.
Okay.
How we monitor? Oh, da bin ich ja mal gespannt.
Da habe ich ja früher mein Geld mit verdient, mit Serverüberwachung.
Schauen wir mal.
Ah, der gute Rechenzentrum-Sound.
Der gute RZ-Sound.
Excellent.
Übrigens, niemand zieht sich Ohrhörer auf da drinnen.
Also...
Man zieht die die ersten 5 Minuten auf.
Ja, und dann zieht man sie wieder aus.
Also...
Es gibt mit Sicherheit da irgendeine Vorschrift, dass man Ohrschutz aufhaben muss.
Aber...
Ehrlich gesagt hat kaum einer wirklich da längere Zeit Ohrschutz auf.
Er hat...
Stimmt, ja.
Ja, die sind aber auch besser als diese fetten Ohrschutz...
Wie heißen diese Gehörschutz-Dinger?
Diese Kopfhörer quasi, diese Dinger.
Die sind sowas von unbequem.
Ja.
Und man muss sagen, wenn man lange im RZ ist...
Man hört es irgendwann auch gar nicht mehr.
Die Micky-Mäuse, genau.
So, Leute. Willkommen zurück zu einem neuen Tag im Leben, welches ein bisschen unerwartet ist.
Ich habe gerade ein paar PdUs für ein neues Rack-Setup installiert.
Und ein Teil des Setup-Prozesses, den ich durchfahre, ist es,
dass ich ein paar Fans in verschiedene Anwendungen drücke,
damit sie verschiedene Umstände auswählen.
Und ich dachte, weißt du was?
Lass uns einen Chat mit den Marketing-Mitgliedern machen.
Und wir können ein Video machen über unser Monitoring-System,
welches Software wir benutzen und wie wir das alles machen.
Also, ich werde die Fans einladen, sie einladen,
zwei von ihnen...
Neues Cancelling-Kopfhörer ist auch eine gute Idee, ja.
... und wir werden die Systeme anschauen.
Das Problem ist immer...
Eigentlich wäre so ein neues Cancelling-Kopfhörer gar nicht schlecht,
weil dann könnte man auch mit den Leuten telefonieren mit dem Kopfhörer.
Das Problem ist immer, wenn du miteinander sprechen willst im RZ.
Meistens bist du ja dann nicht allein.
Und du kannst halt mit Ohr...
Gehörschutz nicht gescheit reden mit den Leuten.
Das heißt, so ein neues Cancelling-Kopfhörer
und sich einfach gegenseitig anrufen,
das wäre eigentlich richtig gut.
Wow, ist ja gut.
Übertreib's mal nicht.
Jetzt kommt hier der harte Dubs, der Wub-Wub-Wub an den Start.
Die Sound-Up-Mischung ist auch nicht so optimal.
Ist das ein Heizlüfter?
Das ist wie ein Heizlüfter.
Das heißt, ich kann auf dem Graf lesen, um sicherzustellen, dass alles monitoriert ist.
Hä? Warte mal, was ist das? Einfach ein Lüfter oder was?
Oder ich habe es jetzt nicht kapiert, was das ist.
Ich habe sie auf Heizluft gesetzt.
Eine von ihnen ist auf...
Und die andere ist auf 2.
Ah, der macht es da drin jetzt warm,
um zu überprüfen, ob das Monitoring anschlägt, wenn es zu warm wird.
Also, die eine ist auf...
Und dann füge ich die andere in den Feed-B.
Um sicherzustellen, dass es funktioniert.
Also, sie spinnen auf.
Sie sind auf.
Und sie sind heiß.
Ich muss sie ein paar Minuten ablassen,
um die Software zu testen und sie zu lesen.
Ah, jetzt verstehe ich.
Der macht es da warm,
dass er überprüfen kann, ob ihre Sensoren funktionieren.
Das...
Von den Graphen her könnte das sogar irgendwie so eine Art Nagios sein.
So richtig die richtig Oldschool-Variante.
Das ist so diese Default Graph...
Wie heißt das?
RRD oder irgendwie so...
Graphengeschichte.
Das...
Das könnte durchaus so die Oldschool-Nagios-Variante sein.
Nee.
Nee, das ist ein...
Das ist kein Nagios.
Das ist ein Cacti oder sowas?
Was ist denn das?
Ich kenne das.
Kommt mir bekannt vor.
Ist das Cacti?
Cacti.
Ja, das heißt echt so.
Das heißt so.
Cacti.
Hehehe.
Aber man schreibt so.
Cacti.
Cacti Web Interface.
Ja, es ist Cacti.
Hier, guck.
Was die aufhaben.
Ja, also nicht hier wie Cacti.
Sondern so wie...
Wahrscheinlich Cacti ist es.
Wahrscheinlich Cacti.
Muss es ja immer besonders cool aussprechen.
Aber Cacti ist auch die Oldschool-Variante.
So, was haben wir hier?
Zeig mal her.
Naja.
Weil man sieht nicht viel.
Also das ist auch nicht wieder Cacti.
Okay, das ist zweimal Cacti hier.
Das ist irgendwie so eine Rack-Übersicht oder sowas.
Ah, jetzt erzählen sie es ja.
Exzellent.
Okay, dann sagen wir mal.
Cacti heißt das.
Cacti.
Aha.
Nicht Cacti.
Cacti.
Jetzt haben sie wieder was gelernt.
Ist das Rack Tables oder sowas hier?
Ist auch Cacti.
Das ist auch Cacti.
Was ist das?
Ist das?
Wir wissen es nicht.
Das ist auch Cacti.
Nee, das ist auch Cacti.
Warum ist da ein Fisch?
Cacti.
Das ist ein Fisch.
Einfach, einfach Cloudflare davor.
Naja gut, bei denen macht es keinen Sinn nach.
Ih, Windows.
Das ist Nagios.
Ey, wenn das da oben kein Nagios ist.
Weil es könnte auch, es könnte auch ein uralter Zabbix sein.
Aber das sieht so krass Nagios-Style aus da oben.
Bestimmt Nagios.
Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, das was die hier zeigen, das wirkt extrem oldschool.
Aber das gefällt mir eigentlich.
Das ist das Zeug.
Was halt echt funktioniert, ja.
Also, Cacti, Nagios und dann sollen sie, das wirkt schon irgendwie.
Eher so 2005, ja.
Es ist nur eine Überblickung.
Wir haben viele mehr Kameras auf unseren Computern,
die wir sehen können, wo sie sind, was sie machen, wo sie sind.
Und auf der Screen oben.
Ah, das ist wieder Cacti.
Die Screen, die literally nur Syslog-Events auslösen.
Von unseren Geräten.
Und das läuft auch in Cacti,
was die anderen Screens auch machen.
Kackdai natürlich.
Gut, wenn du ein RZ betreibst oder ein Datacenter, musst du natürlich wissen, wer wo ist.
Überall liegen LWL-Kabel rum. Ja, das war bei uns früher auch so.
Also Netzwerkkabel ist so ein Ding. Bei uns waren es nicht die blauen, bei uns waren es noch die richtig oldschool, diese orangenen.
Ich kenne ja noch diese orangenen Glasfaserkabels. Lagen früher bei uns auch an jeder Ecke rum.
Und wir hatten mal einen 15.000 Euro San-Switch als Türstopper. Das war noch Zeit, ne.
Es gibt eine Pay-Version, die wir natürlich auch haben.
Und es ist einfach gut, ein paar verschiedene Monitoring-Systeme, die die gleichen Dinge monitorieren, weil sie in verschiedenen Wegen arbeiten.
Manche sind einfacher, wobei Observium sehr einfach ist. Es sind nur Grafen und es erzählt dir, was du wissen musst.
Kackdai, wirklich gute Details. Du kannst viel damit machen. Es ist sehr mächtig.
Bam! Kackdai.
Ja, das ist fast alles, was es mit Software angeht. Wir haben ein paar weitere Sachen mit Software, aber ich werde nicht weiterhelfen.
Es ist nur ein Überblick dieses Videos.
Also, Pav wird ein Video machen.
Ich werde bald ein Video mit euch machen.
Über den physischen Bereich davon.
Ich glaube, das ist auch nicht unbedingt der größte Anbieter, oder?
Ihr Service-Center-Raum, da ist schon ziemlich klein. Da passen maximal fünf Leute rein.
Und in Corona-Zeiten wahrscheinlich nur maximal zwei.
Das Monitoring sah jetzt auch recht oldschool aus.
... die Monitoring-Plattformen, die custom-Stuffe, die wir gemacht haben, um verschiedene Teile und Pops zu monitorieren.
Also, Pav, wir nehmen dich auf eine...
... kurze Durchführung davon, in den kommenden...
Auf der anderen Seite muss man sagen, wenn es ordentlich gemacht ist, du brauchst ja da auch nicht hunderte Leute für.
Da lohnt sich das ja gar nicht, so etwas anzubieten.
... James, der mit dir ein Lab-Setup durchführt.
Also, es installiert, es spielt mit ihm.
Und einfach ein paar Geräte auf Kackdai, zum Beispiel. Ich denke, das ist es, was er verwenden wird.
Kackdai-Setup müssen wir uns nicht angucken.
Ich habe ein paar Sachen, die ich anbieten muss. Ich habe einige sehr urgente Setups.
Ich scroll mal kurz drüber über das andere.
Das ist Format.
Okay, nee, das ist nicht so spannend.
So.
Leute, ich habe übelst Hunger.
Nee, den gucken wir nicht.
Den gucken wir jetzt nicht.
Gucken wir mal.
NFC-Tags. Nee, das ist auch nicht so spannend.
Barbecue-Pit-Boys.
Was haben die Leute immer, wenn... Wo ich das hier gerade sehe...
Was haben die Leute immer für riesige Setups denn im Keller?
Was ist denn hier los?
Okay, das muss man... Den Typ versteht man eh nicht.
Ich lasse jetzt einfach mal die Musik laufen und labere ein bisschen dazu.
Was haben die denn da immer im Keller stehen?
Das ist mehr, als manche Firma am Start hat.
Schon das iPhone vorbestellt? Nee, wozu?
Das ist aber olles Zeug.
Richtig olles Zeug.
Was ist denn das? Ein PowerEdge?
Kennt man das irgendwo, was das ist?
Ja, PowerEdge.
820.
Gut, was kostet neu?
Das sind so ausgemusterte olle Server, die sind relativ günstig.
Das Problem ist halt, das kannst du in Deutschland nicht machen, weil es zu teuer ist.
Also nicht die Server, aber das hier zu betreiben.
Die Stromkosten bringen dich hier um.
Und dazu kommt, es ist laut und warm.
Alter, what the fuck?
Was macht der denn daheim?
Home-Data-Center.
Okay, der nimmt das Wort Data-Center wenigstens noch ernst.
Nicht wie ich mit meinem Popel-Rack da, aber...
What the fuck? Was hat der denn alles?
Okay, der muss, der wohnt garantiert im Freedom-Land und kriegt Strom mehr oder weniger umsonst.
Damit kannst du noch nicht mal gut Bitcoin minen.
Ich meine, du sparst dir ein bisschen...
Es geht ja immer noch weiter.
Ich meine, du sparst dir vielleicht ein bisschen Heizkosten, ja?
Alter, was ist das für ein Riesen...
Okay, das Neueste sind eindeutig die Ubiquiti-Router hier oben.
Du kannst damit deinen Geldbeutel minen. Ja.
Rausgewinnen wirst du damit nicht machen.
Ich meine...
Was ist los mit den Leuten?
Er hat jetzt einen Edge-Router.
Genau, das zeige ich schon mal weiter.
Dann hat er irgendeine ASA oder was das ist.
Oder ne... ne... ne VISA.
Warum hat er zwei Edge-Router?
Ja, das kann man jetzt nur raten.
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Das müsste er uns jetzt sagen.
Aber man versteht ihn im Video nicht.
Und das ist ja auch so.
Das ist ja auch so.
Ich habe das Video volle Pulle und du verstehst nichts.
Wofür braucht er überhaupt Edge-Router?
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Das müsste man ein bisschen mehr um das Setup verstehen, ja.
MPLS.
Ey, würde mich nicht wundern.
Aber vermute ich eher nicht.
Okay, er hat gerade gesagt LACP-Uplink.
LACP ist, ähm, diese...
Wenn du mehrere Ports zusammen verwendest.
Ja, genau.
LACP ist, ähm, diese...
Wenn du mehrere Ports zusammen verwendest.
Ja, genau.
Link Aggregation...
Genau.
Link Aggregation Control Protocol.
Also du kannst quasi mehrere Ports zu einem logischen bündeln.
Das heißt, das hat er ja auch schon mal gemacht.
Das heißt, es sind zwei SFP-Plus-Ports.
Das heißt, es sind 20G.
Ordentlich.
Das ist nochmal ein logischer 20G-Port.
Er ist erstmal immer schön dran ziehen an Glasfaser.
Was ist denn hier los?
Warum braucht man das? Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Brauchen tut man es, glaube ich, nicht.
Ich bin ja Fan von diesen Keystone-Dingern hier.
Das ist top.
Da kann man einsetzen, was man will.
Von Netzwerk kann man RJ45-Stecker einsetzen.
Man kann sogar USB einsetzen.
Man kann Glasfaser, man kann vieles einsetzen.
Also diese Keystone-Dinger sind wirklich sehr praktisch.
Keystone-Panel, diese Dinger hier.
Ja.
Man kann dann unterschiedlichste Module einsetzen.
Von RJ45-Steckern
von RJ45-Steckern bis zu
allen möglichen Sachen.
Finde ich sehr nützlich.
Glasfaser kannst du knicken.
Ja, guck ich mir später an.
Herz 93 Benchmarks.
Ich kauf mir jetzt eh nicht unmittelbar was.
Ich muss jetzt gleich erstmal was essen.
Ich hab übelst Hunger.
Guck mal.
Es ist jetzt schwierig in der Größe einzuschätzen.
Aber Leute, was meint ihr?
Ah, XD.
Sind das 2,5 oder 3,5 Platten?
Ich würde sagen 2,5.
Aber das täuscht manchmal bei der Größe.
PowerEdge R27 XD
Oh, da hat ein 2020er Update von seinem Datacenter auch schon gemacht.
Hier.
24 2,5 Inch.
Also 2,5 Zoll Platten.
Ja, ich hätte auch gesagt 2,5.
Aber das täuscht das irgendwie, wenn da so viele drinstecken.
Okay, er hat gerade gesagt, er hat 3 Unified Access Points.
Okay.
Ich habe vielleicht auch demnächst 3, weil ich will ja noch gucken, dass ich besseren Empfang im Hof habe.
Aktuell habe ich ja nur 2.
Reicht auch voll und ganz.
Komplett super Abdeckung.
Wie viel?
Oh man, wie viel?
24 Terabyte.
Das heißt, das sind 1T Platten, oder was?
1T Platten, 10.000 Umdrehungen.
Das ist so eine krasse Stromverschwendung, dieses Setup.
Boah, Alter, okay.
Ich meine, so nice das ist, das im Keller stehen zu haben.
Cool ist es schon irgendwie.
Was das an Strom kostet, wie laut das ist, was das für Abwärme macht.
Und vor allem, und das ist das, was für mich eigentlich Mist dabei ist,
das braucht ja auch Maintenance.
Das braucht ja auch Maintenance.
Also du musst da auch ab und zu mal eine Platte wechseln.
Du musst neues Zeug nachbestellen, falls du das noch überhaupt irgendwo kriegst.
Du musst dich um die Sachen kümmern, die da drauf installiert sind und betrieben werden.
Das ist ja fast schon ein zweiter Job.
Und bei so viel Hardware geht auch ab und zu mal was kaputt.
Und die Dinger sind ja schon ziemlich so gebaut, dass sie nicht einfach so mal kaputt gehen.
so gebaut dass sie nicht einfach so mal kaputt gehen also schon recht robust die ganze server
geschichten aber wenn man so viele sachen hat da geht schon ab und zu mal was kaputt ist bleibt
er nicht aus allein um so um so mehr zeug da hast umso höher ist die chance dass man was kaputt geht
sollte ich mal was tolles erzählen nächste nächste woche ist die letzte woche wo ich komplett arbeiten
muss dieses jahr bis 18 ab 18 habe ich urlaub bis januar der dude übertreibt echt warum hat er
da so viele server mit so vielen festplatten drin was alle was das für krach macht was das
für stromkosten weil wie warm das wird ach guck mal da der 120 ssds drin das heißt er hatte nicht
mal ordentlich nutzbare kapazität da also das wirklich maßlos übertrieben und darunter kommen
noch
50 weitere dinger moment so ist das mit off-site storage nicht gedacht also es ist kein off-site
storage nur weil der storage im rack unten drunter paar hohen einheiten ist ach nee er
meint dass er die festplatten irgendwo hinbringen kann also sprich der spiegel sein nass hier unten
drauf und dann trägt er die festplatten irgendwo anders hin alter was einen riesen act ich meine
man kann auch auf sein bergab einfacher machen wichtigste ist dass man sich nicht nur die
ist dass man sich erstmal überlegt was man wirklich backup muss meistens ist es gar nicht so viel und
dann legt man das ganze verschlüsselt im zweifelsfall auf irgendeinen cloud server dem er gemietet hat
oder wenn man ja oder oder meinetwegen auch auf google drive oder so wichtig dass verschlüsselt
ist ordentlich warum hat er da der hat er da irgendwie fünf storage kisten drin
but why
90 terabyte wie kommt er auf 90 terabyte wie kommt er auf 90 terabyte sind es doch
zehn terabyte platten obwohl da nur drei terabyte dran steht du was braucht er sonst soll ich habe
keine ahnung weil es geht
zu
und
,
man lernt da tatsächlich ein bisschen was aber ich würde wirklich den kram nicht
machen wollen für mein home homepage
voll übertrieben voll übertrieben für daheim und hier unten ist nix mehr
usf
da hat er noch zwei wo das ist eine das ist ist ein oder zwei das sind zwei zwei der hat 2
eine zwei haye
zweimal zwei he usv die dinger sind total schwer hatte jemand von euch schon
mal das vergnügen usv einzubauen 16 monate märz ist der kanal hier
wetters so als das video was wir zusammen aufgenommen haben
also die ist mit sicherheit also was ist denn für dich nicht sonderlich schwer
also wenn jetzt der krasse gewichtheber stemmen du bist aber ich würde also ich
kenne diese dinger hier nicht aber ich würde die mal schon so oft 30 kilo 30 40
kilo oder so ich kenne das modell ich habe keine ahnung was ist das für einer
für eine also was die tonne 5 px 1000 so gewicht
wo sieht man das
was der kram wiegt das kona da muss man nach kilogramm gar nicht suchen 28 da
war ich doch mit 30 kilo gar nicht mal so schlecht so und 30 kilo mag jetzt für
den super hier gewichtheber mensch nicht nicht viel sein aber man darf ja
nicht vergessen die dinger sind die sind ja auch noch mal so 60 70 zentimeter
lang ja und wenn du dir jetzt vielleicht nicht gerade da unten einbaust sondern
da bleibt nurcendig einen angècesiefer gibt und wo hogsburg mit aktuellem
saison würde ich danken haben wie man teilweise server ein bisschen weiter
oben irgendwo das ist alleine wirklich kacke 30 kilo mit oder ich würde mal
sagen mit akkus oder weil ohne wer verdammt schwer
28 aber was es kostet bei ihm wenig was 0,1 cent die kilowattstunde übrigens der
hat das nicht verstanden wussten dass woigen das kommentar von ihm wo steht das hier mit dem größte commentopes-podcast.com
das hier mit dem größte Comment goo.be
von ihm mit dem stromverbrauch da will nämlich da will ich nämlich was zu sagen
weil es ein gutes beispiel ist für ja also das da ist was was viele leute
schreiben was aber grundsätzlich falsch ist kilowattstunden ist nicht kilowatt
pro stunde ich muss jetzt hier mal den ober den
oberlehrer machen sondern es ist mal stunde also das ist das ist keine
geschwindigkeit oder irgendwie sowas das ist eine energiemenge wenn das so
willst das ist nicht kilowatt durch stunde das ist kilowatt mal stunde also
quasi das was das ganze gerade verbraucht mal eine stunde
ich sehe das total oft dass kw durch h geschrieben wird aber eigentlich ist es
entweder kw h oder eben kw mal stunde klingt das mal so als ergibt sinn
weil das ist ja das ist ja das ist ja das ist ja das ist ja das ist ja das ist ja
weil man kennt ja auch kilometer pro stunde also durch durch durch stunde
aber es ist damit gemeint dass das mal die ganze das ist die ganze stunde lang
wenn das die ganze stunde lang läuft dann certified lots foam
gucke mal also ich zeige dir jetzt mal was ich sage also moment so
Also, also, guck mal her.
Educational.
Da muss ich manchmal, wenn ich diesen Tag verwende, muss ich manchmal schon educational sein.
Das ist richtig.
Was ist Jules Durchzeit, ja, Durchsekunde, ja.
Das ist korrekt, ich sehe schon, wir haben ja wieder den Big Brain Chat.
Ja, gut, ähm, das weiß ich nicht, wie ich da drauf gekommen bin,
aber das ist, das sehe ich, das sehe ich ziemlich oft, dass da KW Durchstunde steht.
So, alter.
Guck dir das mal an.
Was ist da oben, der Aluhut, oder?
Ah, da hat der Abzug für die Klimaanlage.
Gut, wenn du sowas ohne hast, dann brauchst du auch eine Klimaanlage.
Boah, alter, übertreib's mal.
Aber es sieht aus wie bei uns früher im Rechenzentrum.
Weil dort, wo ich noch beim Provider gearbeitet habe, das war ja so die Zeit ungefähr,
als diese Hardware gerade top aktuell war, was er hat.
Genau so sah das damals im, im, so einem Rack aus.
Und was heute auch noch so ist, man wird heute, das sage ich ja jedes Mal,
man wird heute immer noch verdammt viel VGA-Ausgänge sehen.
Also, Rechenzentrum, was das angeht, da bewegt sich die Zeit äußerst langsam.
Ne, die sind, die sind aus.
Die sind einfach, einfach nur vorhanden, die Server, dass es cooler aussieht.
Also hier sind die Server alle, allesamt, okay, hier oben.
Die, die unten hier sind alle aus, hier ist nur was.
Aber der hat's echt mega übertrieben, ey.
Aber Moment, es reicht noch nicht.
Es reicht noch nicht, da hat er, der hat daneben, der hat daneben nochmal ne Mini-Rack stehen.
Das ist doch zu wenig.
Wird knapp, Kapazitätsprobleme.
Er kommt langsam an die Grenze, glaube ich.
Ich meine, er könnte die ganzen Server, die aus sind, ausbauen, nur das andere Zeug da rein.
Additional Storage für was?
VNX?
Was ist VNX?
Storage?
Was ist, was ist VNX?
Es sagt mir nix als Abkürzung.
Heimkino?
Was?
Ne, oder?
Das wird doch nicht Heimkino-Storage sein.
Doch, Plex!
Es ist tatsächlich Heimkino.
Plex!
Der hat gerade gesagt, hat gerade gesagt Plex.
Plex?
Er braucht einfach mal ein komplettes Plex-Rack.
Was haben die Leute eigentlich?
Das ist immer truff, wenn ich mir einen Film angucke, gucke ich mir mal bei Amazon, äh, irgendwie Prime einen Film an oder so, oder bei Netflix, ich würde gar nicht auf die Idee kommen, so was Unbedeutendes wie Filme lokal zu speichern.
Kostet viel zu viel Geld und Speicherplatz.
Wenn es doch gerade Filmestreaming easy gibt.
Was ich mir speichern würde, ist keine Ahnung, wenn ich irgendwie Filme von der Familienfeier oder irgendwas habe, was ich für die Nachwelt aufheben will oder für mich, dass ich es mein 20er angucken kann.
Okay, aber das hat er da ja nicht drauf.
Der hat, der hat da bestimmt nur...
...legal gezogene Blu-Ray-Sicherheitskopien drauf.
12 Dollar das Stück, ja gut, den Scheiß will ja auch keiner mehr haben.
Also was heißt Scheiß, das Zeug ist immer noch gut, ja?
Der Kram ist gebaut, um, äh, zu funktionieren.
Der hat nur Linux-ISOs drauf, über Torrent, der zieht nur Linux-ISOs über Torrent, ja.
Aber eins muss man schon sagen, man, man merkt, dass...
...man merkt es im ganzen Video an, dass er seinen Rack schon sehr geil findet.
Kann er ja auch, ist ja auch ordentlich, äh, was er da, was er da hat.
Ich meine, zwar ziemlich sinnlos, denke ich mal, aber nice.
Kassascheiße.
Lull.
Leute, ich geh was essen, ich hab Hunger.
Wir sehen uns eventuell heute, ähm, Mittag wieder.
Da programmieren wir ein bisschen weiter.
Ähm, und machen, äh, versuchen, versuchen...
...in, ähm, diese Kamera...
...Übersicht einzubauen, dass der Personen erkennen kann in einzelnen Bildern.
Das funktioniert.
Alles klar, Leute, wir sehen uns.
Macht's gut, bis später oder bis morgen, mal gucken.
In der Uhrzeit kann ich dir noch nichts sagen, absolut keine Ahnung.
Also, bis denn, macht's gut, see you.